le pouls de la manifestation parisienne
sur le terrain où nous attendent les
deux équipes de Figaro live Damien
caniveys en tête de cortège et puis bien
sûr Vincent roseron qui ira lui
recueillir les différentes réactions des
responsables politiques on ira à leur
poser toutes nos questions on ira leur
poser vos questions puisque vous
connaissez le principe n'hésitez pas à
réagir dans le chat sur le site du
Figaro et puis bien sûr depuis notre
chaîne Youtube je relierai tous vos
commentaires je vous donne un aperçu du
programme de l'après-midi le voici nous
sommes avec Claire conduite conduite
pardon du service politique pour
commencer nous serons ensuite avec amour
écoutant c'est du service actualité
Thomas en grand qui viendra nous parler
de cette réunion hier de l'Inter
syndicale avec Elizabeth borne à
Matignon Christophe corneven également
viendra nous faire un point sur le
dispositif de sécurité cet après-midi on
reparlera politique ensuite avec Carl
meus Arthur bijouta et viendra nous
donner les premières estimations ensuite
Mary Viso pour le point économie ça ce
sera aux alentours de 16h Dina Cohen
ensuite du service politique et puis
Guillaume roquette qui viendra nous
donner son analyse et puis bien sûr on
enchaînera sur point de vue on est
ensemble jusqu'à 18h20 minimum et avant
de me tourner vers clair conduite du
service politique clair qui est déjà là
en plateau avec moi on va tout de suite
aller voir sur le terrain ce qui nous ce
qui nous attend Vincent roseron quel est
l'ambiance sur place
et bien cette ambiance de début de manif
c'est là comme vous l'a dit c'est la 11e
manifestation ici à Paris depuis janvier
contre la réforme des retraites je le
trouve actuellement vous pouvez le voir
à l'avant de ce cortège là où il y a
l'intersyndical vous voyez tous ces
drapeaux CGT CFDT solidaire Sud Rail ils
sont tous ensemble à l'intérieur et
rester unis et il se ils ont voilà ils
commencent d'ailleurs justement à
avancer cette interdicale qui s'est
exprimée il y a quelques instants
alors est-ce qu'on a une idée sur
d'abord sur ce qui s'est dit dans cette
réunion de l'intersyndicale Vincent
alors sur ce qui s'est dit à la Réunion
pas grand chose alors la Réunion voulait
dire ce qui s'est passé là ce qui vient
de se passer à l'instant de ce qui s'est
dit il y a Laurent Berger alors on va se
décaler un peu puisque il y a les
services de sécurité qui nous poussent
un peu forcément puisque c'est le début
du cortège Laurent Berger qui a persisté
avec ses propos en disant voilà
aujourd'hui il y a une forme de crise
démocratique et une crise à l'égard des
institutions ce qu'il avait déjà dit
hier et qui avait
hérité le chef des propos qui avait
hérité le chef de l'État et son
entourage et puis vous ça a été souligné
aussi en début de manifestation c'est la
première manifestation de Sophie Binet
en tant que secrétaire général de la CGT
et elle aussi a été offensive en disant
que le gouvernement était complètement
déconnecté il fait comme si de rien
n'était il vit dans une réalité
parallèle à tel affirmée il n'y a pas
d'autre issu que le retrait de cette
réforme voilà pour les deux principaux
syndicats de cette manifestation qui se
sont exprimés en début de manifestation
et vous voyez ce cortège sur les images
de math iste Flora qui m'accompagne avec
la CFDT qui ouvre la route sur ce
cortège qui démarre petit à petit en
partant des Invalides le cortège qui
semble donc en train de s'élancer est-ce
qu'on a est-ce que vous pouvez nous
faire un petit point sur et bien le
parcours que vous emprunter les
manifestants cet après-midi Vincent
oui alors c'est un parcours qui a déjà
été à peu près utilisé lors de la
manifestation c'est à dire qu'on part
d'invalides et on arrive Place d'Italie
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron on
viendra à vous chercher bien sûr tout au
long de l'après-midi vous n'hésitez pas
également à nous appeler dès qu'il se
passe quelque chose clair qu'on rit
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec le du
service politique du Figaro car je le
disais en introduction ça fait
maintenant 16 jours que le texte a été
adopté dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale qu'attend les syndicats de
cette onzième journée de mobilisation
que peuvent-ils encore espérer
aujourd'hui bah alors simplement pour
recontextualiser un petit peu là cette
mobilisation intervient au lendemain
quand même d'une réunion à Matignon
entre les partenaires sociaux et
Elisabeth borne une réunion qui s'est
soldée en tout cas pour les syndicats
naturellement par un échec
si vous voulez vous avez deux entités
qui se sont retrouvés et qui ne voulait
pas les mêmes choses le gouvernement
l'exécutive veut absolument passer à la
séquence suivante les syndicats exigent
le retrait du projet de loi et donc même
si a priori la mobilisation étant est en
baisse comparativement naturellement au
premier mobilisation mais même à la
mobilisation il y a deux semaines
on peut peut-être prendre le pari que ce
dialogue de sourd d'hier
puisse en quelque sorte dopé
la manifestation et les contestations
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
syndicats après cette réunion ils ont
effectivement dit eux-mêmes que c'était
un échec solo en tout cas quelle est
leur état d'esprit aujourd'hui
tous ces tous ces particules cristallisé
après la réunion et même ce matin avec
un un Laurent Berger extrêmement remonté
qui a parlé qui parle non plus seulement
d'une crise sociale mais d'une crise
démocratique ce qui veut pas un petit
peu loin là en tout cas l'entourage les
d'Emmanuel Macron réfutent totalement
naturellement comment dire cette cette
formule
qu'on entend à gauche et puis des
semaines que qui a une crise institution
institutionnelle qui est la manipulation
des outils parlementaires pour faire
passer cette loi et donc cette tension
entre à Laurent Berger Emmanuel Macron
et tel enfin si vous écoutiez leur
envergers ce matin sur RTL
je veux dire il était partiellement
remonté disant que il fallait pas
qu'Emmanuel Macron voir ses propos
inattaque personnelle et que et que là
il fallait absolument trouver la voie de
l'apaisement
au chef de l'été est-ce que le dialogue
est encore possible à ce stade entre
l'exécutif et les syndicats alors même
que le rang berger de la CFDT est plutôt
réputé pour être ouvert ou dialogue
plutôt réformiste
vachement vu de ce qu'on entend
depuis la bouche de Laurent Berger ce
matin
c'est quand même très tendu vous avez en
parallèle l'exécutif qui fait un peu la
tournée des plateaux télé en assurant
que le dialogue est renoué que qu'on ne
fera rien sans les partenaires sociaux
qu'on ne passera pas en force etc mais
force est de constater que voilà il y a
une rupture de discours évidente
qu'est-ce qu'on va retenir finalement
donc de cette de cette rencontre d'hier
plutôt le côté échec ça c'est en tout
cas la communication des syndicats ou
plutôt ce que dit Elisabeth band c'est à
dire on se parle on dialogue c'est un
début
c'est c'est ça dépend votre point de vue
non on retiendra que c'est un échec de
fin à partir du moment où vous avez des
entités syndicales qui le retrait d'un
projet de loi et que visiblement de
façon ne bougera pas du côté de
l'exécutif on assure que la voix
démocratique a été empruntée et qu'il y
a plus de sujets qu'on est allé jusque
la motion de censure qui n'a pas été
adopté à 9 fois près cependant mais
voilà on est de justesse mais qu'on est
allé au bout et que maintenant voilà il
faut passer à autre chose entre
guillemets j'entends ce que vous dites
mais vous parliez de ce féminer la
nouvelle patronne de la CGT elle avait
brandi la menace du rang d'une rencontre
qui pouvait durer 5 minutes si jamais ça
se passait mal finalement une heure de
rencontre bon c'est pas non plus la
panacée mais ce qu'elle a pas évité au
moins l'humiliation Elisabeth borne hier
oui je peux je pense pas qu'on puisse
parler d'humiliation ça c'est c'est
certain et de toute façon
toute cette séquence politique est un
peu mise en suspens parce que la
prochaine étape de toute manière c'est
les conclusions du Conseil
constitutionnel que tout le monde attend
pour vendredi prochain voilà le 14 avril
et qui va se prononcer sur voilà la
recevabilité de la loi des outils
parlementaires qui ont été qui ont été
utilisés et qui va aussi se prononcer
sur le référendum d'initiative partagée
demander par la gauche notamment qui
voilà
vise à solliciter directement le
l'opinion des Français sur le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite en
faisant deux ans sur sur Elisabeth borne
j'y reviens je me permets d'insister
est-ce que c'est pas déjà une victoire
pour elle le fait que les
l'intersyndical est accepté de venir
s'asseoir autour de la table est-ce que
c'était pas gagné il y a encore une
semaine non c'est vrai il y a pas il y a
pas une rupture totale
en même temps elle a veillé à garder une
forme d'ouverture avant le rendez-vous
elle disait que tous les sujets pourront
être abordés que voilà et naturellement
elle elle veut rentrer dans une séquence
parler de la qualité de vie au travail
donc ils ont pas dû s'étendre très
longtemps sur la réforme des retraites
mais elle a essayé si vous voulez
jusqu'au bout de de maintenir cette
porte ouverte sur l'air très de les deux
camps sont toujours autant impossibles
ah bah les deux camps à gauche droite
vous voulez dire
la gauche est inflexible c'est pas de
comment dire de paix entre guillemets
avant leur stress et pour reprendre je
pense l'une de leurs formules
ne passeront pas à autre chose tant que
maman n'a pas retiré la mesure d'âge des
64 ans non il ne passeront pas à autre
chose
je vous dis tout dépend de ce que dira
le Conseil constitutionnel s'il y aura
un référendum derrière et côté LR
de toute façon la direction du moins et
pour la réforme donc alors il y a eu des
dissensions au sein du groupe c'est
certain vous
groupe autour de rien Pradier notamment
mais bon côté LR et puis en plus
l'exécutif si vous écoutiez si vous
lisiez Clément Beaune il y a quelques
jours dans les colonnes de je sais plus
d'un côté de Libé ou de je ne sais plus
mais Clément Beaune qui disait bon on va
pas s'enfermer dans un dialogue avec
elle parce que visiblement pour nous
c'est pas un partenaire politique très
fiable on va revenir sur cette question
des républicains avec vous Clark horoute
mais avant cela on va faire un tour du
côté du terrain où on retrouve Vincent
roseron Vincent vous confirmez que le
cortège s'était lancé
alors j'ai l'impression que Vincent ne
nous entend pas on va on va le joindre
tout à l'heure on va le rappeler bien
sûr justement sur cette question des sur
cette question des républicains clairs
conduite on voit mal c'est la mission
qui a donné Emmanuel Macron et Elisabeth
borne d'élargir la majorité c'est vrai
qu'on les voit mal les républicains
baptisé et faire une alliance avec la
majorité maintenant au pire des moments
où au moment de la majorité se trouve
dans une situation très délicate mais
c'est pour ça que vous avez aussi l'aile
gauche de la majorité qui dit
il faut qu'on parvienne à créer une
majorité aussi à gauche et notamment
avec les socialistes
même avec les écolos sur certaines lois
enfin en tout cas c'est un argument qui
qui revient et donc effectivement il
faut continuer selon une partie de de la
macronie de mener les discussions de
convaincre texte par texte
projet par projet et ne pas s'enfermer
pour reprendre les mots de Clément bonne
dans un dialogue unique avec alerte on
voit les images qui nous parviennent de
cette manifestation qui s'est donc
élancée on voit à l'instant le cortège
de la de la CFDT avec notamment ses
ballons orange Vincent roseron est avec
nous de nouveau Vincent vous confirmez
le cortège s'était lancé
[Musique]
oui effectivement vous voyez le Cantal
s'est lancé beaucoup de bruit je vous ai
pas entendu tout à l'heure effectivement
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de musique
forcément là vous voyez la scène était
métallurgie qui est en train de passer à
côté de nous avec voilà et on est au
niveau du Parti socialiste parce que
vous le savez tout au long du cortège il
y a aussi les partis politiques qui sont
là et qui discute avec les gens tout au
long de ce côté on essaiera d'avoir
leurs réaction mais en tout cas voilà ce
cortège qui est parti les premiers
camions qui défilent et c'est la CFDT
qui a débuté cette manifestation
merci beaucoup Vincent rose on continue
bien sûr de venir vous chercher dès
qu'il se passe quelque chose clair qu'en
vite sur cette sur cette question là de
d'élargir la majorité ces missions
impossible pour les événements si vous
voulez en tout cas
côté gauche au vu de la manière dont les
consultations ont été menées ou pas
d'ailleurs ces derniers jours ça va être
très compliqué entre
les communistes qui ont voulu marcher
jusque l'Elysée pour remettre une lettre
à Emmanuel Macron lui demandant
solennellement de retirer sa loi entre
les insoumis qui qui
étaient devant le Conseil
constitutionnel pour un peu faire de la
faire mousser un peu cette idée que tout
repose désormais sur les sages et en
effet vous avez alors vous avez les
social et vous avez les socialistes et
les écologistes qui qui sont allés
Tondelier
séparément toutefois et mind Tondelier
par exemple il est allé en précisant en
précisant nous on n'y va pas pour parler
de la réforme des retraites parce que de
toute façon on s'attend rien mais elle y
allait surtout pour parler de l'état du
pays et des violences et donc on voit
quand même
qui a une rupture de dialogue qui est
pas surprenante mais voilà
définitivement pourquoi ils sont allés
séparément Olivier format montrer que
ils viennent pas dans le cadre de la
nups oui ils ont dit que c'était dans
une dans une logique républicaine bon de
il fallait sans doute en effet y aller
au titre du parti des du socialisme
d'abord puis écologie derrière merci
beaucoup d'être venu avec nous pour
lancer ce direct on continue on revint
chercher le terrain avec Damien Canivez
qui est qui est là également Damien
Kelly et quel est l'ambiance là où vous
vous trouvez à l'instant
bonjour cher Timothée effectivement je
me trouve à l'avant du cortège de la
manifestation qui s'était lancé
aujourd'hui à 14h dans les rues de Paris
nous étions esplanade des Invalides il y
a seulement quelques instants où nous
avons vu tout les syndicats qui étaient
présents de la CFDT à la CFTC en passant
par la CGT nous avons vu également le
CNT et nous avons passé à tête de
cortège syndical pour nous retrouver à
l'avant du cortège pour voir ce qu'il
s'y passait et comme vous pouvez le
constater sur les images de Julien
Leclerc et bien nous avons un cordon de
gendarme voilà une soixantaine de
gendarmes qui précèdent la manifestation
pour très certainement empêcher la
formation d'un prêt cortège de militants
radicaux puisque vous le savez très bien
depuis que nous couvrons ces
manifestations sur Figaro live
régulièrement il y a des éléments
radicaux des manifestants violents qui
se rassemblent devant le cortège
syndical et c'est policiers qui sont
venus en nombre et qui précèdent la
marche permettent justement de ne pas
assister à ce genre de rassemblement
violent c'est assez nouveau parce que
jusque là en tout cas jusqu'au 28 mars
dernier nous n'assistions pas forcément
cette doctrine des forces de l'ordre les
forces de l'ordre étaient invisibles
placées dans des rues souvent parallèles
à l'itinéraire prévu par par la
préfecture de police de Paris et depuis
maintenant la semaine dernière et bien
des forces de l'ordre sont très visibles
et sont en nombre devant le cortège
syndical les rangs des manifestants sont
assez clairsemés on devrait peut-être se
retrouver dans un chiffre qui avoisinera
celui du 15 mars dernier lorsque
justement les manifestants c'était
relancés à l'époque c'était également
Place des Invalides direction la place
d'Italie
merci beaucoup Damien Canivez et tout de
suite on rejoint notre deuxième équipe
sur le terrain Vincent Roson qui est
avec Olivier Faure Vincent c'est à vous
oui effectivement Timothée je suis avec
Olivier fort monsieur fort merci d'être
avec nous comment déjà vous jugez la
manifester les forces en présence
aujourd'hui le nombre de personnes dans
la rue
vous avez rencontré la première ministre
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est sorti de
cette réunion pour vous et là c'est la
même chose qu'avec sanica c'est à dire
que elle est dans une situation où je
l'ai senti en fait à se dépassé avec un
pouvoir qui a fuit Matignon pour
regagner l'Élysée si tenté qu'il ait un
jour quitté l'Élysée et donc sans aucun
moyen de répondre à quoi que ce soit et
même je vais sentir certains moments
dans une forme d'hésitation et peut-être
même
était-elle en fait dans un service
commandé qu'il oblige à rester
inflexible parce que je crois qu'elle
peut comprendre que son sang personnel
mais même le sort de ce quinquennat est
lié à cette réforme et que si le
président obstine il n'aura peut-être
nulle part il y en aura plus dans le
monde politique parce que ni à gauche ni
à droite personne ne voudra discuter
avec quelqu'un qui est de toute façon
considéré à ses partenaires éventuels
comme des collectif et pas davantage
dans le monde social ou qu'un syndicat
ne voudra plus négocier avec avec ce
gouvernement qui les méprisent donc
chacun est terminé et la seule façon
d'arriver à autre chose de renouer avec
la possibilité d'avancer de trouver
d'autres possibilités c'est soit le
retrait soit le retour devant les
Français et le retour des Français c'est
soit par le biais d'un référendum soit
par le biais de la dissolution mais ça
vous y croyez une dissolution
aujourd'hui mais je ne crois rien je dis
simplement que si le président vraiment
reçoiviné est considère que il a un
mandat pour cela et bien qu'il le
vérifie et qu'il fasse le choix de le
demander par l'avoir et faire un air ou
par une dissolution qui obligerait les
Français à se déterminer sous cette
réforme mais on voit bien que ça n'est
pas du tout la voix qu'il choisit n'est
pas sur la voie démocratique il est sur
la voie qui est celle de l'autorité et
parce que la Constitution lui confère
des droits des pouvoirs qui sont
exorbitants et bien ils utilisent tous
ces uns après les autres pour au fond
imposer une vision qui est une vision
solitaire il y a une date et abondance
c'est celle du Conseil constitution du
Constitutionnel
est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas à la fin du
processus après justement cette décision
du Conseil constitutionnel mais non
parce que le Conseil constitutionnel va
dire quoi elle va dire est-ce que ce qui
c'est ce projet de loi est conforme ou
non à la constitution non mais je pense
qu'il y a de très nombreux motifs
d'invalidation mais même si le Conseil
émotionnel n'a valide pas ça ne veut pas
dire que il est justifié sur le plan
social sur le plan politique sur le plan
tout simplement humain et donc nous
continuerons à nous battre y compris
parce que nous les essaierons de le
faire par le biais du référendum des
actif partagé et c'est comme ça que nous
imposerons le référendum malgré tout au
président de la République puisque moi
je pense que nous trouvons les 4,7
millions de signatures qui permettent de
d'exiger du président un référendum sur
cette réforme
merci beaucoup monsieur voilà vous
l'avez entendu Olivier Faure qui appelle
de ses vœux lui soit une dissolution
soit une retrait de cette réforme
forcément mais il peut demander aussi
une dissolution de la semaine ou un
référendum que de nombreux que de pardon
excusez-moi que de nombreux
manifestants demandent aussi sur un
référendum d'initiative partagée
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron bonjour
Amaury bouton
du service actualité du Figaro Amaury
Olivier Faure qui parle de ce retour
c'est l'importance de ce retour devant
les Français vous allez couvert un
certain nombre de manifestations depuis
le début du mouvement contestation c'est
quelque chose que que qui revient quand
vous parlez avec les manifestants la
question d'une éventuelle dissolution
d'un éventuel référendum d'initiative
partagée je pense que même plus
globalement et au-delà les manifestants
avec lesquels j'ai pu discuter remettre
en cause la légitimité du président de
la République et par la même des
institutions c'est-à-dire qui ne
considère pas qu'Emmanuel Macron est
légitime pour parler en leur nom bien
qu'il ait été élu par une majorité de
Français à la dernière élection
présidentielle quand tu aurais fait un
homme d'initiative partagée dans la
dernière manifestation c'est-à-dire
après l'activation par Elisabeth borne
de l'Artic 49.3 de la Constitution c'est
quelque chose qui a été beaucoup évoqué
comme pouvant redonner un peu de
démocratie participative et de pouvoir
aux citoyens alors que le Président de
la République a été élu moi ce que ça me
rappelle surtout c'est que c'est un peu
la quand même revendication que le RIC
pendant les gilets jaunes que pour
lesquels on avait déjà pu discuter
effectivement on sent un
une volonté parmi les citoyens de
retrouver une forme de pouvoir qu'il ne
sent pas incarnée par les institutions
de la 5ème république quand vous voyez
c'est ces images cet après-midi quelles
évolutions est-ce que vous vous observez
par rapport au premier journée de
mobilisation c'était au mois de janvier
je pense que la première chose qu'il
faut noter c'est la présence de plus en
plus nombreuses de jeunes de personnes
qui ont moins de 25 ans qui soient
étudiants ou lycéens dans les premières
manifestations ce qui me frappait
énormément c'est que c'était beaucoup
plus tôt beaucoup plus un cortège
syndical classique avec des gens qui
sont affiliés à telle ou tel syndicat
mais également quelques familles au fur
et à mesure c'est ces personnes là il y
en a eu de moins en moins on pensait
également qu'il y ait eu un coup pour
ces gens puisque la grève a un coût
syndiqué à un coût pour les gens qui
vont manifester c'est quand même la
onzième journée de manifestation je
pense également que aujourd'hui ça fait
presque deux semaines que il n'y a pas
une manifestation je pense que les
mouvements les mouvements syndicaux ont
voulu temporiser un peu le temps de
redonner du souffle aux gens et on l'a
vu les services de renseignement
annoncent entre 6 à 700 000 personnes
c'est quand même pas négligeable c'est
pas négligeable au niveau des jeunes
aussi est-ce que on a une idée du nombre
de jeunes qui sont attendus dans les
rues que ce soit de la capitale mais
également les rues des grandes villes de
France où ça manifeste cet après-midi
j'ai pas de chiffres précis à vous
communiquer quand elle au nombre de
jeunes qui vont manifester moi ce qui me
paraît quand même assez important à
noter et on l'avait déjà vu le 28 mars
dernier c'est que un certain nombre de
facultés et d'université qui n'ont pas
de tradition de blocage ont été bloqués
Lyon 3 la faculté d'Assas qui est quand
même été très longtemps à bastion de de
la droite subi des blocages encore ce
matin je pense que il y a au-delà de la
contestation de la réforme des retraites
chez les jeunes plus globalement une
volonté de rejet d'un système
capitaliste d'un rejet d'un système où
le travail est au cœur de la réalisation
d'un être humain ça c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment rejeté je pense que et
c'est il te dit par des gens bien plus
compétents que moi mais le travail ne
fait donc plus partie d'un projet de vie
de réalisation de soi et c'est ce
pourquoi les jeunes se manifestent sur
la mobilisation des jeunes en tout cas
on a le sentiment qui a eu un début et
un après 49-3 vous qui avez couvert
plusieurs manifestations à partir de
quel moment est-ce que vous avez senti
que les jeunes se sont joints à ce
mouvement à ces manifestations contre
les retraites immédiatement après le
déclenchement de l'artica9.3 sur la
place de la Concorde on a vu tout un tas
de manifestations spontanées et de gens
qui sont venus pour manifester leur
opposition au déclenchement de cet
article de la Constitution par la
première ministre c'était très
majoritairement des personnes jeunes
sont des personnes jeunes également qui
ont continué les manifestations
spontanées dans les jours qui ont suivi
pour moi c'est vraiment le déclenchement
de l'article 49-3 qui est signifié la
mobilisation des jeunes mais encore une
fois au-delà de la du du de la réforme
des retraites je pense que les jeunes se
manifestent contre un pouvoir dans il ne
se reconnaissent pas ou en tout cas une
pratique du pouvoir dans lequel il ne se
reconnaissent pas qu'il juge et qu'il
qualifie d'autoritaire
cette rejet de la pratique du pouvoir
par Emmanuel Macron et également cela
dit partagé par un certain nombre de
personnes dans les cortège syndicaux je
pense que ce qui a également mobilisé
les gens au-delà du 49-3 ça a été la
fameuse phrase d'Emmanuel Macron sur les
factieux c'est quelque chose qui revient
beaucoup on peut le lire sur les
panneaux sur sur les pancartes etc et
lorsque l'on discute avec les gens les
gens qui manifestent nous disent voilà
moi je ne me reconnais pas non seulement
dans cette réforme non seulement dans ce
pouvoir mais en plus j'ai l'impression
que ce pouvoir me méprise et c'est pour
ça que je suis dans la rue aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est Emmanuel Macron qui est
qui conteste ou est-ce que c'est le
système en général je pense que ces
manifestants jeunes par les manifestants
jeunes c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
large en effet vous avez raison de le
souligner c'est effectivement un système
dans lequel il ne se reconnaissent pas
lorsque l'on discute encore une fois
avec ces jeunes qui ont autour de la
vingtaine ce sont quand même des gens
qui ont soit passé le bac pendant la
période covid soit qui ont subi ça dans
leur première année dans leur première
année d'études et qui ont l'impression
d'avoir eu deux ans de voler et il me
disent ils le disent aussi franchement
que ça on m'a volé 2 ans avec le covid
pourquoi est-ce que je redonnerai deux
ans à la société avec un report de l'âge
de la retraite quel est le ton de ces de
ces manifestants les jeunes et les moins
jeunes est-ce que on est aujourd'hui
dans une forme de résignation parce que
finalement on est déjà à ce 11e cette
onzième journée de manifestation vous
l'avez dit ça un coup alors pour les
jeunes peut-être un peu moins les pour
les étudiants mais enfin ça coûte cher
de faire des de faire des grèves et puis
est-ce qu'on est dans cette résignation
ou bien est-ce qu'on dit non au
contraire on est combatif on ne lâchera
rien je ne crois pas je pense vraiment
que l'état d'esprit qui prédomine chez
les manifestants et beaucoup plus
combatifs à la fois pour les raisons que
nous avons évoqué précédemment à savoir
la sensation d'être dépossédés mais
également la sensation d'être méprisé
par le gouvernement et enfin je pense
que le mouvement syndical a joué assez
habilement en écartant progressivement
les dates des manifestations afin de
pouvoir laisser les gens rep
il n'y a pas véritablement
d'organisation syndicale qui structure
complètement ces mouvements de jeunes
contrairement aux gens un peu plus âgés
qui sont encadrés qui parlent la sfdt
qui parlent la CGT qui par sudrive par
exemple le je pense que vraiment chez
les jeunes il y a surtout un rejet de
leur de leur quotidien Aujourd'hui de
leur de ce qu'il considère comme du
mépris du gouvernement mais de là avoir
un projet politique derrière je suis pas
certain que ce soit formé le site
clairement en revanche les les
problématiques écologiques mais
également les problématiques sociales
sont très souvent abordés de manière un
peu différente bien sûr mais les
solutions sont assez éparses et personne
n'arrive véritablement à s'accorder soit
sur une tête d'affiches qui pourrait
rassembler tous ces jeux de manifestants
soit sur un programme commun allez on va
aller voir Vincent roseron sur place
Vincent on parlait justement de cette
mobilisation des jeunes est-ce que c'est
le cas cet après-midi est-ce que vous en
avez croisé beaucoup
[Musique]
derrière dans un cortège et quand vous
reviendrez vers nous je on essaiera d'en
avoir avec nous aussi
on va essayer effectivement d'aller les
interroger on va demander à nos
journalistes sur place d'aller leur
bander pourquoi ils sont ils sont
mobilisés en tous les cas à morue
coutant c'est perversaire cette
mobilisation des jeunes n'a finalement
pas changé grand chose est-ce que est-ce
que c'est crédible est-ce que le
gouvernement scrute cela de près les
blocages de lycée d'université ou bien
finalement est-ce que on a le sentiment
que bah ça va ça n'a rien changé avec
cette cette mobilisation de la jeunesse
c'est peut-être un peu chimique mais je
pense que les gouvernements successifs
français ont été très habitués à une
mobilisation de la jeunesse et à des
blocages d'université ou de lycée ne
serait-ce que si on remonte quelques
années en arrière à la loi travail de
Myriam el khomri en 2016 déjà il y avait
eu de nombreux blocages et finalement la
loi avait été tout de même adoptée
d'ailleurs par 49-3 également je pense
pas que une mobilisation de la jeunesse
modifie la titre du gouvernement quant à
l'adoption de cette réforme je rappelle
quand même que ça a été un engagement de
campagne du président de la République
qui capitalisait énormément sur cette
sur cette réforme ne serait-ce que pour
avoir une crédi budgétaire donc je ne
pense pas malheureusement pour ces
manifestants que leur mobilisation fera
reculer le gouvernement je pense quand
même que c'est un signal important
puisque cette forte mobilisation de la
jeunesse doit également interpeller les
observateurs politiques puisque s'ils
sont mobilisés aujourd'hui sur la
réforme de retraite demain sur une autre
ou une autre ou une autre réforme il est
possible quand même c'est en tout cas
mon sentiment qu'il y a une génération
qui est très sensibilisée aux gens eux
en vous enjeux pardon écologiques et
sociaux et qui poursuivra sa
mobilisation au fur et à mesure des
années à venir un mot peut-être à mon
écoute en séparaker sur l'ampleur de la
mobilisation vu de loin comme ça on a
évidemment pas encore les chiffres mais
on a le sentiment qu'il y a du monde
dans les rues de Paris et dans les rues
de France aujourd'hui oui vraiment
énormément de monde le Le Figaro
infographié a commencé à recenser un peu
partout au moins 200 000 personnes à
travers la France qui est quand même
assez considérable pour l'heure à
laquelle nous parlons dans la journée je
rappelle quand même quelques chiffres le
19 janvier la première mobilisation les
syndicats avaient annoncé deux millions
de manifestants le 7 mars 3 millions et
demi le 23 mars également 3 millions et
demi des chiffres et une ampleur de la
mobilisation qui n'avait pas fait
reculer le gouvernement néanmoins je
crois que le déclenchement de l'article
49-3 à poursuivi en tout cas à favoriser
le sentiment de mobilisation chez ces
manifestants et qui veulent encore une
fois lutter contre ce que nous évoquions
tout à l'heure à savoir ce qu'il juge
comme étant du mépris de la part du
gouvernement merci beaucoup
service actualités d'être venu nous
donner vos éléments vous qui avez
couvert on l'a dit plusieurs de ces de
ces manifestations on va rejoindre sur
le terrain Damien Canivez reporter du
Figaro live cet après-midi Damien il
semble que vous soyez en présence de un
black bloc je ne sais pas mais enfin des
des manifestants avec des des volontés
un peu belliqueuses
ouais le mot est juste Timothée c'est
vrai que là je me trouve à mi-chemin
entre le cordon de gendarmerie dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure qui s'est
formé juste devant le pré-corpège pour
ainsi que assurer la sécurité des
manifestants et surtout éviter qu'un
pré-corpège d'éléments radicaux ne se
forment seulement ces policiers prient
beaucoup d'avance ils ont marché
quelques dizaines de mètres devant le
cortège syndical et bien des
manifestants radicaux et on en profitait
pour former ce qu'on appelle un black
bloc alors un black bloc on rappelle ce
que c'est c'est un groupe un
rassemblement de militants
essentiellement composés d'ultra gauche
et on peut les reconnaître assez
facilement à travers leur code c'est à
dire que en une fraction de seconde il
sorte des parapluies souvent noir
derrière sous lesquels ils peuvent se
dissimuler afin de se changer et de se
vêtir dans une couleur très uniforme
souvent la couleur noire couleur de
l'anarchie l'anarchisme dont il se
réclame et et voilà voilà vous entendez
ces tambours aussi ça fait partie de
leur code ils sont juste à côté de nous
c'est à dire qu'ils sont à quelques
dizaines de mètres de là ils sont assez
nombreux aujourd'hui vous voyez ce
parapluie arc-en-ciel aussi Qui est qui
est typique de ce mouvement c'est un
signe de ralliement pour indiquer que le
mouvement enfin que le black bloc se
trouve bien à cet endroit là pour
l'instant la manifestation reste calme
mais je tiens malgré tout à préciser
qu'il se forme extrêmement tôt dans la
manifestation parce que le 15 mars
dernier la dernière fois que nous sommes
partis de l'Esplanade des Invalides
direction Place d'Italie le Black Bloc
c'était formé beaucoup plus tard juste
devant l'hôpital Necker il avait fallu
attendre 1h30 voir deux heures avant que
ces militants radicaux ne se rassemblent
cette fois-ci seulement quelques minutes
après le départ officiel de la
manifestation et bien c'est militant
d'ultra gauche ce sont rassemblés et
pour le moment ne se limite qu'à jouer
de la musique vous entendez ces bruits
de temps bon juste derrière moi mais on
imagine bien que voilà leurs intentions
sont toutes autres le cortège syndical
n'est pas encore là par contre il est
encore bien loin on le voit pas vraiment
à l'horizon vous voyez le bâtiment enfin
le monument des Invalides en
arrière-plan il devra arriver dans les
toutes prochaines minutes nous sommes
justement boulevard des Invalides
merci beaucoup Damien Kany vs depuis le
boulevard des Invalides et j'accueille
Thomas en grand qui nous a rejoint dans
notre plateau bonjour Thomas Thomas ces
images de Black Box c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait moins vu lors
de du début du mouvement en tout cas ça
pouvait se former parfois comme le
disait Damien tard dans la manifestation
et c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment qu'au
fur et à mesure que et bien cette
mobilisation contre la réforme est
avancée dans le temps et bien ça s'est
tendu petit à petit oui clairement alors
ils existent depuis le début voilà
effectivement c'est là c'est je pense
que c'est la première fois je me suis
même sûr que c'est la première fois que
il se forme aussitôt d'habitude ils
arrivent en milieu de cortège enfin au
milieu de parcours le but effectivement
c'est que s'il se forme trop vite ils
sont trop facilement ciblables par la
police et on peut les enlever les
empêcher de nuire c'est un énorme
problème pour les syndicats eux-mêmes
puisque ils jouent une grande partie de
l'opinion publique sur le fait qu'ils
arrivent enfin même de leur légitimité
sur le fait qu'ils arrivent à organiser
des manifestations qui soient
respectueuses des biens et des personnes
comme ils disent et voilà et même des
fois ça déborde complètement il y a
quelques il y a deux jours enfin deux
journées de mobilisation donc c'était le
autour du 24 je crois c'est pas de
bêtises
des Black Blocs avec carrément réussi à
s'infiltrer à l'intérieur de la tête de
cortège résultats toute la tête de
cortège c'était un peu gazer et il
n'avait jamais voilà exactement 28 mars
n'avais jamais pu arriver à Place de
l'Opéra donc qui était normalement le
lieu enfin uni il n'avait pas pu arriver
jusqu'au bout du parcours donc
effectivement c'est un gros problème et
ça démontre effectivement une
radicalisation moins d'une partie de la
population et puis en fait d'une
situation sociale qui ne cesse de
stendre un gros problème pour les
syndicats un problème aussi pour les
responsables politiques certains d'entre
eux sont dans les cortèges cet
après-midi va-t-il panneau qui est avec
Vincent roseron la chef de fil des
députés la France insoumise à
l'Assemblée nationale Vincent je vous
laisse la parole
[Musique]
oui Timothée merci je suis avec panneau
merci d'être avec nous aujourd'hui déjà
comment vous juger les forces en
présence le nombre de manifestants
de ça on verra à la fin de la journée en
tout cas ce que je vois partout dans le
pays que ça soit en termes de blocage de
grève ou de manifestations c'est que
nous sommes à des niveaux très élevés de
mobilisation et c'est d'abord et avant
tout l'échec du gouvernement qui voulait
en quelque sorte tourner la page et
changer de discussion en disant que les
retraites c'était fini et qu'il fallait
bien aller discuter je ne sais quoi de
quelle loi grimigration de je ne sais
quoi et bien ce que sont en train de
dire les millions de Français qui sont
aujourd'hui mobilisés c'est que non nous
ne tournerons pas la page d'une réforme
qui touche dans les chair d'une réforme
qui va affecter des millions de Français
et les générations futures et que nous
continuons à demander le retrait de la
retraite à 64 ans puis il y a eu un
deuxième échec de ce gouvernement
puisqu'ils ont essayé là aussi d'aller
discuter avec les présidents de groupe
parlementaires aucun des groupes de la
nuit passée sont allés et avec l'Inter
syndicale et on l'a bien vu puisqu'ils
ont refusé de retirer la réforme des
retraites l'interphone ducale dans son
unité a refusé de continuer les
discussions
donc on est dans un moment où la
macronie est au fond du trou et elle
creuse encore avec en plus
un déni complet en disant que nous ne
sommes pas dans une crise démocratique
évidemment nous sommes dans une crise
sociale et démocratique et il ne reste
que deux options en pouvoir le retrait
ou le retour devant le peuple et si
aucune de ces deux options des des
choisies par exécutif après Conseil
constitutionnel vous avez déjà vu un
pouvoir qui vous explique qui va lâcher
jamais mais je veux dire il faut quand
même vous rendre compte vous avez un
président de la République
qui ne peut plus se déplacer dans son
propre pays ou alors s'il le fait il
avait déjà annulé le roi Charles III
annuler Toulon annuler le stade et quand
il l'a fait pour le plan haut il s'est
rendu en hélicoptère pour présenter le
plan o donc moi je veux bien qu'on nous
explique que le Président de la
République féministe et les
parlementaires macronistes restent
confinés pendant des mois et des mois
mais ça ne va pas tenir longtemps
première des choses deuxième chose la
situation de blocage et d'un passe dans
lequel nous sommes c'est le pouvoir
qu'il a créé c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
en est responsable donc maintenant il
faut trouver une sortie par le haut et
je le dis il n'y aura pas d'issue
policière à une crise politique je le
dis d'autant plus solennellement que des
organismes internationaux ont alerté sur
la question de l'ONU au Conseil de
l'Europe jusque aux grandes associations
des droits humains dans notre pays qui
s'inclette du glissement autoritaire de
ce pouvoir et je note avec satisfaction
que aujourd'hui le tribunal
administratif de Rouen a décidé
d'annuler les réquisitions sur la
raffinerie en Normandie en disant que
c'était une attein très grave au droit
de grève donc petit à petit on se visage
autoritaire du gouvernement et aussi lui
aussi en train de se dévoiler et je vous
le dis ce que nous disons aujourd'hui
c'est que nous nous arrêterons pas tant
que la loi ne sera pas retirée très bien
merci beaucoup
voilà pour cette réaction de la chef de
filtre des députés de la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
n'a-t-il panneau qui répondait au Figaro
live Thomas en gros on va revenir sur
cette question des syndicats que vous
suivez de près pour Le Figaro cette
réunion hier avec Elisabeth borne à
Matignon 55 minutes de réunion est-ce
qu'on a déjà des éléments sur
l'atmosphère dans laquelle s'est
déroulait cette cette réunion quel était
j'allais dire l'ambiance sur place alors
elle a été quand même respectueuse
certains saints inquiétés certains et
même menacés Sophie binaves menacé que
la Réunion pourrait durer 5 minutes
façon de dire que la pression voilà
mettre la pression et que c'est il
serait pas là pour parler des heures
s'il y avait pas d'avancé effectivement
donc elle a été respectueuse mais elle a
été très claire c'est-à-dire que les
syndicats étaient arrivés en disant nous
on est là pour parler de la du recul de
enfin du repos de repousser la loi sur
les retraites le gouvernement a été très
clair en disant que il ne le ferait pas
donc bon il y a eu un tour de table la
première ministre a par les différentes
organisations syndicales ont parlé dans
leur protocolaire en finissant toutes
par la même phrase madame la première
nuit liste êtes-vous prête à
reculer sur cette réforme à l'issue de
ce tour de table donc la première
ministre n'a pas répondu de questions a
voulu réembrayer sur la question de la
pénibilité du travail voilà donc elle
espérait mettre
dans la discussion
ce jour-là Laurent Bergel a interrompu
en lui disant on vous a posé une
question pouvez-vous y répondre et elle
a bien sûr répondu par la négative et
donc les syndicats sont levés et sont
partis donc ambiance assez tendu quand
même
enfin assez froid donc on va dire quand
même respectueuse mais froide voilà ça
pas été un peu de ville c'est ce que
craignait certains
voilà il paraît que alors bon moi c'est
vrai que j'ai plutôt les sources
syndicales qui disaient que la qui
disent que la première ministre a été
surpris quand même que des syndicats
n'hésitent pas à tous ensemble se lever
voilà de leur propre chef donc donc oui
bien on serait clair bon et puis après
sans surprise à la sortie les syndicats
en parler d'échecs
un terme qui a réfuté la première
ministre mais clairement en tout cas ça
n'a absolument pas permis d'avancer sur
cette question des 64 ans ça n'a pas
permis d'avancer ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que cette cette réunion elle
l'a servi à rien finalement
alors difficile à dire en tout cas sur
la question des des retraites
ça a été un désaccord qui était déjà
connu depuis depuis le début de la
contestation
après
c'était sûrement nécessaire quand même
qui reprennent la parole il s'était pas
rencontré depuis plusieurs mois c'était
notamment quelque chose dans ce
plaignait beaucoup les syndicats disant
qu'il n'y avait pas été reçu ils avaient
envoyé une lettre au président de la
République qui avait répondu en
expliquant que le gouvernement lui est à
disposition mais pas le président de la
République bref donc il fallait qu'elle
ait lieu elle était dans l'intérêt des
deux camps d'avoir lieu pour essayer de
montrer que chaque camp tentait de
tendre la main à l'autre elle a acté sur
un désaccord
voilà bon est-ce que c'était pas un peu
prévisible finalement c'était totalement
prévisible effectivement
certains syndicats me disent même que il
avait ils avaient reçu un coup de
téléphone du conseiller comme de
Matignon leur expliquant
leur confirmant ce qui ce dont tout le
monde dès que la première ministre
reviendrait pas surface 64 ans à partir
de là il pouvait pas se permettre
d'annuler la dernière minute ça aurait
fait mauvais genre mais bon
voilà et eux disent plutôt qu'en fait
cette réunion a plus servi c'est leur
avis à la première année ça a été testé
la solidité de l'Inter syndicale et que
bon ben ils ont en tout cas sur ce plan
là prouvé que il restait toujours
exactement sur le même longueur d'onde
toujours sur la même longueur d'onde
assez offensive très offensif le rang
berger par exemple le secrétaire général
de la CFDT qui dit on a une crise
sociale qui se transforme en crise
démocratique et ce qu'il n'en fait pas
un petit peu trop la loi en berger
il est lui il a il s'est il est
complètement devenu la tête de proue de
la contestation à la réforme des
retraites déjà il a été quasiment le
leader incontesté le seul qui arrivait à
être un peu reconnaissable sur ces
questions à part lui c'était Philippe
Martinez Philippe Martinez qui donc a
quitté son poste de secrétaire général
de la CGT pour le laisser à Sophie Binet
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a encore peu
connu qui doit se faire une place qui a
pas encore les user coutumes de la
contestation donc il doit
un peu être le porte-parole de toute
l'Inter syndicale donc en fait essayer
de ménager aussi les organisations
sociales les plus radicales un signe
très symbolique c'est qu'à l'issue du
tour de table quand la Première ministre
a voulu reprendre la parole lors de
réunion mercredi c'est Laurent Berger
qui l'a arrêté qui lui a posé la
question et actant le désaccord a mis
fin à la Réunion donc on sent clairement
que voilà c'est lui et qu'il a un rôle
qui dépasse en fait aujourd'hui
exclusivement SDT pour en fait être le
secrétaire général si je puis dire de 8
syndicats de salariés le robergé avec
qui c'est particulièrement illustré dans
cette dans cette séquence est-ce qu'ils
espèrent encore faire flancher le
gouvernement sur ces 64 ans
officiellement oui ils peuvent pas dire
le contraire et tout le monde a bien
compris que le gouvernement ne
reculerait plus alors eux continuent de
penser il y a quelques espoirs encore
qui sont fondés sur le Conseil
constitutionnel qui doit être rendre sa
réponse le 14 avril donc vendredi
prochain si je dis pas de bêtises bon
alors ça paraît quand même hautement
improbable que le Conseil
constitutionnel retoque largement
ce projet enfin cette loi maintenant ils
espèrent toujours aussi jouer sur le
fameux RIP le référendum d'initiative
partagée il pense que ça pourra être un
moyen d'objet le gouvernement enfin s'il
obtient les 4,8 millions de signatures à
revenir à la table des négociations donc
ils arrêtent pas le combat effectivement
est-ce que les grandes journées de
mobilisation vont être encore longtemps
d'actualité ça c'est très contestable
parce que il y a effectivement celle-là
il y en aura très certainement une
semaine prochaine et à ce probablement
jeudi prochain même si rien n'est décidé
mais depuis plusieurs semaines c'est
soit le mardi soit le jeudi le Conseil
constitutionnel donne sa réponse le
vendredi mardi c'est le retour du lundi
de Pâques il y a beaucoup d'éléments qui
laissent imaginer que soit il change
complètement de tactique entre
aujourd'hui et la semaine prochaine soit
le jeudi a quand même des arguments
solides derrière lui ça sera décidé ce
soir
voilà mais effectivement ça sera
peut-être la dernière ou l'avant
dernière
et après et après et d'ailleurs après
c'est intéressant parce que on voit
poindre les premiers désaccords assez
marquants au sein de l'intersyndicale
effectivement la CFDT a toujours dit
étant légitimes qu'une fois le Conseil
constitutionnel aurait rendu c'est
ses réponses ça serait difficile et pas
vraiment la technique de la CFDT de
d'appeler encore les gens à venir dans
la rue à manifester d'autres syndicats
notamment force ouvrières solidaire ont
clairement annoncé que ne comptait pas
arrêter à l'issue de
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
donc il semble toujours attaché à
l'Inter syndical avoir comment ils
arriveront à ménager la chèvre el chou
dans cette situation on va aller voir
Damien Canivet sur le terrain Damien qui
se trouve et bien en tête de cortège
Damien on sait que c'est précisément là
que que peuvent se trouver parfois les
éléments perturbateurs Damien Calais
l'ambiance à ce niveau là du cortège
écoutez Timothée l'ambiance est plutôt
calme nous sommes toujours boulevard des
Invalides le cortège est resté
immobilisé pendant une grosse vingtaine
de minutes le temps que le black block
se forme le cordon de gendarme est
toujours très loin de nous finalement à
quelques dizaines de mètres et boulevard
de des Invalides c'est assez endroit là
qu'on se rencontre en fait que le la
manifestation est particulièrement à
risque pourquoi parce que nous venons de
croiser disons la route de certains
monuments assez symboliques comme par
exemple quel est le ministère du Travail
qui se trouve rue de Grenelle qui est à
quelques dizaines de mètres de là où
nous trouvons nous venons aussi de nous
trouver juste à côté de du ministère des
outre-mer et c'est en partie pour cette
raison et bien que le dispositif
policier est conséquent aujourd'hui 4200
gendarmes et policiers sont prévus sur
cette manifestation à Paris ce qui est
malgré tout moi que le mardi 28 mars
dernier date de la dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites et voilà voilà c'est gendarmes
sont aujourd'hui très visibles ils
attendent entre 500 et 1000 militants
d'extrême gauche alors après ça reste
une parenthèse dans cette manifestation
qui se déroule malgré tout très bien le
cortège syndical est à quelques dizaines
de mètres de nous et manifeste dans le
plus grand des calmes et on a le
sentiment ici finalement qu'il y a un
nouvel acte qui se joue vous savez c'est
mobilisation contre les réformes des
retraites c'est un peu comme une série
dont la première saison tournée un peu
autour de la réforme des retraites la
deuxième saison c'était le 49-3 la
troisième c'était la mobilisation contre
les forces de l'ordre et finalement et
bien cette quatrième acte on sait pas
vraiment quelle tournure ça va prendre
mais en tout cas on essaiera de répondre
à cette question dans les toutes
prochaines heures ici dans les rues de
la capitale
n'hésitez pas à nous appeler dès qu'il
se passe quelque chose en tête de
cortège on a bien compris que pour le
moment la situation était assez calme
une situation qui est importante parce
que ça peut ça peut peut-être jouer sur
l'éventualité d'une nouvelle
manifestation mardi ou jeudi par exemple
vous vous disiez peut-être même les deux
est-ce que
dans ce cas si cette onzième journée de
manifestation n'était pas la dernière
est-ce que les syndicats ne prennent pas
aussi un risque parce que les Français
on le sait sont majoritairement opposés
à cette réforme mais il risque de se
lasser peut-être à force de ces grèves
et de ses manifestations à répétition
il y a un risque il y a un risque il y a
une grande question qui commence à
pointer notamment chez les syndicats
réformistes c'est comment on sort de ce
mouvement de contestation on savait
depuis le début qui durerait pas
éternellement fallait bien qu'il prenne
fin alors soit en faisant reculer le
gouvernement ce qui n'arrivera
probablement pas
mais voilà
il en plus une colère qui fait que c'est
pas facile de
fermer la parenthèse comme si de rien
n'était tous les syndicats ne sont pas
d'accord comme je disais tout à l'heure
certains veulent continuer coûte que
coûte d'autres me disent que ça devra au
moins prendre de nouvelles formes donc
effectivement ça c'est quelque chose qui
commence à se tramer donc c'est jamais
officiellement mais ça ne faut aucun
doute que c'est quelque chose qui traîne
dans la tête de beaucoup comment réussir
à me faire une fin qui soit digne pour
les syndicats pour tous les partis
comment éviter que ça se transforme en
violence dans la rue comme il y a pu
avoir un certain moment notamment après
le 49-3
voilà quoi quelle suite à donner comment
préserver l'Inter syndical qui a quand
même été une franche réussite enfin les
syndicats enfin ils sont réussi à mettre
beaucoup de monde dans la rue et les
syndicats sont très contents de cette
interdicale donc ça c'est des questions
compliquées et sur lequel il y a pas
l'air d'y avoir de réponse pour le
moment ils ont eux aussi de trouver une
porte de sortie finalement parce qu'il
faut bien que ce mouvement finisse par
s'arrêter un jour c'est ça en fait c'est
vrai que ça serait plus facile si le
gouvernement donnait donnait quelque
chose de suffisamment de conséquent qui
justifie qui puisse se permettre à la
CFDT et peut-être d'autres de sortir
malheureusement en fait on voit que la
discussion maintenant est exclusivement
cliquez sur 64 ans pas 64 ans et il peut
pas y avoir 18 choix soit il reste soit
il bouge et vu que personne n'a envie de
discuter du reste on voit pas bien
comment on peut essayer tendre un autre
un autre cadeau quoi qui est qui
satisface quand même les les syndicats
réformistes donc c'est une situation
compliquée je pense que si il y a un
vrai essoufflement de la mobilisation ça
permettra déjà plus facilement de
justifier un départ de certains on verra
un peu les chiffres d'aujourd'hui en
tête de cortège ils hésité entre dire
similaire à la semaine dernière ou
légèrement moins ils sont quand même que
s'il y a une baisse au moins de 10%
enfin certains chefs qui remontent par
rapport à la semaine dernière donc avoir
surtout si un autre la semaine prochaine
à quel niveau de mobilisation elle sera
on fera un point tout à l'heure sur
cette sur ce niveau de la mobilisation
avec Arthur bijouta du Figaro data un
mot Thomas Engrand sur Sophie Binet la
nouvelle patronne de de la CGT parce que
là aussi ça peut ça peut jouer sur la
suite du mouvement elle vient d'être élu
elle succède avec elle succède pardon a
Philippe Martinez donc à la tête de de
la CGT avec un ton on l'a vu assez
offensif d'abord qui était parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle est encore assez
inconnue du grand public quel est son
son mandat à ce féminin alors c'est un
peu à étrange parce que elle doit un peu
faire un grand écart elle a été élu un
peu grâce enfin du fait du rejet du
bureau précédent et des décisions qu'il
avait pris notamment sur des questions
sociétales notamment sur des questions
de féministes qui essayent de mettre de
façon plus importante au cœur de la
centrale et il s'avère que elle a
exactement le même programme elle c'est
une donc c'est une femme qui est assez
attachée à ces questions d'écologie et à
ces questions de féminisation donc déjà
c'est un peu étrange ce qui est
compliqué c'est qu'effectivement elle
doit jouer avec les dures de
la CGT qui ont un vrai pouvoir de
nuisance et qu'on pas mal grossi ces
dernières années donc elle doit aussi
donner des gages en étant ferme en se
montrant dans la
donc il y a un peu cette difficulté
pour le moment elle se dire elle montre
les muscles en étant très ferme mais
effectivement il faut s'attendre à voir
donc peut-être une CGT de combat dans
les prochaines années mais qui donne un
qui s'approche des questions d'écologie
aussi et des questions de féminisme et
on continuera bien sûr de suivre ces
questions avec vous Thomas en grand
responsable de tout ce suivi syndical
pour Le Figaro merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup pour votre éclairage cet
après-midi on va aller voir de nouveau
Damien canivelez en tête de cortège
Damien comment est-ce que le la
manifestation se passe on a le sentiment
que le cortège marche d'un bon pas
depuis les Invalides maintenant
tout se déroule dans le calme pour le
moment nous sommes juste en face
l'hôpital Necker vous savez cet hôpital
pour enfants qui avait fait beaucoup
parler de lui à l'époque des gilets
jaunes puisqu'il avait été plus ou moins
vandalisé et ça avait à l'époque suscité
une énorme polémique et bien nous sommes
devant cet établissement parisien
direction le boulevard du Montparnasse
avec effectivement des manifestants qui
défilent pour le moment dans le calme on
espère que que ça va que ça va durer
ainsi pendant de longues minutes le
cortège syndical n'est pas encore là
nous nous trouvons dans le pré-corpège
finalement entre les forces de l'ordre
et le cortège composé de la CFDT et de
la CGT et tous les autres syndicats bien
connus alors nous avons croisé des têtes
que nous connaissons ici dans dans les
rues de Paris Jérôme Rodriguez notamment
vous savez cette figure gilet jaune qui
s'est fait connaître à cette époque lors
du de ce mouvement de contestation et
qui est connu pour avoir effectivement
revendiqué en tout cas clamer des
slogans Antipolis en raison de de de son
œil qui l'a perdu lors des
manifestations nous avons également
croisé des des militants que l'on a
l'habitude de voir ici dans ces
manifestations et qui se rassemblent
toujours devant le cortège syndical et
qui claque bien souvent non pas des
slogans en lien avec la réforme des
retraites et le mouvement de
contestation tel qu'on le connaît mais
des des slogans Antipolis des slogans
également anticapitalistes finalement
c'est manifestants sont peut-être les
mêmes que ceux que l'on a retrouvé à
sainte-solin vous savez au niveau des
méga bassines et qui sont de toute façon
contre la police là vous les voyez ils
sont en train de de clamer des des
slogans anarchistes à Paris debout
soulève-toi voilà ce sont des des
phrases que l'on a d'habitude d'entendre
ici depuis maintenant de nombreux mois
depuis le mouvement de la réforme des
retraites qui a commencé maintenant en
janvier dernier
avec donc effectivement c'est cette
ambiance assez particulière quand même
en termes de cortège Christophe corner
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef
notamment des questions de sécurité et
vous me disiez à l'instant en arrivant
sur ce plateau qui a un côté un petit
peu antique qui est en train de monter
dans ces dans ces cortèges ouais ouais
en fait c'est de nouvelles
particularités on va dire de cette de
cette 11e journée nationale d'action
contre la réforme des retraites c'est à
dire que généralement jusqu'à maintenant
c'était les points cristallisations
c'était l'âge légal du départ à la
retraite évidemment le 49-3 qui était
brandi comme un déni de démocratie et en
fait les policiers là se sont rendus
compte que sous l'effet s'ouvre de
sainte-solide mais aussi des polémiques
qui ont tourné sur la Brava mais on en
reparlera si vous le souhaitez Timothée
il y a comme une espèce de de d'élan de
de colère contre les forces de l'ordre
qui s'est véritablement
manifesté depuis le 16 mars le dernier
et là on les les services de
renseignement que j'ai eu en ligne hier
étaient très inquiets sur
les attaques qui pouvaient être menées
contre les unités engagées sur place
aussi bien policier que gendarme
et et pourquoi parce que il faut quand
même se rappeler que notamment le 23
mars quand il avait été quand la
manifestation avait véritablement dérapé
il y avait eu 500 15 policiers et
gendarmes blessés en une seule journée
ce qui avait été un bilan absolument
considérable et
hier notamment les analyses de la place
Bovo redoutaient une espèce de réplique
un peu de cette de cette haine en tiflic
qui qui est très présente à Nantes il y
a eu des mots d'ordre tous unis contre
la police
il y a eu
là encore à Lyon tout à l'heure il y a
eu quelques débordements ou à Rennes ou
il y a qui est un Bestron à bastion de
l'ultra gauche il y a des slogans qui
sont toujours les mêmes c'est on déteste
tous la police suicider vous en parlant
aux policiers évidemment aux gendarmes
une balle un flic et ça c'est quelque
chose qui la mention akab sarbastards
etc c'est autant de autant de autant de
signaux qui qui montent de plus en plus
en gamme et qui inca de véritablement le
les forces de l'or c'est à dire qu'on
ait pu véritable très souvent on n'était
pas que sur le thème de la thématique
des retraites mais là on est vraiment
sur quelque chose qui
qui monte en gamme et qui inquiète ça
c'est certain quelque chose qui inquiète
les forces de l'ordre qui n'a en tout
cas pas refroidi les ardeurs des
manifestants je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez j'ai le sentiment qu'il y a du
monde dans les dans les rues de France
et en tout cas de Paris aujourd'hui
alors il y a du monde mais
on est quand même face à une espèce de
de de de tasse quand je parle pas
d'effondrement une espèce de tassement
quand même on est à la 11e journée
nationale d'action 11e journée de colère
dans le pays à 14h il y avait 181
manifestants ce qui est quand même 50000
de moins que le
dixième 10e épisode où il y avait eu 230
000 personnes et c'est surtout la moitié
de mobilisation en moins que le pic du 7
mars il y avait eu je crois presque 430
000 personnes alors on parle dans les
rues de du pays donc c'est à dire que
on voit que ça continue quand même à
mobiliser mais on est on est on est
quand même sur une légère décélération
c'est à dire ce qui reste c'est pas
forcément bon signe parce que ceux qui
restent c'est ça peut être aussi parmi
il y a les Ultra et jusqu'au boutisme
ceux qui se disent que de toute façon
il lâcheront rien tout à l'heure on
entendait
notamment les les élus de la France
insoumise qui disaient que
l'issue de cette crise politique et
sociale ne pouvait pas être policière et
que et que ça ne marcherait que que par
la force et le bras de fer avec la rue
donc
ça reste mobilisé mais un peu moins mais
ça reste mobilisé mais c'est pas c'est
pas encore gagné en tout cas pour ce qui
est des jeunes beaucoup de jeunes dans
les rues il y a un élément à prendre en
compte c'est le début des vacances
scolaires la zone A est en vacances
vendredi est-ce que ça peut jouer ça
ouais ça jouait ça peut ça peut jouer
alors ça peut jouer dans un sens comme
dans l'autre en fait les policiers eux
pensent que ça peut jouer dans le sens
d'une mobilisation des jeunes dans la
mesure où comme les vacances c'est
vendredi
il pense enfin en tout cas les les
services de renseignement pensent que
les notamment les lycéens pour avoir la
tentation finalement de se dire bon bah
je vais je vais prendre une journée de
vacances un peu plus tôt et je vais
participer à la manif de jeudi et je
vais commencer mes vacances jeudi et
donc ça peut faire en sorte que les
jeunes rejoignent ce mouvement on estime
qu'il serait entre 20 et 30 000
aujourd'hui ce qui est ce qui est un
nombre assez assez important plus un peu
au moins au moins autant que la semaine
que le que le 28 mars dernier donc c'est
quelque chose qui est qui compte le
gouvernement avait essayé désamorcer un
peu cette grenade qu'il a dans la poche
le grenade de la grenade de la jeunesse
notamment en en tirant un trait sur la
prolongation du du SAU vous savez le
service national universel et ça a pas
vraiment marché finalement et qui a pas
non ça pas vraiment marché on ce qui est
clair c'est que ça ça a mis encore plus
de jeunes dans la rue mais le retrait du
SNU de cette mesure même contestée n'a
pas été de nature à désamorcer
complètement cette cette colère cette
colère de la de la jeunesse il y a pas
trop de blocage dans les facs et dans
les lycées mais on sent que ça frémit
hein dans ce dans ce dans ce dans cette
partie là de la population et à chaque
fois on doit le rappeler c'est que les
jeunes c'est certainement un des
paramètres que regarde le plus les
forces de l'or parce que on n'intervient
pas évidemment sur des des cortèges
composés de de jeunes parce que
parce que parce qu'il y a le moindre
incident peut prendre des proportions
tout à fait importante et dramatique et
évidemment tout le monde garde en esprit
le l'épisode de malikosikine qui avait
été
qui avait trouvé la mort en décembre 86
lors d'une manifestation à Paris on va
aller trouver Vincent Rousseau sur le
terrain mais avant cela une dernière
question Christophe Cornavin avant
d'aller voir Vincent des manifestations
des jeunes à Paris mais pas que non les
jeunes ils sont ils sont on les a vu ils
sont à Lyon ils sont à Rennes ils sont à
Grenoble en fait il y a il y a toutes
les villes universitaires ou toutes les
villes où il y a beaucoup de de jeunes
ont mobilisé même si c'est un peu moins
que les précédentes
éditions diraient il reste encore pas
mal de jeunes dans la rue et
effectivement il y a en plus dans la
Zona ce phénomène vacance qu'appréhendé
les services de renseignement donc voilà
donc on est on est quand même sur un
point d'intention là encore donc il y a
un la colère antique de les jeunes qui
sont en embuscade et puis trois
évidemment toujours les les
cette constellation des gens disent
nébuleuse mais pourquoi parce que dire
constellation de de de des casseurs
d'ultra gauche
avec les ultras les gilets jaunes ultra
avec une partie des syndicats aussi les
services se sont rendus compte que il y
a une partie des syndicalistes qui
commencent à se à se radicaliser aussi
de leur côté parce qu'on arrive à la fin
du mouvement tout le monde le sait il y
aura peut-être la semaine peut-être même
certainement la semaine prochaine une
une nouvelle journée ce sera peut-être
l'ultime certainement l'ultime en tout
cas avant la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel donc même si les
syndicats refusent de parler de baroud
d'honneur il est clair que là on est
quand même dans quelque chose qui
peut amener à à pousser le à pousser le
pousser l'élément la force le plus loin
possible quoi pour les syndicats Vincent
roseron étant en queue de cortège cet
après-midi Vincent dites-nous un peu
comment ça se passe j'ai le sentiment en
voyant ces images que l'on voyait à
l'instant que le cortège était un petit
peu clairsemé c'est peut-être un peu
moins le cas là où vous vous trouvez
alors forcément à l'avant l'avant ça
avance toujours très vite à l'avant du
cortège donc ça a l'air plus clairsemé
moi là où je suis en tout cas le cortège
est assez dense surtout que alors il
peut paraître un peu clairsemé parce
qu'en fait la on est sur le valide et
c'est très large en fait la chaussette
est très large beaucoup plus par exemple
que vous boulevard Voltaire de la
dernière manifestation qui se déroulait
entre République et nations là la
chaussée était plus resserrée et donc
forcément et plus de densité et pour
vous répondre en fait je suis pas forcé
je suis pas vraiment au fond de la
manifestation moi je suis plutôt pas non
plus au début mais un peu au milieu je
pense encore on a eu un grand cortège
étudiant qui est passé justement vous
donnerez tout à l'heure s'il y avait les
étudiants on en a vu pas mal passer ils
étaient assez nombreux là maintenant ce
sont plutôt les les personnes encadrants
des universités qui sont passés devant
nous et au fond de sur ces images vous
pouvez voir sur les images que vous
montre batis fleuret les ballons de la
CFTC de de solidaire et là si j'étais
n'est toujours pas passé non plus donc
il y a encore beaucoup beaucoup de monde
qu'on attend en fait et qui doit encore
passer sur cet endroit qui on est encore
boulevard des Invalides on est quand
même au début de la manifestation donc
encore
encore au début de la manifestation donc
beaucoup de monde dans les rues de Paris
Christophe Cornavin on l'a vu et vous
l'avez mentionné des éléments de
violence qui ont éclaté lors des
précédents cortèges généralement vers la
fin de ces de ces manifestations est-ce
que les services de renseignement ça
prend ça prête pardon à affronter le
même type de scènes de violence
aujourd'hui en tout cas elle le
redoutait il le redoutait hier et tant
que la journée n'est pas finie c'est
hypothèse ne peut être complètement
exclu on est on pourrait presque dire
quand c'est inscrit le pays c'est
inscrit dans une espèce de de routine de
violence programmée
de épisodes après épisode le 12 ans de
l'année 11e et on est toujours avec ce
même scénario avec des défilés alors
déblocage le matin la journée se passe
toujours en deux temps le matin vous
avez
des blocages de dépôt des
occupations rond-point des opérations
coup de poing sur des axes routiers
comme à Lyon on a enflammé on a fait des
murs de flammes là pour bloquer la
circulation et puis dès le début
d'après-midi
on l'a vu dans certaines villes de
France donc j'en viens de parler de Lyon
et c'était aussi vrai à Rennes et à
Nantes l'ultra gauche notamment en tout
cas des casseurs se mettent en mode
black bloc et commence à à chauffer la
salle je dirais essaye de de perturber
de faire dévisser un peu les cortèges
vers quelque chose d'autre et à chaque
fois on arrive vers le phénomène de
casse le vers le phénomène de de
d'incendie volontaire et pour le
finalement arriver à cette à cet
affrontement final en mode western avec
les forces de l'ordre plutôt en fin de
journée donc plutôt en fin de journée et
et et à chaque fois le même rituel se
renouvelle donc il y a aucune raison
pour que pour que pour que ça s'arrête
aujourd'hui même si là où il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de policiers donc il y
a 5000 il y a 4000 pardon 4200 personnes
des forces de l'ordre policiers
gendarmes dans Paris donc ça peut être
de nature quand même à calmer un peu le
jeu mais on est quand même sur une sur
une tension qui est toujours palpable
dans chacun des défilés et Paris
n'échappera pas à la règle d'autant plus
que Paris aujourd'hui son parcours il
est quand même
à risque c'est pas un parcours qui va
faire plaisir forcément
à la police parisienne au préfet de
police dans la mesure où il est rive
gauche il va passer près des lieux de
pouvoir il est aux invalide après on va
descendre on va passer près de Grenelle
etc après les ministères ce qu'on
appelle le fameux quartier des
ministères et puis après on va descendre
du côté de de
comment de la du boulevard Montparnasse
et boulevard Montparnasse il y a des
adresses qui sont évidemment importantes
comme
qui était un point un point marqué
macrony maintenant dans l'esprit tout le
monde et qui à chaque fois doit être
protégé pour ne pas se faire caillasser
brasserie donc brasserie parisienne
fréquenté par Emmanuel Macron notamment
voilà et puis après tout tout le monde
doit arriver à à Place d'Italie bon
Place d'Italie c'est un endroit qu'on
peut que les que les forces de l'ordre
arrivent à
à gérer parce que évidemment il y a il y
a un peu près 5 manifestations par jour
dans Paris donc les paris donc les les
forces de l'ordre connaissent leur
territoire par cœur mais l'idée c'est
qu'il va falloir quand même boucler ce
périmètre qui est quand même assez grand
pour pouvoir éviter que une partie
notamment des des éléments les plus
radicaux ne puissent partir en cortège
sauvage dans les rues de la capitale
comme on l'avait vu le 23 mars où je
vous le rappelle Timothée il y avait
plus de 900 incendies dans la ville en
une seule soirée j'en sais quelque chose
puisque j'étais sur le terrain ce
jour-là
un mot sur les dispositifs de de
sécurité vous avez dit 4200 policiers et
gendarmes déployés aujourd'hui dans les
rues de la capitale qu'est-ce que ça
représente par rapport aux autres
manifestations
c'est c'est une des manifestations les
plus ortacées des mobilisations les plus
fortes la plus forte mobilisation
policière en fait ça a été le 28 mars
dernier d'accord où on était à 5000
policiers
il faut vraiment se rendre compte que ça
fait presque 90 unités de Paul de
gendarmes mobiles et de CRS c'est
l'équivalent un peu d'une mobilisation
qu'on pourrait retrouver devant une demi
finale voir une finale de Coupe du monde
de football ou on s'attend à avoir des
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
la rue donc ils sont généralement plus
festives donc mais on est quand même sur
des sur un dimensionnement du du service
d'ordre qui est
ce qui est intéressant c'est quand on
est sur le terrain à précisément on
s'aperçoit que les forces de l'ordre
même si elles sont présentes en nombre
elles se font assez discrètes en tout
cas au début du cortège et elle se
trouve dans les dans les rues adjacentes
généralement et elles sont assez peu
visibles des manifestants pour quelles
raisons en fait ça c'est une en fait
c'est juste un retour de d'une
application du du schéma national du
maintien de l'ordre en fait c'est que
l'idée c'est et le préfet de police
Laurent Nunès a remis ça de manière très
claire dans son dispositif c'est de
faire en sorte que les forces de l'ordre
soit le moins visible possible quel
finalement quelle disparaisse du décor
qu'elle soit dans les rues adjacentes
pourquoi parce que il se il s'est rendu
compte comme un certain de stratège de
de l'ordre public que plus vous mettez
des forces de l'ordre au contact plus
tout d'un coup vous achetez un chiffon
rouge contre qui n'ont qu'une envie
justement c'est d'en découdre ça c'est
nouveau ça c'est Laurent nouilles qui a
mis ça en place en tout cas leur Nunes
la remis véritablement au goût du jour
parce que son prédécesseur
Didier l'allemand
était plus plus contraint finalement de
mettre ses forces au contact parce que
c'était les gilets jaunes à l'époque il
est gilets jaunes n'avait pas de service
d'ordre pour
encadrer un peu leur mouvement tandis
que là le leur Nunes peut compter sur
les services d'ordre des syndicats des 8
centrales syndicales au service de la
CGT dessus etc de CFDT qui permettent de
de flanc garder en tout cas de de
protéger en fait le l'enveloppe le le
contour de des défilés et de et de
mettre donc ces forces à lui un peu en
retrait comme vous l'avez vu Timothée
sur le terrain pour simplement après
leur donner l'ordre de foncé et
d'interpeller au moment de l'exaction au
moment de la casse c'est une prise de
risque pour le préfet de police parce
que c'est à dire que lui il laisse il
faire en sorte que la que la que les que
les forces de l'ordre ben finalement
sont pas là tout de suite au moment des
dons qui comptent sur une très grande
réactivité des forces il faut des pour
ça des unités extrêmement mobiles et oui
parce qu'on a potentiellement un temps
de retard du coup il y a toujours un
temps de retard mais entre
j'allais dire par définition il y a
toujours un temps de retard parce que
contrairement à ce qui a une idée qui
est répandue et qui est massivement
erronée il n'y a pas d'interpellation
préventive les interpellations qui sont
faites par les forces de l'ordre ne sont
fait qu'après la commission d'un fait
d'une exaction d'un d'une case donc il y
a toujours un temps de retard mais
les forces de l'ordre qui sont
prépositionnées sont à quelques dizaines
de mètres même si on les voit pas elles
sont à quelques dizaines de mètres c'est
un peu l'idée de ces de ces de ses
forces qui sont un peu sur la colline et
tout d'un coup qui peuvent dévaler dans
la dans les vallées et qui en moins de
2-3 minutes peuvent faire cesser le le
chaos et ils ont des unités qui sont
spécialement entraînées pour ça aussi
bien au sein des CRS que des gendarmes
mobiles et aussi pour les braves qui
sont ces nouveaux de nouvelles brigades
motocyclistes dont on a beaucoup parlé
alors on va revenir sur cette question
des braves parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une question dont on parle
beaucoup comme vous le dites en ce
moment une question avant cela
simplement sur Gérald Darmanin qui était
interrogé hier au Parlement sur cette
sur cette question de de l'usage des
forces de l'ordre en quelques mots
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui est
ressorti de cette audition ah en fait
Gérald Darmanin
il a défendu bec et ongles en fait la
l'institution c'est à dire que il est il
était complètement dans son rôle
c'est-à-dire que ça fait quand même
deux mois et demi que les policiers et
les gendarmes sont en train d'essayer de
contenir un des des manifestations qui
peuvent être très largement débordés on
l'a vu tout à l'heure on en a parlé il y
a des jours où ils ont eu à déplorer
plus de 500 blessés dans leur dans leur
rang à Paris il y a eu des forces des
forces de l'ordre qui ont été grièvement
touchés il y a des gens qui notamment la
mâchoire cassée après avoir reçu des des
boules de pétanque ou qui ont été
si de tentative de on essaie de les
enflammer avec un nouveau procédé qui
sont des flacons de parfums dans
lesquels on met des transformes un peu
en espèces de cocktail Molotov donc et
donc ils sont les forces de l'ordre sont
à la fois en première ligne aussi dans
cet étau où ils sont en même temps point
du doigt pour pour des violences et donc
et donc Gérald Darmanin lui a essayé de
de
défendre un peu ces forces de l'ordre et
il a pas été simplement que dans
l'incantation il a été il a il a rappelé
quand même deux trois deux trois deux
trois fois qui sont pas inintéressant
notamment tout simplement par exemple
qui a eu depuis le début des des
manifestations plus de 41 en quête
judiciaires c'est-à-dire c'est pas de
l'enquête de la police de police c'est
40 40 enquêtes dans lesquelles il y a
des magistrats indépendants qui vont
travailler c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas
d'impunité de la police ni de violence
systémiques aveugles de la police les
policiers sont quand même sous contrôle
et il y a dans un même chiffre qui est
pas inintéressant je l'avais noté c'est
que il représente les gendarmes et les
policiers est représentent dans la
fonction publique 5,5% de tous les
personnels de la Fonction publique 5,5%
et bien le seul ils ont concentré
5% des sanctions disciplinaires pour
toute l'administration
5% du nombre 55% des sanctions
disciplinaires pour toute
l'administration dire que en fait c'est
quand même une des administrations les
plus contrôlées de France et les plus
réprimés de France et Gérald Darmanin a
rajouté une petite chose qui est pas
inintéressante pendant son son propos
c'est qu'il dit que beaucoup de
policiers de jeunes policiers et de
gendarmes en fait ce sont des des
enfants du peuple ce sont des gens qui
sont
issus des milieux pas forcément
favorisés les gens qui sont qui ont fait
des études de grandes études ou qui sont
issues de milieu très favorisés n'ont
pas forcément vocation à devenir CRS ou
gardien de la paix à 20 ans et à gagner
1700 euros par mois pour prendre des
coups et donc en fait il y a aussi
l'idée que en fait en s'attaquant aux
policiers c'est un peu la foule qui qui
frappe le peuple et et et et ça c'est et
ça c'était aussi une manière de défendre
ces troupes tout simplement
c'est une unité spécialisée celle des
des braves m qui suscite la polémique
ces derniers jours d'abord rappelez-nous
de quoi il s'agit c'est quoi la brave m
alors la bravane c'est cette fameuse
brigade de répression de l'action
violente en fait ce sont des brigades
motocyclistes d'accord ça fonctionne
très simplement il y a donc ces deux
policiers c'est des binômes ils sont en
tout 220
des binômes donc il y a un policier qui
est un motard qui donc pilote la l'engin
et à l'arrière se trouve donc un
opérateur un policier qui est là pour
l'intervention pourquoi on parle d'eux
comme ça bah on parle d'eux comme ça
parce qu'en fait c'est un peu le faire
de lente c'est un peu le faire de lance
de l'intervention c'est à dire que
quand il y a des casseurs quand tout
d'un coup ça devient très très chaud on
envoie la braven pourquoi parce que tout
à l'heure on disait que le préfet avait
besoin de réactivité dans le dans le
dans le mouvement dans le dans le dans
le déploiement des forces et la Bravet
évidemment grâce au moto peuvent
remonter des sens interdits
peuvent
non pas à se stationner à se garer etc
ils arrivent en quelques vraiment en un
claquement de doigts sur sur la sur la
scène où il faut intervenir et pourquoi
on parle d'eux parce qu'évidemment comme
ils sont à moto ça rappelle évidemment
le triste épisode de la mort de cette
étudiant
malico c'est qui en 1986 qui avait été
dans la mort avait mis en cause à des
policiers voltigeurs qui étaient à moto
mais le parallélisme effectivement
c'était des policiers à moto en 1986
mais à la différence des policiers à
moto de 86 les policiers de la brave ne
interviennent pas sur les casseurs
depuis leur moto ils descendent des
motos et ils le font comme des unités à
pied comme n'importe quelle unité à pied
sachant qu'en plus la brave m elle à la
différence des bacs qu'on a utilisé
contre les brillants qu'on a utilisé
contre les gilets jaunes la brevet mais
vraiment spécialiste dans le maintien de
l'ordre donc c'est des gens qui qui sont
tout à l'heure à faire ils ont été créés
rappelons-le en mars 2019 pendant le
pendant l'acte 18 des gilets jaunes
c'est à dire juste après que les gilets
jaunes eurent
il y a un feu à 100 la place de la de la
de la de la l'Arc de Triomphe voilà
et depuis lors ils sont quasiment sur
toutes les sur toutes les je crois
qu'ils ont été engagés sur plus de 8000
manifestations depuis le début et donc
comme ils sont contactés ils sont filmés
comme ils sont filmés quand même dans
une gare de l'image généralement
on met en mai en images les ceux qui
veulent pointer un doigt accusateur
contre les labravennes mettent
simplement le la fin d'une action ou la
Brava mais effectivement peut donner des
coups
et parfois le préfet de police lui
demande à ce que on est une lecture plus
globale de la défaite et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il y a 40 plus de 40 en
cas de judiciaires c'est que c'est qu'on
peut pas on peut pas inscrire des
process sur Internet et sur la fois de
vidéo qui dure 12 secondes sur TikTok
certains réclament la dissolution de la
brave c'est possible
ça va être à nous en tout cas tant que
le préfet de police actuelle sera aux
manettes ça me semble hautement
improbable il est défend à bec et ongles
la France insoumise à effectivement dit
que qu'il voulait mettre la fin il
voulait tordre le cou à ce qu'ils
appellent la brigade de la terreur parce
que là on est en sens de la mesure qui
me semble peut-être un peu dépassé et et
on se souvient que que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui a demandé à ce qu'on
soigne
comment maintenant psychiatrie les
policiers de la braven parce qu'il
considère que ce sont des des policiers
qui des jeunes gens comme il dit qui a
20 ans se porte volontaire pour monter
sur des motos et pour tabasser les les
manifestants ce qui est une lecture là
encore je pense un peu rapide de la de
la de la situation il faut quand même
rappeler que depuis l'entrée en vigueur
des braves m
notamment l'usage des LBD donc les
fameuses les fameuses balles en
caoutchouc qui était au cœur de toutes
les polémiques pendant les gilets jaunes
et qui avait l'occasion d'un certain
nombre de blessures graves et notamment
des ébornements depuis la mise en place
des braves m le nombre de tirs de LBD a
complètement disparu de mémoire il y a
eu juste avant la Bravet mais il y avait
eu des jours avec plus de plus de 1000
tirs de LBD en une seule journée et là
on était quand ils sont arrivés il y
avait même pas une trentaine de tirs de
LBD et là je crois pas que ce sujet
était évoqué depuis les 11 premiers
jours de manifestation qui a connu la
France depuis ces trois derniers mois
donc dire que il y a aussi
cet emploi de la force a permis de ne
pas utiliser des des armes dites
intermédiaires et qui provoquaient aussi
de graves blessures donc il faut
toujours mesurer sa critique quand on
regarde de près un dispositif de matière
de l'ordre merci beaucoup Christophe
Cornavin rédacteur en chef adjoint au
service société du Figaro on cherche de
toutes les questions de sécurité on va
aller voir Damien canivelle sur le
terrain qui se trouve au niveau du
cortège de la CFTC le cortège qui semble
arrêter à cet instant Damien
[Musique]
oui effectivement il vient de reprendre
sa route direction la place d'Italie
nous sommes boulevard de Montparnasse
c'est très précisément et je suis sûr
que la plupart de nos téléspectateurs
vont savoir de quoi je parle au pied de
la tour Montparnasse il est quand même à
une institution dans la capitale et un
monument en tout cas que de nombreux
Français connaissent et à cet endroit là
nous l'avons vu aucune force de l'ordre
ce qui est assez étonnant puisque lors
de la dernière manifestation qui reliait
les Invalides à la place d'Italie il y
avait énormément de de policiers ici
pourquoi parce qu'au pied de la tour
Montparnasse se trouve de nombreuses
enseignes de prêt-à-porter des également
aussi des banques des restaurants il y a
on a aussi un hôtel et on sait que les
militants radicaux ont tendance à
s'attaquer à des symboles de richesse
dont peuvent faire partie effectivement
ces enseignes ici aucun policier et en
même temps le cortège c'est est passé
devant la Tour Montparnasse sans grande
difficulté et sans grabuge je vous le
disais tout à l'heure la réforme la
retraite n'est pas forcément au centre
des préoccupations de cette tête de
cortège en tout cas de ce pré-corpège
nous avons entendu des revendications
anticapitalistes des slogans également
que je peux vous citer leur loi notre
calvaire contre-attaque révolutionnaire
également en thème Darmanin également
égal terrorisme institutionnel vous
voyez l'émotion fort on a également vu
des appels au meurtre qui ont été
affichés sur des pancartes noires sur
blanc ce qui est beaucoup beaucoup plus
grave donc on est à peu près un tiers du
parcours de cette manifestation qui est
assez longue aujourd'hui qui s'est
tension plus de 5 km Timothée
[Musique]
merci beaucoup Damien Canivez donc dans
au coeur du cortège cet après-midi je
suis avec carmelus qui me rejoint en
plateau bonsoir bonjour car bonjour
c'est noté
du Figaro Magazine Carl l'horizon semble
assez bouché onzième journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui une rencontre
hier qui tourne au dialogue de sourd on
l'a dit entre Elisabeth Band et les
partenaires sociaux comment s'en sortir
de cette galère Carus
dans le meilleur des cas il reste une
petite semaine à tenir on sait que la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel sur
la validité de ce texte de loi sera
prononcé le 14 avril et donc à partir de
ce moment là les
le mouvement syndical en tant qu'a une
partie de devrait s'arrêter puisque à
partir du moment où le Conseil
constitutionnel va dire
ça veut dire que le mouvement social
continue non bien sûr c'est pas fini
parce que jusqu'au 14 avril il y a
possibilité pense au moins c'est les
syndicats de peser sur la décision du
Conseil consuel de montrer que c'est
d'ailleurs un des recours que toute la
procédure qui a été adoptée où il y a
pas eu de vote véritablement à
l'Assemblée nationale cette
multiplication d'articles de la
Constitution qui d'abord accélère les
débats ensuite empêche
ne permet pas de vote tout ça peut
peut-être aboutir à ce que le Conseil
constitutionnel invalide je n'y crois
pas mais bon on verra bien
la forme du texte donc il faut mettre la
pression ce qu'il continue à faire avec
quand même on le voit bien je parle sur
le contrôle de des journalistes sociaux
qui nous diront mais il y a trois
semaines on nous disait le pays va être
bloqué mais aujourd'hui le pays n'est
pas bloqué il y a des blocages par
endroits il y a des actions mais le pays
globalement comme on a pu le connaître
en 95 pas vous
trop jeune mais moi
donc vous l'avez connu mais
au moins en 95 voilà c'était totalement
paralysé là c'est pas le cas mais
d'accord ça veut dire que les syndicats
ont échoué à bloquer le pays en tout cas
ceux qui appelaient au blocage parce que
la cfdtl n'a jamais appelé véritablement
au bocage au blocage mais la CGT qui
appelait au blocage oui Martinez
d'ailleurs en convenait le soir même on
dit non mais c'était une façon de parler
machin oui non on voit bien que là de ce
point de vue là ils n'y sont pas arrivés
volpazu vous vous interpelle dans le
chat du Figaro car il nous dit il vous
dit les syndicats on dit qu'il
n'arrêterait pas
oui mais ça c'est normal de dire ça
quand on est au coeur du mouvement bien
sûr
c'est de c'est du bras de fer c'est du
rapport de force de la même façon que le
gouvernement dit je ne renonce à rien
j'y vais jusqu'au bout il faut voir dans
comment le rapport de force va basculer
donc le vous imaginez un syndicaliste
qui dirait aujourd'hui bon je manifeste
mais bon c'est vrai qu'apparaît avant la
décision dans une semaine je vais
arrêter mais vous démobilisez les gens
donc il faut dire on bloque le pays il
faut dire du point de vue syndical on va
jusqu'au bout on ne s'arrêtera pas mais
on sait bien qu'à partir du moment où le
Conseil constitutionnel donnera sa
décision si cette décision c'est sûr que
si il considère que la loi est
inconditionnel le mouvement s'arrête
puisque par définition la loi elle-même
ne sera plus valide mais s'il valide la
loi le mouvement s'arrêtera doucement
parce que on le voit bien d'ailleurs
dans les sondages une grande majorité
c'est à peu près 70 80% des Français ils
sont opposés mais une très grande
majorité aussi entre 70% les gens disent
on est contre mais de toute façon cette
loi va passer donc il y a une sorte de
résignation un message à nouveau de
l'internaute du Figaro qui nous dit le
blocage c'était la CGT et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous avez
sorti ce sondage dans dans les pages du
Figaro Magazine ce weekend et dès
aujourd'hui sur le site internet du
Figaro Jean-Luc Mélenchon on aurait pu
penser qu'il allait tirer profit de
cette mobilisation parce que évidemment
on voit les députés notamment de la
France insoumise et qui sont présents en
nombre dans les cortèges et pourtant et
pourtant dans les sondages ça ne se voit
pas c'est un peu pour ça qu'on a demandé
à Ifop de faire ce sondage parce que on
voulait vérifier le rapport de force
aujourd'hui c'est pas tellement voilà
l'élection présidentielle en elle-même
on sait bien il y a pas eu de campagne
les gens sont pas dans le vote mais ça
permet de montrer quel est le rapport de
force la logique aurait voulu que la
gauche en profite on est sur une unité
syndicale qui ne s'est jamais vu depuis
longtemps des manifestations des
cortèges
nombreux même si le pays n'est pas
bloqué les gens manifestent
on est sur des revendications sociales
de gauche
le refus de l'allongement de
l'âge de départ à la retraite c'est par
définition une revendication de gauche
donc tous les éléments tous les
ingrédients étaient là pour que
normalement la gauche progresse résultat
du sondage de
ifope Fiducial pour SUD RADIO et
magazine c'est l'inverse si on refaisait
l'élection présidentielle d'il y a à
peine un an le premier tour c'était le
10 avril et bien Jean-Luc Mélenchon
perdrait à peu près 5 points de mémoire
il était à 17%, voilà 17%, il était à 23
et quelques Emmanuel Macron finalement
résiste pas si mal que ça il était à 27
et quelques il est à 25 et celle qui
progresse c'est Marine Le Pen alors là
pour le coup une progression de 7 points
et demi elle passe à 31%. donc on voit
bien là que ce n'est pas la gauche ce
n'est pas la gauche 2 Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et donc là il y a une question qui se
pose pour l'avenir de la gauche c'est ce
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est toujours le
bon candidat est-ce que stratégie de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon de semer le chaos à
l'Assemblée nationale de de semer la
tension
dans les manifestations mais dans les
mots est-ce que c'est la bonne stratégie
la partiel de l'Ariège dimanche dernier
à montrer que c'était pas forcément la
bonne stratégie avec effectivement une
candidate dissidente à la IPS a filé au
Parti socialiste qui l'a emporté donc
face à cette face à la députés sortante
de la France insoumise je voudrais
parler des lisabeth borne karlmeus avec
vous Elisabeth borne et qui recevait
hier les partenaires sociaux j'ai le
sentiment quand on écoute les
partenaires sociaux ils disent c'est un
échec cette rencontre qui les abattement
elle elle dit là vous voyez bien que le
dialogue il est pas rompu avec les
syndicats donc finalement je fais mon
travail j'avance
est-ce qu'elle joue son avenir à
Matignon et Elisabeth sur ce coup-là oui
clairement tout le monde a bien compris
dans l'intervention du président de la
République quand tu dis j'espère qu'elle
va y arriver qu'il lui donne une mission
qui est d'élargir la majorité c'est ces
missions impossible ils avaient de
bornes malheureusement n'est pas Tom
Cruise donc
c'est pas un cadeau euh la chance
qu'Elisabeth borne a c'est
qu'aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
de solution alternative en tout cas ne
l'a pas trouvé qui est aujourd'hui
l'homme politique ou la femme politique
qui peut dire à Emmanuel Macron tu me
nomme et moi je t'élargis la majorité je
vais grâce à moi prendre les 40 députés
LR qui ne sont pas venus avec Isabelle
bonne dont tu as besoin pour avoir la
majorité absolue il y en a pas alors il
y en a un qui est très populaire dans
l'opinion qui vit en plus des
républicains c'était par Philippe un
retour d'Édouard Philippe à Matignon
c'est crédible ça
je crois pas que ça soit dans sa
stratégie et les résultats du sondage
montrent que je suis pas sûr qu'il
aurait un grand intérêt à revenir à
Matignon il y a plutôt intérêt à jouer
la carte de la présidentielle c'est ça
que vous dites puis surtout
Edouard Philippe il est déjà dans la
majorité donc il n'élargirait pas par sa
présence la majorité il peut aller
chercher quelques électeurs quelques
députés pardon des républicains j'allais
y venir mais c'est exactement ça il peut
peut-être en apporter quelques-uns mais
ce qu'il est sûr d'en apporter la
quarantaine indispensable à une
majoritaire absolue parce que c'est ça
l'enjeu c'est essayer de ne pas revivre
le psychodrame de la réforme des
retraites ou pendant trois mois vous
dites oui je peux avoir la majorité avec
la républicains non je vais devoir
passer par le 49.3 je l'ai et au le
matin même dire non bah finalement je ne
les ai pas ils ne veulent pas revivre ça
mais sauf que personne aujourd'hui chez
les LR ils veulent pas y aller une
grande partie et dans la majorité ils
sont pas persuadés d'arriver à trouver
le nombre nécessaire de députés pour
pour avoir la majorité absolue mais
est-ce que c'est le bon profil est-ce
qu'il a pas fait une erreur de casting
Emmanuel Macron en choisissant Elizabeth
borne on nous disait vous allez voir
c'est une négociatrice elle a mené les
négociations avec la RATP à la mener les
négociations ce qui est vrai ouais mais
alors aujourd'hui les négociations bon
alors vous avez entièrement raison si on
prend le verre à moitié plein
ce que font évidemment les services de
Matignon le gouvernement ils disent sur
les 23 textes qui ont qui sont passés là
depuis le début de la législature 20
sont passés sans 49,3 des textes assez
consensuels peut-être bah sur le
nucléaire pas tellement les énergies
renouvelables c'était pas forcément
gagné le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif c'était pas gagné donc en
réalité il y a eu la loi de finances le
financement de la sécurité sociale et
les retraites qui sont passées en 49-3
donc vers à moitié plein finalement on
peut s'en sortir et dans la mesure où
pour l'avenir on va plus avoir de texte
qui sont sensibles on peut continuer
comme ça après il y a le verre à moitié
vide et qui est celui qui Emmanuel
Macron regarde peut-être parce que vous
vous souvenez qu'à l'automne Emmanuel
Macron ne voulait passer la réforme des
retraites dans un amendement au projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et qui lui a dit il faut surtout
pas faire ça
François Bayrou et Elizabeth borne en
leur disant un
il faut apaiser le pays si on fait ça le
pays sera pas à baiser 2 je vais
négocier avec la CFDT je vais ramener la
CFDT au bord de la avec nous pour la
négociation sur ce texte et trois je me
fais fort de passer un accord avec les
républicains ça vachement bien marché
bah les trois c'est chèque totale donc
effectivement si on regarde ça les jours
ils avaient bonne peuvent on peut
considérer que les jours d'Elizabeth
borne sont comptés à Matignon vous
parlez de la CFDT Laurent Berger c'est
c'est la nouvelle icône de ce qu'il
reste de la de la gauche
social-démocrate ah bah en tout cas
c'est celui on savait que c'était lui
qui avait la clé de la réforme c'est à
dire que si lui acceptait le deal et
bien la réforme pouvait se faire le
problème c'est que ils ont négligé un
aspect c'est que Laurent Berger a été
réélu par son congrès avec un mandat
clair qui était ne jamais accepter un
report de l'âge légal à partir de ce
moment-là on savait que Laurent Berger
ne pouvait pas accepter il est lié et
c'est pas un politique le problème c'est
ça c'est que les politiques ils disent
oui d'accord j'ai dit ça mais je vais
faire autre chose
il dit non moi j'ai mon mandat je peux
pas faire autrement
et après bon il faut pas faire dire plus
à berger que ce qu'il ne dit et
d'ailleurs lui-même dit qu'il ne veut
pas plus que un mandat syndical que il
n'a pas derrière pensé politique
c'est ce qu'il dit en tout cas c'est ce
qu'il dit c'est ce qu'il répète et on
peut le croire parce que après tout il
en a vu tellement avec les politiques
que peut-être que celle-là ça
l'encourage pas à franchir le ruban
Renaud musulier le président de la
Région PACA dit il faut recoudre le lien
entre Emmanuel Macron et Laurent Berger
c'est vrai qu'il se connaissent depuis
un certain temps on dit qu'il se tutoie
parce qu'ils sont côtoyés je crois Bercy
vous allez nous nous confirmer cela
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez c'est
indispensable tout le monde le sait
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
en France vous ne pouvez pas passer une
réforme importante une réforme sociale
sans avoir au moins un syndicat avec
vous on se souvient que son prédécesseur
François cherec avait accepté un deal
avec le pouvoir de l'époque certes la
CFDT elle l'avait payé cher par la suite
mais même Nicolas Sarkozy avait essayé
de dealer avec la CGT de Bernard
Thibault alors ça se faisait pas aussi
clairement mais en tout cas les contacts
étaient fréquents là le problème avec
grand berger c'est que les contacts
étaient rompus avec l'Élysée et qu'il
avait très peu de contacts avec Matignon
et Laurent Berger en plus ne comprenait
pas il l'a répété plusieurs fois
pourquoi les gilets jaunes qui casse
tout obtiennent 17 milliards et nous
dans les manifestations parce que les
les 10 premières manifestations c'était
passé vraiment sans heure et dans le
calme ça se passe dans le calme et on
obtient rien donc voilà on sait que il
faut qu'un lien soit retissé ça n'en
prend pas le chemin pour l'instant mais
parce qu'on est encore au cœur du combat
et que on est dans un rapport de force
mais de toute façon il y a une loi
travail qui est en préparation avec des
éléments importants et Emmanuel Macron
va devoir d'ailleurs il l'a dit ça porte
c'est ouverte il va il va recevoir les
syndicats dans les prochaines semaines
il y a bien un moment où ils vont finir
par se remettre autour de la table et
par discuter exactement merci beaucoup
Carmel Merci à VOUS rédacteur en chef ou
Figaro Magazine on va aller voir Damien
Canivez sur le terrain parce qu'il
semble que quelques petits mouvements de
tension commence hélas à éclater Damien
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe autour de vous
et bien
quelques problèmes de liaison avec avec
Damien Canivet ça tombe c'est pas grave
on a on a deux équipes sur le terrain
cet après-midi on va on va aller voir
Vincent roseron qui lui se trouve à un
autre endroit du cortège et qui nous a
appelé tout à l'heure Vincent comment
les choses se passent de votre côté il
semble que ça soit bien plus apaisé que
les quelques images que nous venons
d'apercevoir du côté de Damien
effectivement ici c'est un cortège
apaisé qui qui passe on peut le voir sur
les images de bâtisseur et que vous
montrer c'est après c'est Sud solidaire
là qui est en train de passer à une
manifestation qui se déroule dans le
calme là nous sommes au niveau du Parti
communiste francais parce que comme je
vous l'expliquais depuis 2007
manifestation il y a des parties tout
autour des partis politiques tout au
long de la manifestation pour discuter
avec les manifestants et on essaiera
d'avoir quelqu'un du Parti communiste
français dans quelques instants mais
voilà en tout cas pour l'instant tout se
passe bien de ce côté-là de la
manifestation tout à l'heure Christophe
corneven parlait par exemple des du type
de slogan des slogans antipolisés par
exemple et bien on en a entendu
effectivement mais j'ai l'impression que
c'était moins que la dernière
manifestation qui a eu lieu mardi
dernier vraiment là de nouveau des
slogans au niveau des représentations ce
n'est plus vraiment la réforme des
retraites qui faisait mais rien Emmanuel
Macron et ils avaient de Bordeaux
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron on a
retrouvé le lien avec avec Damien
Canivez Damien canivevez et qui se
trouve à proximité de La Rotonde c'est
c'est cette brasserie dont on parlait
tout à l'heure et quelques quelques
mouvements hélas de violence
voilà quelques problèmes de connexion
avec Damien Canivez peut-être parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de monde mais vous le
voyez sur ces sur ces images tournées
par par Julien Leclerc cette cette
célèbre brasserie parisienne de la
rotonde fréquentée notamment par
Emmanuel Macron qui semble être cible de
quelques projectiles et donc les forces
de l'ordre qui se sont déployées aux
alentours on va tenter de retrouver
Damien Canivez ce qui va nous décrire un
petit peu ce qu'il se passe autour de
lui j'accueille Arthur bijota du Figaro
data bonjour Arthur merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous c'est pour votre
invitation bonjour à tous on va faire un
petit point sur les chiffres que vous
avez pu étudier depuis le début de cette
journée d'abord un point sur les
premières manifestations de ce matin un
peu partout en France quels sont les
remontées du terrain le mouvement est
suiv oui on peut encore dire que que le
mouvement reste relativement suivi la
mobilisation est un petit peu plus
faible mais elle reste encore assez
assez haute assez importante pour vous
donner un point de comparaison à 15h au
moment où vous avez nous avons
comptabilisé l'ensemble des
manifestations qui avaient eu lieu ce
matin et à midi dans les grandes villes
on avait 233 000 manifestants
aujourd'hui contre 295 000 le 28 mars et
538 000 le 7 mars donc vous voyez bien
c'est en baisse c'est environ une
vingtaine entre 20 et 25% plus bas ce
qui nous fait dire que la mobilisation
totale à la fin de la journée j'emploie
toujours le conditionnel mais serait
entre 550 et 590 000 manifestants ça
veut dire une baisse substantielle ça
veut dire que on aura là la septième
plus grosse manifestation sur les 11
journées de mobilisation si on effectue
un classement voilà de la plus forte
mobilisation 7 mars à la plus faible le
aujourd'hui ce 6 avril se classerait à
la septième place sur 11 donc on est
dans une moyenne un petit peu basse
voilà c'est ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui parmi et parmi ces
mobilisations il y a celle à Paris dans
les rues de la capitale où nous envoyés
spéciaux se trouvent cet après-midi
est-ce qu'on a retrouvé Damien et
Canivez Damien il semble que ça bouge
autour de vous
c'est à toi ouais absolument Timothée en
fait les violences ont commencé à
éclater au moment où nous sommes passés
à l'angle du boulevard de Montparnasse
et boulevard Raspail c'est à cet endroit
que se trouve le fameux restaurant La
Rotonde ce nom vous dit très
certainement quelque chose puisque c'est
dans cet établissement de bouche qui
Emmanuel Macron a dîner le soir de son
élection présidentielle de la première
élection présidentielle au terme du
second tour et à ce moment-là
effectivement des des jets de de
projectiles ont plus sur sur les forces
de l'ordre qui se sont déployées en
masse devant cette cet établissement et
le cortège maintenant effectivement est
à l'arrêt parce que il y a effectivement
des exactions qui sont commises ici
boulevard de Montparnasse des poubelles
sont en feu les braves aiment vous savez
cette unité motorisée de la préfecture
de police de Paris c'est déployé au
niveau de ce boulevard de Montparnasse
pour venir en aide aux forces mobiles
qui sont ici et une charge de la police
vous voyez sous vos yeux est en train
d'avoir lieu pour justement essayer de
disperser ces fauteurs de troubles qui
lance un pavé bouteille en verre et
autres et autres projectiles qu'ils ont
susceptibles de blesser des forces de
l'or alors ce cortège est scindé en deux
en réalité vous voyez là il y a des
projectiles qui pleuvent aïe parce que
justement
figurez-vous que on est en train de
force de l'ordre et les Blacks donc
c'est assez compliqué et c'est les bras
qui sont effectivement prises pour cible
et c'est une unité qui est
particulièrement décrié vous le savez en
ce moment en raison ben voilà de de des
violences policières présumées voilà
c'est c'est ce que disent beaucoup de
d'éléments radicaux qui sont en train de
les prendre pour cible beaucoup
demandent d'ailleurs leur dissolution
chose que le préfet de police a mis de
côté assez vite et là vous voyez qu'ils
sont en train de se replier parce qu'il
y a énormément de de militants ultra
violents ici sur ce boulevard de
Montparnasse vous voyez la rotonde là
qui se trouve juste à côté qui se trouve
sur la gauche de votre image et c'est
voilà c'est policiers sont en de de
battre en retraite quelque part et je
peux vous dire qu'ici les les
projectiles sont nombreux les poubelles
manifestement n'ont pas été vidés au
cours de la nuit et les les manifestants
d'ultra gauche sont en train de s'en
servir comme projectiles contre les
forces de l'ordre voilà c'est assez
violent ce qui se passe ici dans les
rues de la capitale les services de
renseignement territoriaux attendaient
entre 500 et 1000 casseurs mais écoutez
je peux vous assurer qui sont ils sont
ici sur cette sur ce boulevard des des
de Montparnasse juste en face donc de la
rotonde établissement je vous rappelle
ou Emmanuel Macron a fêté sa première
élection présidentielle
merci beaucoup Damien canive
effectivement c'est quelques mouvements
vous faites attention à vous bien
évidemment pas de risque
inutile Arthur bijouta on parlait de
cette manifestation donc vous disiez une
manifestation un peu moins suivie que
que lors de des précédents en tous les
cas une manifestation un mouvement de
contestation moins suivi mais qui
concerne toujours les grandes et les
petites villes tout à fait Timothée on
peut voir de nombreuses encore de
nombreuses manifestations partout en
France je prends l'exemple des grandes
villes on a quand même des grandes
villes qui maintiennent un certain
niveau de mobilisation pardon je viens
avec les chiffres tout récents de Lyon
qui indique 13000 personnes selon la
préfecture du Rhône c'était 12500 la
dernière fois c'était un petit peu plus
même mobilisation à Bordeaux 10000
personnes même mobilisation à Marseille
10000 ou 11000 personnes donc ça reste
quand même encore assez important mais
surtout c'est qu'après 10 journées de
mobilisation on est quand même à la 11e
journée de mobilisation on a encore de
nouvelles de nouveaux lieux de
manifestations qui apparaissent sur
notre carte je pense par exemple à une
petite ville du Nord qui s'appelle Lolo
Emery où il y avait pas une
manifestation il y en a une ce matin il
y avait 300-350 personnes c'est peu mais
ça montre encore que que le mouvement et
que la mobilisation contre cette réforme
des retraites est encore assez dynamique
et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est
c'est nouveau mouvement comme ça qui qui
émerge de certaines villes alors parfois
vous avez des questions de lieu on
alterne entre la voilà vous avez deux ou
trois villes moyennes qui sont côte à
côte donc on alterne les mobilisations
des fois deux d'un côté deux de l'autre
et puis on fait la troisième dans la
troisième ville il y a des éléments
comme ça mais parfois c'est parfois la
manifestation départementale reste assez
loin pour les gens c'est 30 40 50 km de
de voiture et bah on connaît le prix de
l'essence les difficultés à se déplacer
ben on se dit plutôt faire une petite
mobilisation plutôt répartir toute la
mobilisation que de faire une une grosse
manifestation départementale donc ça a
des éléments comme ça une autre menace
brandie par les syndicats c'est celle
des blocages on a le sentiment malgré
tout que ça va mieux que le pays n'est
pas si bloqué que que ça aujourd'hui non
le pays n'est pas bloqué mais on a quand
même des petits des petits points de
tension entre guillemets qu'on avait pas
lors des premières mobilisations je me
souviens fin janvier même au courant du
mois de février jusqu'au 7 mars jusqu'à
l'appel des syndicats bloqués le pays
les manifestations vraiment étaient
étaient bonnes enfants on sent les
observateurs étaient presque surpris
d'un d'un tel contexte d'une telle belle
ambiance entre guillemets dans les
cortèges ça a changé un petit peu après
le 7 mars on a vu plus de blocages et là
depuis trois quatre cinq manifestations
vous voyez beaucoup plus des blocages de
rond-point le matin des usines bloquées
des raffineries bloquées des
usines de gaz bloqués etc etc chose
qu'on ne voyait absolument pas
débarrasser des opérations pH ouverts
des choses comme ça qu'on ne voyait
absolument pas il y a ne serait-ce que
que qu'un mois voilà on va aller faire
un tour sur le terrain vous le voyez sur
ces images on voit d'un côté ces images
en haut à gauche ça c'est là où se
trouve Damien canivevez avec Julien
Leclerc du côté de la rotonde avec on
l'a dit cette situation assez confuse
qui semble malgré tout se calmer un
petit peu en ce moment voilà ces images
tournées par Julien Leclerc on va aller
voir Vincent roseron qui lui se trouve
un petit peu plus en arrière dans le
cortège et on voit que la manifestation
semble comme de coutume d'ailleurs avec
avec un premier cortège où il y a
quelques mouvements épars de violence et
à l'arrière et bien ça semble assez
calme est-ce que vous le confirmez
Vincent
oui effectivement Timothée jusqu'à tout
s'est très calme dans ce cortège des
champs alors on voit quand même des des
tags sur les murs là on peut les voir on
a vu des des hakabs comme parler des des
ballons des tags comme ils écrivent
Cornavin il y en a le long de ce pouvoir
des Invalides on est plutôt au début de
la manifestation a toujours il y a un
tour Montparnasse qui est un peu plus
loin vers là-bas mais on l'a toujours
pas atteint mais en tout cas à part
c'est c'est tags qu'on voit sur les murs
aucune casse on ne voit aucune casse on
ne voit aucun mouvement de débordement
ici tout est calme
merci beaucoup Vincent et c'est vrai
qu'on préfère quand ça se passe dans ces
conditions là Arthur bijouta sur les les
mouvements de blocage on a bien compris
ce que vous nous disiez mais pour ce qui
est des transports là aussi il sent que
ça aille mieux oui effectivement ce
matin si vous êtes parisien et que vous
avez pris le métro vous n'avez pas dû
voir une grande différence avec les
journées entre guillemets normales
à l'exception de trois lignes si ma
mémoire est bonne dont la ligne 3 donc
oui un trafic normal à la SNCF pareil je
crois 3 TGV sur 4
circulaient aujourd'hui donc
effectivement même dans dans les
transports mais même dans la plupart des
autres secteurs je pense à l'éducation
également les taux de grévistes qu'on
analyse avec avec soin également chez
fig data on voit qu'ils sont quand même
beaucoup beaucoup plus faibles je crois
que le taux de grévise se situe autour
de 7 ou 8% dans l'éducation nationale
pour vous donner un ordre de comparaison
c'était 32 % de 7 mars donc vous voyez
c'est pas du tout la même chose mais ça
n'empêche pas
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de sans plomb tout
simplement pour résumer pour résumer en
quelques mots et la situation
s'améliorer quelque peu puisque les deux
grandes raffineries qui alimentent la
région parisienne et le centre Val de
Loire qui sont les deux raffineries
normandes de port Jérôme et de
Gonfreville c'était remise à fonctionner
à Port Jérôme ça remarchait bien depuis
mardi à Gonfreville il y avait des
réquisitions lundi mais la justice
aujourd'hui a annulé l'arrêté de
réquisition à Gonfreville donc les
réquisitions devraient s'arrêter si tout
est correctement effectué si tout est
suivi donc bon la situation reste quand
même risque d'être encore tendu au moins
jusqu'en début de semaine prochaine pour
les automobilistes Franceville au-delà
de cela carmélis disait tout à l'heure
il faut tenir en gros il faut tenir une
semaine jusqu'à cette décision du
Conseil constitutionnel est-ce qu'on a
une idée de ce qu'il va se passer la
semaine d'après ou bien c'est trop trop
tôt pour le dire alors ce qu'on va dans
les petites population dans les dans les
toutes petites villes dans les dans les
villes moyennes c'est que on appelle
d'ores et déjà des rassemblements le 14
avril le jour du de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel mais l'Inter
syndical devrait devrait annoncer une
nouvelle mobilisation une douzième
journée de mobilisation
interprofessionnelle mercredi ou jeudi
en tout cas avant la décision du du
Conseil du Conseil constitutionnel pour
pour maintenir la pression pour pour
continuer le mouvement social merci
infiniment Arthur bijoutin Merci à VOUS
Timothée du Figaro data pour ses
précieux chiffres allez on retourne tout
de suite sur le terrain parce que vous
l'avez vu sur ces images c'est au niveau
de la rotonde que hélas quelques
mouvements de violence sont en train de
d'éclater on va aller voir Damien et
Canivez qui se trouve sur place Damien
le cortège est-il toujours sain dérangé
ou bien est-ce que il commence à
repartir de l'avant
ouais
non pas du tout on est vraiment le
cortège et scindé en deux et là c'est en
train de se tendre encore plus ici au
niveau de de la rotonde vous pouvez le
constater ce restaurant où à dîner
Emmanuel Macron le soir de sa première
élection à la présidence de la
République et pris pour cible vous avez
vu une pluie de projectile qui s'est
abattu tout à l'heure sur les forces de
l'ordre qui ont quand même réussi à se
frayer à chemin et à faire quelques
charges là il y a une première charge
des des forces de l'ordre et là voilà
ils sont en train de ratisser large et
nous on est obligé de faire très
attention aussi à nous puisque c'est
très difficile de faire la différence
entre des journalistes et des
manifestants ici puisque nous sommes
tous casqués avec des masques à gaz pour
éviter de respirer les grenades
lacrymogènes et la Rotonde est en train
d'être en flamme la rotonde le
restaurant ou à dîner Emmanuel Macron
est enflamme actuellement en tout cas
une partie de la de de du tissu qui
recouvre ce restaurant en fait c'est un
fumigène qui a été lancé sur cet espace
et le feu c'est tout de suite propagé au
niveau donc de cet endroit vous le sur
les images tournées par Julien Leclerc
les forces de l'ordre ont beau
effectivement être déployés en masse
autour de ce restaurant c'est très
compliqué pour eux d'assurer pour elle
pardon d'assurer la sécurité autour de
de ce bâtiment on a une employée aussi
qui se trouve au premier étage de cette
de de cet établissement qui essaye
justement d'utiliser un extincteur pour
éteindre le feu et éviter que ça se
propage à d'autres endroits mais c'est
très compliqué les pompiers aussi vont
avoir du mal à se frayer un chemin ici
au niveau au niveau de la manifestation
puisque les forces de l'ordre sont
devant et essayent de protéger cet
endroit les manifestants sont ultra
violents ici sur ce boulevard du
Montparnasse je rappelle que nous sommes
à Paris dans le dans la capitale à
l'angle du boulevard Raspail et vous le
voyez le feu est en train de se propager
les forces de l'ordre essaie de
dissuader cette dame très certainement
d'agir puisque elle va être lassive très
certainement de projectile on rappelle
que c'est cet établissement est très
symbolique pour les manifestants d'ultra
gauche puisque c'est ici qu'Emmanuel
Macron à dîner ça c'est effectivement
les conséquences d'un fumigène qui a été
lancée tout à l'heure parmi tous les
projectiles je peux vous assurer ici que
c'est une pluie de verre qui se trouve
sous nos pieds des bouteilles ont été
jetées en nombre tout à l'heure les
forces de l'ordre des bravesmes sont
juste derrière moi effectivement ils
sont en train de regarder ce qui se
passe c'est très court c'est c'est très
très bizarre l'ambiance ici pour être
honnête avec vous Timothée parce qu'on a
le sentiment que les forces de l'ordre
ne peuvent absolument rien faire contre
ces manifestants qui sont entre 500 et
1000 entre certainement les forces de
l'ordre qui battent en retraite
actuellement qui sont pourtant nombreux
mais ce sont les militants les militants
d'ultra gauche là qui sont en train de
courir après ces forces de l'ordre alors
peut-être pour les aspirer un peu plus
sur le boulevard de Montparnasse afin
que voilà ce black bloc se disperse un
petit peu mais manifestement c'est c'est
ces éléments de l'ultra gauche sont bien
compris la stratégie des policiers qui
restent très très groupés et qui ne se
disperse pas voilà donc les pompiers qui
finalement on réussit à se frayer un
chemin parmi les manifestants et les
forces de l'ordre qui sont à coller
finalement face à cette rotonde et qui
heureusement ne sont pas l'objet pour
l'instant en tout cas de de projectile
mais le feu en tout cas est en train de
ronger un peu plus cette toile qui se
trouve au niveau de la Rotonde et les
pavés en continu à pleuvoir c'est c'est
très dangereux là pour les policiers
d'ailleurs même nous journalistes on a
on fait très attention puisque nous
trouvons vraiment juste au niveau au
pied de de la Rotonde et je peux vous
dire que voilà les les pavés non
n'arrive pas forcément à la destination
à la destination voulue voilà vous voyez
aussi ces casques blancs qui sont les
membres de la brave m cette brigade
motor brigade motorisée de la préfecture
de police de Paris qui brigade qui est
très très décrié puisque voilà ils font
ils sont accusés de commettre ce que
certains appellent des des violences
policières voilà ils sont partis en
retraite là en tout cas et les forces
mobile sont sur ce boulevard de
Montparnasse en train de voilà de de
d'attendre peut-être que les pompiers
fassent comment dire face leur travail
voilà Timothée pour l'ambiance là les
esprits se sont un petit peu calmés vous
voyez là-bas ce black bloc qui reste
bien compact et qui n'a pas forcément
l'intention de se désunir des barricades
vont être construites aussi à cet
endroit là au niveau du boulevard de
Montparnasse des des éléments de
chantier ont été
réquisitionnés par par ces militants
d'ultra gauche pour très certainement
voilà les utiliser contre contre les
forces de leur les pompiers sont
parvenus aussi à monter au premier étage
de du restaurant pour réussir à à
éteindre le feu mais surtout aussi pour
rester un peu en sécurité à l'abri des
pavés puisque les les pompiers sont dans
ces cortèges contre la manifestation des
retraites très respectées puisque il
manifeste aussi en nombre contre cette
réforme qui est considérée par certains
de ses pompiers comme injustes donc ils
n'ont pas l'habitude d'être pris pour
cible comme ça avait été le cas lors de
la crise des gilets jaunes souvenez-vous
mais là disons que c'est assez compliqué
pour d'évoluer tant la Rotonde est un
établissement symbolique aux yeux de ses
militants ultra violents
merci beaucoup Damien Canivez de nous
avoir fait vivre cette événement Marie
Viso que j'accueille en plateau
rédactrice en chef ou Figaro économique
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous c'est assez dommage de voir
ses images d'autant que ça ne fait les
affaires de personnes effectivement vous
avez raison c'est dommage tout se
passait plutôt bien
ce qu'on est ce qu'on est en train de
voir la ces images
gâche un peu la fête en tout cas la fête
des syndicats qui pour l'instant avaient
réussi à bien mener leur barque alors
effectivement on le dit la rotonde
endroit symbolique
moi ce que je remarque c'est on est à
quelques encablures d'un autre endroit
symbolique qui est l'hôpital Necker qui
est l'Hôpital des Enfants Malades et si
je me souviens bien les gilets jaunes
avaient commencé à perdre le soutien
de la population enfin les mouvements
avaient commencé à être moins soutenus
le jour où il s'était enfin ou des
événements avaient eu lieu autour de
Necker cet hôpital des enfants malades
il faut faire attention voilà c'est ça
veut dire que ce type d'événement peut
peut-être retourner l'opinion publique
qui on le sait est majoritairement
défavorable à cette réforme mais qui
pourrait en avoir marre de voir ce type
d'image je pense que la rotonde retourne
pas le retourne pas le l'opinion
publique
l'hôpital Necker oui en tout cas les
syndicats vous en avez parlé ils ont
rencontré hier et Isabelle borne on a le
sentiment que d'un côté comme de l'autre
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus reculer et
ben c'est exactement ça c'est à dire que
les syndicats ne reviendront pas sur
leur position ils veulent se retrait des
64 ans on en a largement parlé vous
l'avez largement commenté et le
gouvernement il a sa il a sa réforme il
tient son son son
64 ans de réformateur il reviendra pas
non plus en arrière ça on l'a bien
compris hier autour de la table ils ont
tous religieusement demander à la fin de
leur intervention à Elisabeth borne si
elle était prête à recul à reculer sur
ce point et à retirer sa réforme fin de
non-recevoir donc
le dialogue retour
continue et en même temps il y a il y a
plus de dialogues sur ce point donc
évidemment il y a plus de dialogues de
sourds sourd pardon chacun campe sur ses
positions à partir du moment où on sait
que chacun campe sur ces conditions
est-ce que c'était le bon timing pour le
gouvernement d'organiser cette rencontre
la veille une journée de manifestation
d'ampleur moi j'ai envie de poser la
question différemment c'est ce qu'il
avait le choix est-ce qu'il fallait pas
à un moment quand même montrer ce signe
non pas de réconciliation parce qu'il y
a pas de réconciliation entre le
gouvernement et les syndicats on l'a vu
hier à la sortie de Matignon les mots et
ont été dur de la part des partenaires
sociaux enfin des des syndicats
ils devaient recevoir ça faisait
longtemps qu'il n'avait pas été reçu qui
avait pas eu un dialogue
Elisabeth burnes espéré pouvoir parler
d'autre chose alors c'était un peu vain
elle avait en tête
calendrier de réforme qui aurait pu être
abordé tout en sachant que à partir du
moment où la question des 64 ans serait
au cœur des discussions ce serait très
compliqué voilà c'est tout ça tourne un
petit peu un petit peu en rond et
maintenant sur cette réforme c'est le
temps qui va enfin je pense que c'est le
temps qui va jouer
on a la le Conseil constitutionnel la
semaine prochaine qui va
approuver censurer partiellement on sait
pas on sait pas très bien on n'est pas
constitutionnaliste le texte qui
pourrait être promulgué bon à un moment
il faudra se reparler il faudra se
remettre autour d'une table il faudra
passer à autre chose le temps peut
blesser les plaies mais ce temps n'est
pas encore venu le temps n'est pas
encore venu mais c'est vrai que c'est un
temps en tout cas celui que nous vivons
aujourd'hui qui risque de coûter cher à
la fois pour les grévistes mais
également pour pour le pays est-ce qu'on
a une idée de combien ça coûte une grève
d'ampleur comme ça sur plusieurs mois
alors
macroéconomiquement au sens du PIB du
pays ça coûte pas grand chose on a des
études de l'Insee qui nous disent c'est
un ou deux dixième de points de PIB sur
un trimestre
donc ça ne ça ne plondre pas
fondamentalement la croissance du pays
après évidemment que les commerçants qui
se trouvent
sur les trajets des manifestations et
qui pour la 11e journée ou ferme le
rideau ou voit leur commerce
désertés ou leur restaurant vide ou les
terrasses il fait beau aujourd'hui
[Musique]
s'entourent sans personne pour consommer
pour eux bien sûr que ça a des
conséquences on en a fait un sujet dans
le dans le Figaro économie de ce matin
que j'invite tout le monde que j'invite
à lire effectivement les commerçants ils
en ont ras le bol parce que tirer le
rideau pour eux c'est une journée de
chiffre d'affaires en moins
c'est un manque à gagner
ce qui crame il faut le racheter donc
oui ça a des conséquences ça a des
conséquences très concrètes et puis ce
qu'on explique aussi dans notre dans
notre enquête de ce matin c'est ça a des
conséquences qu'on ne mesure pas encore
complètement sur l'image de la France à
l'étranger alors évidemment c'est ce que
j'allais vous demander à l'international
investisseur
les images se baladent partout
évidemment c'est pas notre gloire de
voir ses poubelles en feu à la une des
journaux anglaises anglo-saxons c'est
évidemment très mauvais en terme d'image
pour l'instant les investisseurs
internationaux c'est-à-dire les
entreprises étrangères les financiers
ils sont résilients c'est-à-dire ils
sont pragmatiques ils résonnent en
termes de business pour eux le pays un
n'est pas à feu à 100 on a ces images là
cet après-midi mais ça ne modifie pas la
structure et les bases du pays donc pour
l'instant les projets d'investissement
très productifs très très concrets sont
parmi en cause bon il faudrait pas que
ça dure trop longtemps ça reste des
mouvements évidemment de violence on met
des mouvements localisés je voudrais
qu'on parle Marie des chantiers à venir
du gouvernement vous parliez tout à
l'heure vous avez commencé à l'aborder
cette future loi la loi pleine emploi
d'abord de quoi il s'agit là alors il va
y avoir deux choses dans les semaines à
venir que le gouvernement va mettre sur
la table de mettre sur la table il va y
avoir d'abord dans un premier temps et
assez rapidement
une proposition de loi de la majorité
sur le partage de la valeur alors le
partage de la valeur
le partage de la valeur c'est en gros
quand une entreprise gagne mieux sa vie
elle doit en faire davantage bénéficier
c'est salarié il y a quelqu'un c'est la
participation à l'intéressement pour
résumer les choses mais c'est surtout un
accord qui a été passé il y a quelques
semaines entre le patronat et le saint
et les syndicats qui très judicieusement
alors qu'on était déjà en plein débat
sur les retraites sont soumis d'accord
sur un texte sur les modalités de faire
davantage participer les salariés au
profit des entreprises
et qui ont mis donc sur la table un
texte parapher par tous pour montrer au
gouvernement voilà vous voyez quand il
faut parler de choses importantes nous
on sait discutés contrairement à votre
assemblée un peu désordonné si je veux
dire les choses pudiquement
donc il va y avoir une proposition de
loi qui va retranscrire le texte qui a
été trouvé par les partenaires sociaux
il y a quelques il y a quelques semaines
et ensuite dans un deuxième temps cette
loi pleine emploi
dont les contours sont quand même assez
floues on a les grandes têtes de
chapitre le nouveau France travail qui
alors c'est le nouveau pôle emploi mais
qui sous une nouvelle bannière c'est une
refonte de potenti une refonte de Pôle
emploi et d'autres
instances publiques que tout ça va se
fondre sous une marque commune en fait
bon
je vais pas dire que c'est artificiel
mais on s'attaque à l'emploi il va y
avoir les le le l'emploi des seniors il
va y avoir le compte épargnector
universel il va y avoir RSA contre
activité voilà on essaye de passer à
autre chose dans ce dans cette loi
pleine emploi bon l'instant c'est pas
complètement gagné pour l'instant c'est
pas gagné on va aller voir Damien
Canivez sur le terrain on voit depuis
tout à l'heure vos images celles en tout
cas de Julien Leclerc qui était avec
vous Damien est-ce que la situation est
revenue à la normale
pas du tout pas du tout et je peux vous
dire que là la tension est à son comble
parce que nous sommes boulevard de
Montparnasse et la police est en train
de d'essayer de trouver une une
stratégie pour se frayer un chemin sur
ce boulevard du Montparnasse puisque de
toute depuis tout à l'heure ils sont
acculés dans les rues perpendiculaires
sans pouvoir forcément
disperser les militants radicaux qui
sont en train de les caillasser depuis
tout à l'heure alors là nous sommes
vraiment à 5 mètres de la rotonde il
faut le savoir la rotonde qui a été
l'objet tout à l'heure d'un incendie à
la suite d'un jeu de fumigène et de
plusieurs jets de projectiles et là les
policiers voilà sont en train de sont en
train de de charger et là je dois vous
avouer que c'est très très tendu il faut
que l'on parte parce que nous sommes
voilà aussi dans le groupe finalement de
de casseurs malgré nous puisque
ils se sont déplacés assez vite sur ce
boulevard de Montparnasse alors voilà là
les policiers tendent vraiment de voilà
tente vraiment de à l'aide de grenades
de désencerclement et de grenades
lacrymogènes
de faire en sorte que ce black bloc se
sarde en plusieurs morceaux pour
diminuer les maîtriser puisque depuis
tout à l'heure ces militants sont
extrêmement compacts sur sur
ce bancaires c'est la les pompiers qui
viennent d'intervenir pour éteindre un
feu qui se trouvait au niveau d'un
élément de chantier qui a été utilisé
pour faire barrage aux forces de l'ordre
là vous voyez un abribus qui a été
totalement pulvérisé c'est une situation
très chaotique ici à cet endroit devant
devant pardon je suis un petit peu
déconcentré justement par ces policiers
qui sont en train de reculer et qui
tentent de voilà de contrôler cette
cette
foule de militants qui sont en train
toujours de jeter des pavés ici sur ce
boulevard de Montparnasse alors voilà la
rotonde vous la voyez aussi sur sur les
images filmées par Julien Leclerc elle a
été malmenée cette cette vitrine cette
cette toile aussi qui qui se trouve
juste au-dessus de ce restaurant puisque
à l'incendie s'est déclaré il y a eu
beaucoup de jeux de projectiles vous les
voyez au sol d'ailleurs ces projectiles
c'est débris de verre c'est ils sont ils
ont plus par dizaines mais les policiers
voilà sont réussis ont réussi à protéger
plus ou moins quand même malgré tout cet
établissement ou aucune intrusion pour
l'instant n'a eu lieu mais on sent
vraiment que les Black Blocs ont enfin
que c'est c'est militant d'ultra gauche
ont très certainement élaboré une sorte
de stratégie quand même pour pour
pouvoir nuire au à cet établissement
parce que ce n'est pas la première fois
que l'on passe devant ce restaurant dans
le cadre des manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites c'était arrivé à
plusieurs reprises et à chaque fois un
cordon de policier se trouve devant mais
c'est la première fois que ce restaurant
est à ce point vandalisé voilà vous
entendez les slogans classique tout le
monde déteste la police qu'ils aient qui
sont scandés alors que là des des pavés
pleuvent derrière les les derrière les
nuages de de pompiers on ne voit pas
grand chose ici voyez sur les images de
Julien Leclerc que les pompiers sont en
train d'intervenir il y a également des
des manifestants qui ont glissé dans un
mouvement de foule et qui sont tombés au
sol le problème c'est qu'au sol se
trouve des centaines de milliers de
débris de verre et que c'est extrêmement
dangereux vous imaginez bien lorsque
l'on tombe sur un tapis aussi coupant
voilà là il y a des gaz lacrymogènes qui
sont en train de
noyer le boulevard de Montparnasse donc
voilà Timothée on va essayer nous de
nous mettre sur le côté et de revenir
vers vous assez aussi vite que possible
effectivement sur ces images tournées
par Julien Leclerc les sapeurs-pompiers
de Paris qui tentent d'intervenir du
côté donc de cette brasserie de la
rotonde sur le boulevard du Montparnasse
à l'angle précisément entre le boulevard
des Montparnasse et le boulevard Raspail
des images qui contrastent avec celles
quelques mètres plus loin où se trouve
Vincent roseron avec une manifestante
Vincent à quel endroit vous trouvez-vous
précisément et puis et bien dites nous
ce que cette manifestant pense de tous
ces événements
alors je suis boulevard Montparnasse il
y a la tour voilà ce qui est juste à
côté donc on est pas non plus si loin
que ça de de Damien Canivez on doit être
un peu plus de 500 mètres mais nous
comme on disait tout à l'heure
l'ambiance est très calme ça change et
je suis avec Lucas qui a manifestant
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous pourquoi
pour vous c'était important d'être là
aujourd'hui
il était une nouvelle dégradation du
système de retraite
vous avez toutes fait ces manifestations
pratiquement oui j'ai dû en rater une ou
deux mais ça doit être ma neuve ième
très bien le aujourd'hui vers vous le il
y a eu 49-3 est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on y
croit encore du côté des manifestations
est-ce que de votre côté vous forcer
encore que le gouvernement peut reculer
le gouvernement peut reculer il y a des
précédents contrairement à son essaye de
nous dire le plus célèbre c'est le CPE
ou une loi même promulguée n'a pas été
appliquée puis a été abrogé oui donc là
vous pensez que ça pourrait être ça
pourrait encore arriver une nouvelle
fois clairement oui très bien merci
beaucoup
voilà vous savez en tout cas garder le
enfin qui qui pense en tout cas lui que
ça va être bon même encore un mois après
il faisait référence au CPE en tout cas
là actuellement le cortège est bloqué
nous n'avançons plus depuis une dizaine
de minutes en fait ça avance sur les
côtés mais le cortège principal lui et
lui est bloqué et
ben alors comme je vous le disais ça par
rapport à ce qui se passe devant on a
pas du tout on a aucune idée de ce qui
se passe devant donc de ce côté là c'est
très calme
merci beaucoup Vincent Rosemont avec
comme malheureusement d'habitude et bien
une manifestation deux ambiances on a
bien compris Marie Viso je reviens avec
vous sur cette sur cette loi pleine
emploi qui pourrait arriver qui devrait
arriver en tous les cas au Parlement il
y a une des mesures que vous avez
pensionné c'est ce revenu universel
contractivité
Emmanuel Macron ça fait longtemps qu'il
en parle de cette mesure
ça fait longtemps qu'il en parle parce
que
d'un principe qu'il ne faut pas que
l'inactivité rapporte autant voire plus
que le travail il est là dans la lignée
de de ces prédécesseurs
et effectivement
cette cet aspect d'assistanat il en
parle depuis très longtemps donc les
modalités de ce de ce revenu universel
elles ont été une première fois discuter
puis ça n'allait pas donc ils en ont
énormément discuté avant de passer
complètement complètement à autre chose
je me trompe pas on nous avait dit au
début quand vous voulez fusionner APL et
minima sociaux
puis abandonné puis révoquer là c'est
pas dans c'est c'est plus dans les
tuyaux encore une fois
on ne sait pas ce qui va être mis dans
cette loi et notamment parce que le
gouvernement veut reprendre complètement
les discussions avec avec les
partenaires sociaux patronnesses mais le
concept de se dire oui on va faire
travailler
contre contre RSA oui ça ça semble à qui
loi pleine emploi d'ici à 2027 ça veut
dire quoi c'est en termes de chômage
aujourd'hui on est à 7%, c'est ça
autour de autour de 5 sachant que
effectivement le chômage a beaucoup
baissé ces trois dernières années mais
que passer de 7 à 5 c'est le plus
difficile parce que il faut aller
chercher ceux qui sont le plus éloigné
de l'emploi ceux qui ont plus de
difficultés à retrouver des jobs donc 7
à 5 c'est beaucoup plus difficile que 10
à 7 ou 9 à 7 ça reste atteignable ou ça
va être compliqué
il faut toujours voilà il y a des il y a
des jeunes il y a de l'argent qui est
mis sur la formation
l'alternance fonctionne bien on peut
rester un tout petit peu optimiste
là-dessus mais ce sera pas facile c'est
un vrai défi le 5%. merci beaucoup
rédactrice en chef au service économie
du Figaro on retourne sur le terrain
parce qu'il se passe des choses en ce
moment et notamment du côté de
Damien Canivez avec cette brasserie de
la rotonde qui était tout à l'heure
cible de projectile de la part des
manifestants Damien est-ce que la
situation est toujours aussi confuse
elle est confuse un peu moins violente
que tout à l'heure même si au moment où
je prends la parole Timothée en abribus
vient de tomber en ruine vous voyez les
pompiers ils manifestent également il se
trouve à cet endroit là sur la gauche de
votre écran là je veux dire Leclerc qui
s'apprête justement à braquer sa caméra
ils sont toujours acclamés ces pompiers
dans les manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites parce que
justement ils sont très visibles et ils
sont toujours là voilà c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous avez vu tout à
l'heure des pompiers qui intervenaient
malgré tout sur le restaurant La Rotonde
et ils ont été évidemment respectés par
les militants même les plus radicaux
alors là des jets de pavés pleuvent
toujours vous voyez ces militants qui
sont là alors là nous avons quitté le
boulevard de Montparnasse se trouver la
rotonde nous sommes désormais boulevard
Raspail nous continuons donc
l'itinéraire qui était initialement
prévu par la préfecture de police de
Paris en réalité une charge policière
tout à l'heure vous l'avez vu puisque
nous avons été noyé dans les gaz
lacrymogènes une charge policière ou a
permis à ses militants de s'engouffrer
sur le boulevard Raspail et donc de
donner un peu plus d'air au niveau du
boulevard de Montparnasse une une pétard
vient d'éclater juste à côté juste à
côté de nous et voilà donc le cortège
poursuit sa route très lentement puisque
notre point de chute je vous rappelle
c'est la place d'Italie donc il reste
encore beaucoup de chemin à faire c'est
une manifestation particulièrement
longue aujourd'hui dans les rues de
Paris plus de 5 km d'habitude et encore
plus lors de la dernière manifestation
qui a eu lieu le mardi de la semaine
dernière c'était moins de 3 km donc
c'était très très rapide cette fois-ci
elle est beaucoup plus longue cette
manifestation et on passe souvent des
endroits effectivement très symboliques
je vous ai cité tout à l'heure le
ministère du Travail la rue de Grenelle
qui se trouvait pas très loin de
l'Esplanade des Invalides on est passé
également devant le ministère des
outre-mer et la rotonde qui est
effectivement ce cet endroit le plus
symbolique peut-être de la manifestation
et en tout cas qui était à coup sûr de
toute façon la cible de ces militants
extrêmement violents alors là vous voyez
un cordon de policier qui bloque
finalement ce boulevard Raspail et qui
permet quelque part d'encadrer ces
militants de façon à ce qui ne partent
pas en manifestation sauvage déjà dans
les rues alentours mais surtout sur ce
boulevard Raspail le fait d'encadrer
cette manifestation vous voyez ça les
permet finalement de les contenir et de
mieux les charger à partir du moment où
l'étend ou la tension commence à devenir
à devenir un petit peu suffocante oui
voilà là voilà des pavés évidemment
continuent à pleuvoir sur sur les forces
de l'ordre donc on peut s'attendre et
c'est logique à une charge des des
forces de l'ordre qui sont juste en face
de nous c'est la police nationale qui
est encadre ce cortège tout à l'heure
vous avez vu les membres de la brave m
qui sont extrêmement mobiles en raison
de leur nature puisque c'est brave m
c'est la brigade motorisée de la
préfecture de police de Paris vous voyez
une charge de la police justement qui a
lieu pour essayer de scinder ce cortège
et faire en sorte que que ce black bloc
se disloque même si je vous parle de
Black Bloc on peut pas vraiment parler
de Black Bloc au moment où je vous parle
en tout cas puisque il y a des gilets
jaunes un petit peu radicaux qui se sont
greffés à ce groupe et qui ne sont pas
des Black Blocs il y a également des
jeunes on voit peut-être des univers des
étudiants qui sont aussi dans dans ce
dans ce groupe donc c'est c'est assez
hétéroclite en termes de profil ici vous
voyez on n'est pas sur comment dire un
black bloc comme on a l'habitude de le
voir avec ses codes et c'est et ses
mœurs si j'ose dire cette fois-ci nous
sommes vraiment avec voilà des des
militants tout simplement en colère et
qui ont décidé de passer à la violence
après
on le rappelle 11 journées de
manifestation dans les rues de Paris
merci beaucoup me donner tes nouvelles
vous continuez évidemment de suivre ces
événements mais bien sûr vous faites
attention à vous pas de risque
inutile j'accueille dinakwen du service
politique donc bonjour dynam merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Dina vous
signez précisément une enquête ce matin
dans le dans le Figaro sur ces jeunes et
qui s'égarent dans la nébuleuse antifa
jeune ou moins jeune en tout cas ces
éléments et bien qui adoptent des
méthodes comme celles que l'on vient de
voir à l'écran qui sont qui sont ces
personnes alors en effet je consigne une
enquête avec mon collègue Vladimir car
c'est un garçon qui est actuellement
dans la manifestation qui les a toutes
faites depuis le début alors qui sont
ces jeunes c'est assez compliqué de
répondre à cette question justement
parce que ce sont des groupes très très
nébuleux comme on le disait c'est
difficile de les identifier ils se
laissent très peu approcher aussi
notamment par la presse ils sont très
fermés
on va les voir en manifestation même en
manifestation c'est difficile de les
approcher parce qu'ils veulent pas
répondre ils veulent pas être vu par des
caméras ils veulent pas être pris en
photo en vidéo mais ce qu'on constate
c'est qu'en fait il y a un discours qui
porte une radicalité donc ces groupes
antifascistes qui sont des groupes qui
ont qui ont toujours existé qui existe
depuis les années 30 c'est quelque chose
de classique mais la nouveauté c'est que
de plus en plus on va employer le terme
de manière extrêmement hyperbolique
c'est-à-dire qu'on va désigner Emmanuel
Macron par exemple comme étant un
fasciste l'État comme étant fasciste la
police comme étant le symbole suprême du
fascisme et en fait ce discours il a un
certain écho auprès de certains jeunes
qui sont justement ce qu'on va retrouver
dans ces manifestations qui sont entrées
plus massivement dans le mouvement au
moment où il y a eu le recours à
l'article 49 alinéa 3
et depuis lors on voit davantage de
débordements justement parce qu'il y a
ces groupes donc une fois de plus qu'on
a du mal à identifier vous y trouver des
Black Blocs mais comme disait Damien qui
est sur le terrain il y a aussi des gens
il y a aussi des gilets jaunes le
discours antifasciste était beaucoup
repris pendant le mouvement des gilets
jaunes puis vous avez aussi des
étudiants qui sont un visage découvert
et qui vont entonner des slows des
champs des slogans antifascistes pendant
les mobilisations et qui au moment des
montées en tension vont un peu se
mélanger ça va se transformer en une
masse ou il y aura ces Black Blocs ces
gilets jaunes ces étudiants c'est pas
vraiment qui et qui il y a des
anarchistes il y a un petit peu de tout
et ça dégénère en violence et
ça touche de plus en plus les cortèges
et c'est aussi quelque chose qui va être
expliqué par certains comme étant un
phénomène logique parce qu'on va dire
que pendant des semaines on a des
cortèges qui se sont menées avec les
syndicats de manière extrêmement
pacifique et démocratique il faut
rappeler que les 8 premières journées
ont été extrêmement calmes avec très peu
de débordements et depuis le
il y a un certain temps qui a adopté par
certains manifestants qui viennent
dénoncer un supposer Tournon autoritaire
et qui font prendre au mouvement un peu
un autre tour non là aussi un tournant
plus violent et ce sont notamment ses
groupes ces jeunes qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à identifier comment est-ce que vous
expliquez cette défiance vous parliez de
la défiance notamment envers les forces
de l'ordre mais aussi envers les médias
c'est vrai que quand on est sur le
terrain on a beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
créer un lien avec ces personnes quel
que soit le média auquel on appartient
pour pour quelle raison je pense qu'on
peut remonter là notamment au gilet
jaune alors ça date d'avance là et c'est
vraiment un phénomène qui qui est qui se
poursuit depuis de nombreuses années
mais les jeunes je pense qu'il y a une
véritable cassure avec les médias on se
souvient qu'il y avait notamment les
journalistes de BFM TV qui devaient être
escortés qui devaient être assistés pour
ne pas être mise en danger pendant les
pendant les manifestations parce qu'on
accusait justement
de transformer les propos des
manifestants de ne pas toujours il y
avait tous ces débats autour de supposés
violences policières on accusait les
médias de montrer qu'une partie de ce
qui se passait en fait c'est juste un
climat ambiant qui tend à s'accroître de
défiance de tout donc on va être
extrêmement méfiant envers les
politiques parce que les politiques ont
pu décevoir et on va totalement associer
les politiques au monde médiatique ça va
être ce monde médiatico-politique donc
on va énormément se méfier avec parfois
aussi des discours politiques qui
encouragent ça je pense notamment à la
France insoumise de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui a pu tenir des discours à l'égard
des médias à l'égard d'un système qui
s'agirait plutôt de de condamner les
vrais de dire que la nuit Pesse
encourage ce type d'action violente
alors c'est peut-être pas de manière
aussi catégorique parce qu'en plus la
nuit pêche d'une certaine manière ça
veut tout et rien dire on a quand même
quatre parties dans la nupaisse et on a
quatre parties qui ont des rapports
extrêmement différent à la violence je
renvoie pour cela notamment à une
analyse de ma conscience Sophie de
Ravinelle qui qui s'est épanchée sur ses
rapports différents qui qui divisent
parfois la nuit Pesse et c'est ce qu'on
a pu voir aussi dans le rapport à ces
assez jeune et assez groupe antifas et
que en fait vous avez des insoumis qui
vous disent que finalement bon c'est pas
si mal qu'il est jeune et qui viennent
avec leur méthode plus violente parce
que ça permet aux mouvements de passer
souffler de rester de rester présent à
un moment où les Français pourraient un
peu en avoir marre se résigner avant
rentrer chez eux et puis en même temps
vous avez des socialistes ou des
communistes qui sont quand même beaucoup
plus clair dans leur rapport à la
violence qui condamne davantage et qui
s'inquiète de ces dérives et vous avez
encore les écologistes ou c'est encore
autre chose parce qu'il y a un rapport à
la désobéissance civile qui est aussi
particulier on l'a vu avec les violences
de sainte Soline ou au nom de l'écologie
on peut faire certaines violences mais
où commence la violence où est placé le
curseur est-ce que c'est de la violence
matérielle est-ce que c'est de la
violence humaine il y a beaucoup de
débats de la nupaisse donc on peut pas
dire que la nuit pèse dans son
intégralité encourage les violences mais
en tout cas une partie de cette alliance
de gauche entretient une grande
ambiguïté par rapport à ces violences
comment réagissent les syndicats à ces
événements ça se fait pas le ça fait pas
le jeu des syndicats parce que ça
décrédibilise le mouvement exactement
c'est pour les syndicats c'est compliqué
c'est un peu la hantise et je vais
renvoyer une fois de plus au gilet jaune
c'est que le problème des mouvements des
gilets jaunes c'est qu'il échappait
totalement au syndicat aucune
organisation traditionnelle n'avait la
main sur les gilets jaunes et on a bien
vu ce que ce que ça a donné on avait
aussi que le mouvement n'avait
n'arrivait pas à se hiérarchiser de
manière interne parce qu'il y avait un
refuge justement de toute figure
d'autorité et donc finalement là les
syndicats sont dans un mouvement qu'ils
ont très bien réussi à cadrer depuis le
début et leur crainte c'est justement
que le mouvement leur échappe à cause de
mouvements de d'éléments plus radicaux
qui qui imprègne les cortèges et
ressenti c'est que ça leur échappe parce
que plus il y a de violence moins en
vérité il y a de gens on profite d'hiver
dans la rue il y avait un samedi au
début de la contestation où vous voyez
des familles qui venaient dans les rues
il y a plus de famille il a quasiment
dans les manifestations parce que ce
n'est plus le ton de cette contestation
en ce moment et justement cette
contestation est bien qui s'affirme dans
les rues et dans les rues de Paris
notamment cet après-midi on va aller
voir Vincent roseron sur le terrain
Vincent il semble que le cortège ça y
est soit reparti en direction de la
place d'Italie mais avec un petit peu de
retard on dirait
oui effectivement ce cortège il a
redémarré là il est encore une nouvelle
fois bloquée il avance en tout cas pas
très vite effectivement je sais pas si
c'est à cause de ce qui se passe plutôt
en amont du cortège mais nous de notre
côté on a l'impression vraiment que ça
n'avance pas très vite et nous sommes
encore du coup vous pouvez le voir sur
les images au niveau de la Tour
Montparnasse donc ce qui est assez loin
encore de la place d'Italie donc on se
rappelle que la dernière manifestation
était beaucoup plus courte elle allait
de République jusqu'à nation et les
manifestants étaient arrivés sur sur la
place au bout presque d'une heure et
demie là on se trouve même pas à la fin
du cortège parce qu'il y a encore toute
la tout le cortège de la CGT derrière
nous et pourtant ça n'avance voilà ça
n'avance pas forcément énormément on est
un peu bloqué et mais l'ambiance est
assez calme et je voulais revenir sur
quelque chose que les élites à Cohen
tout à l'heure en plateau alors c'est
sûr que à l'avant il y avait beaucoup de
familles nous là où on est on a vu quand
même quelques enfants qui étaient là
alors
c'est pas effectivement pas la majorité
bien évidemment comme par exemple on
peut voir leur débat leur démarche pour
le climat par exemple mais quand même il
y a encore des des familles qui viennent
ensemble à cette manifestation en
restant bien évidemment plutôt en
arrière du cortège là où les choses sont
calmes
merci beaucoup Vincent Dina vous vouliez
être
Vincent a raison de le souligner c'est
important de dire en effet ce qui est ce
qu'il voit et s'il y a encore des
familles et
il nous mène à apporter une précision
qui est importante c'est à dire que les
éléments les plus radicaux se trouvent
souvent dans le cortège de tête qui est
géographiquement éloigné du reste du
cortège et le plus souvent éloigné aussi
par le biais de la police qui essaye de
séparer les deux cortèges et donc en
effet comme le voit Vincent dans le
cortège de la de la masse de la masse
populaire on va dire là on peut trouver
encore des familles et des profils plus
classiques de manifestants et c'est vrai
que c'est ces éléments radicaux vont
être vraiment dans le dans le cortège de
tête qui est le plus souvent là où les
violences ou la tension monte et où ça
peut dégénérer en violence un
commentaire peut-être un petit peu
provocateur de volpazu dans le chat du
Figaro qui nous dit combien de ces
manifestants dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure ces manifestants radicaux
combien d'entre eux ont s lu le texte
c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment que au
delà évidemment de la caricature mais
que beaucoup d'entre eux sont là et ils
agissent pas seulement contre les
retraites mais de manière générale
contre contre un système oui
complètement
parce que c'est ce que me disait
notamment un historien que j'ai consulté
pour cet article qui me parlait d'une
greffe opportuniste au mouvement à
savoir qu'en fait le alors il faut dire
quand même qu'il y avait des jeunes
depuis le début du mouvement on peut pas
dire qu'il y avait pas de jeunes dans la
contestation mais ils sont arrivés plus
massivement à partir de l'activation de
l'activation de l'article 49 à linéa3 et
ont finalement saisi cette opportunité
si on peut appeler ça comme ça pour
dénoncer ce fameux tournant autoritaire
mais pour en vérité
imprégner la manifestation de tout un
tas de luttes complètement étrangère à
la réforme des retraites c'est à dire
que les jeunes qui sont là ne sont pas
forcément tout cela pour contester ce
texte en particulier mais plutôt pour
des pour contester un système un état un
gouvernement sa police et puis mettre
dans tout ça une sorte de convergence
des luttes on va on va retrouver aussi
des pancartes consacrées à l'écologie il
y a aussi la lutte féministe enfin il y
a un petit peu tout qui se mélange c'est
une contestation globale donc
mais après il faut aussi souligner que
dans le reste du cortège on voit aussi
et notamment à partir du 49-3 que la
contestation c'est aussi élargie pour
aller au-delà de la réforme des
retraites et contester enfin on fait on
voit beaucoup dans les cortèges des
pancartes qui visent spécifiquement
Emmanuel Macron la personne d'Emmanuel
Macron et de plus en plus la
contestation se transforme en une
contestation de Macron lui-même du
président lui-même et plus simplement de
ce texte et ça c'est aussi quelque chose
qui est qui est sous-jacent depuis les
gilets jaunes ça veut dire que cette
contestation en fait montre dans le fond
une détestation de la personne
d'Emmanuel Macron complètement je pense
que c'est vraiment le cas ça montre une
détestation ça montre un mal-être aussi
un mal-être de la société d'une société
qui est très marquée qui est extrêmement
morcelée et ça ne ça ne va pas
s'arrangeant puisque du coup le recours
au 49-3 symboliquement a été extrêmement
dur pour le pour les manifestants et
pour les personnes mobilisées on le voit
aussi dans dans les sondages qu'on
diffuse dans le Figaro semaine après
semaine on voit que que le soutien au
mouvement de contestation reste très
élevé il stagne voir il augmente et on
voit aussi que les débordements qui sont
constatés ne sont pas imputés aux
manifestants ils sont imputés au
gouvernement on dit que c'est la faute
du gouvernement donc finalement là où
parfois les violences font que les gens
se désolidarisent des mouvements de
contestation comme ça a pu arriver à un
certain moment des gilets jaunes là on
voit que la faute est renvoyée au
gouvernement qu'il n'y a que ce
gouvernement et Emmanuel Macron qui sont
désignés comme les coupables du climat
actuel et ça ça montre un état d'esprit
extrêmement inquiétant dans le pays
parlons sur un plan plus politique
dynakoen la nuit pèse avant son ordre
dispersé en ce moment avec notamment
cette cette élection qui s'est passé
donc dimanche dernier cette candidate
dissidente à la nups qui a battu la
députée sortante de la France insoumise
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire est-ce que ça
veut dire que la nuit pêche est en train
d'exposer petit à petit alors il faut
toujours
de faire attention de tirer des leçons
nationales d'un événement local même
s'il faut pas en négliger le sens c'est
vrai qu'il y a donc cette
circonscription de l'Ariège ou
finalement on a eu un duel de gauche
entre une gauche socialiste et une
gauche nupes la France insoumise
la gauche socialiste on est sorti
vainqueur est-ce que est-ce que ça veut
dire que le PS récupère une hégémonie
sur la nupasse pour autant non je ne le
crois pas en revanche c'est vrai que la
nuit passe fait face à des difficultés
c'est pas la première fois qu'elle en a
depuis ça depuis sa constitution en juin
dernier pour les législatives de juin
dernier c'est vrai que régulièrement il
y a eu des moments où il y avait des
tensions
dire que la nuit passe explose j'irai
pas jusque là parce que parce que la
gauche a quand même besoin de la
nupaisse ils le sont ils le savent tous
ils sont relativement lucides par
rapport à ça ça reste une machine
électorale qui a été qui a été
extrêmement efficace pour les élections
législatives et les différents parties
de gauche savent très bien que si demain
il part chacun de leur côté ils feront
pas le poids pour se poser en
alternative à Emmanuel Macron en
revanche il y a des difficultés il y a
toujours ce cet enjeu de quel parti
réussira à prendre à prendre l'hégémonie
sur la nupasse pour le moment c'est
plutôt la France insoumise et on voit en
fait un front antimélanchon qui se
dessine aussi parce que finalement il y
a plus d'opposants à Mélenchon que des
opposants à la France insoumise au sein
de dire qu'il y a un bloc
social-démocrate qui est en train de se
former qui essaye en tout cas ça c'est
le cas depuis plusieurs mois depuis
l'échec de la candidature Dani dalgo
immédiatement il y a eu des voix qui se
sont élevées pour pour appeler à ce que
la social démocratie ne disparaissent
pas et de toute façon il va y avoir un
espace à récupérer un moment ou un autre
parce que la nuit pèse c'est quand même
une gauche davantage radicale Emmanuel
Macron qui se disait ni de gauche ni de
droite en 2017 a quand même pris un
tournant qui est davantage vers le
centre droit donc on voit un espace pour
les sociaux-démocrates après qui
réussira à l'incarner c'est toute la
question sachant que le front aussi
anti-up n'est pas uni non plus avec
Carole delgat Bernard Cazeneuve
différentes personnalités qui qui
essayent de prendre cette hégémonie
aussi de la sociale démocratie merci
beaucoup Dina Cohen Merci à VOUS du
service politique du Figaro 285000
manifestants à 16h contre
353000 le 28 mars une mobilisation qui
serait donc en baisse une baisse assez
conséquente c'est en tout cas les
premiers chiffres qui nous remontent du
terrain le terrain justement on y
retourne tout de suite avec Damien
Canivez Damien il semble que la la
situation se soit calmée et que le
cortège est repris ça marche en avant
absolument Timothée la situation c'est
c'est un peu calbé ici même beaucoup par
rapport à ce que vous avez pu voir tout
à l'heure sur les images de de Julien
Leclerc même si ce calme dont je vous
parle est assez relative dans la mesure
où chaque abribus chaque panneau
publicitaire devant lequel se trouve une
vitre vol systématiquement en éclat donc
de toute façon les les exactions auront
lieu en allant l'impression ici jusqu'à
la fin de cette manifestation nous
sommes actuellement boulevard Raspail
nous allons rejoindre la place d'Italie
pour cela il faut rejoindre la place
d'enfer Rochereau boulevard
Saint-Jacques et boulevard Auguste
Blanqui nous sommes dans le dernier
tiers de cette manifestation qui s'étend
sur 5 km et au moment où je vous parle
depuis ce boulevard Raspail la situation
est assez confuse malgré tout l'ambiance
est étonnante puisque il y a certains
manifestants qui se dirigent justement
envers cette place d'enfer Rochereau et
la suite de cette manifestation et
d'autres qui vont à qui qui rebrousse
chemin quoi qui qui repartent dans
l'autre sens comme si justement le Black
Bloc dont on parlait tout à l'heure
était de se reformer un fumigène là-bas
au loin jaune est en train d'être activé
alors est-ce que c'est un signe de
ralliement en tout cas on a l'habitude
effectivement de constater ici que dès
lors qu'un fumigène sort de la poche
d'un millier
il se passe toujours toujours quelque
chose
dans les minutes qui suivent voilà donc
le calme comme je vous le dis et est
assez relatif on est assez loin de
l'ambiance que l'on peut j'imagine
constater dans le cortège syndical avec
avec des revendications totalement
en tout cas démocratique c'est-à-dire le
retrait de cette réforme contre la
réforme des retraites avec effectivement
une colère qui se cristallise peut-être
aujourd'hui un peu plus autour
d'Emmanuel Macron en tout cas ici dans
ce pré-corpège on fustige non pas la
réforme des retraites cette ce texte
n'est dans aucune bouche pour être très
honnête avec vous ici on scanne des
slogans anticapitalistes des slogans
Antipolis on à des symboles vous avez vu
tout à l'heure un départ de feu depuis
la toiture de de la de la rotonde en
tout cas depuis ce tissu qui recouvre ce
restaurant qui a été malgré tout assez
vite éteint par les pompiers vous voyez
tout ça c'est ce sont des symboles du
pouvoir ce sont des symboles du
capitalisme et pour le moment en tout
cas vous le voyez sur les images de
Julien Leclerc le cortège poursuit son
chemin même si en ce moment même il est
statique et on a le sentiment que les
militants d'ultra gauche sont en train
de se rassembler
merci beaucoup Damien Canivet sur le
terrain de nous rapporter ce que vous
voyez je suis avec Guillaume roquet
directeur de la rédaction du Figaro
Magazine qui me rejoint sur ce plateau
bonjour Guillaume bonsoir Timothée merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Guillaume on
le voit avec notamment ses commentaires
de Damien canivevez on est quand même
dans une période difficile le pays est
abîmé est-ce que la malédiction du
second mandat présidentiel se confirme
oui elle se confirme et elle s'ajoute
cette difficulté institutionnelle qui
est inquiète un classique puisque le
président a moins de à moins de
d'énergie moins de ressorts et il y a un
autre problème qui est un épuisement
institutionnel généralisé c'est-à-dire
que jusqu'à présent les présidents même
dans leur second mandat avait une
majorité parlementaire aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron n'en a pas et ça donne
cette situation c'est à dire ce pays qui
est bloqué alors c'est pas une
catastrophe parce que la France continue
à tourner le la tentative de mettre à
l'arrêt l'économie à échouer les gens
continuent à vivre mais il y a ce
sentiment que on ne peut plus
véritablement changer les choses dans
notre pays et c'est ça le principal
problème pour Emmanuel Macron parce
qu'il avait été élu sur cette promesse
de changement est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
a définitivement perdu la bataille de
l'opinion dans cette histoire parce que
même si là il venait et c'est très
hautement improbable mais s'il venait à
retirer cette réforme à retirer cette
mesure d'âge on a le sentiment que ça ne
changerait pas grand chose finalement au
climat social je pense que de toute
façon on ne peut plus raisonner de façon
globale c'est à dire que nous vivons
dans une société fracturée Jérôme
Fourquet le politologue a écrit des
pages définitive là-dessus sur
l'archipelisation de la société
française et donc le président de la
République qui réunit autour de lui une
large majorité de de concitoyens ça
n'existe plus et ça n'existera plus me
semble-t-il donc le fait que Emmanuel
Macron mécontente une partie des
Français ça n'est pas gênant je pense
pas qu'il soit définitivement discrédité
moi j'ai été assez sensible à l'argument
qu'il avait mis en avant lors de son
entretien avec nos nos confrères et
concerts de de la télévision en disant
j'aurais bien aimé ne pas faire cette
réforme mais je pense qu'elle était
nécessaire cet argument là aujourd'hui
il est inaudible mais il peut le devenir
et à la fin de son mandat c'est un petit
peu ce qui avait connu Jacques Chirac
entre 2005 et 2016 il y avait eu des
difficultés bien sûr avec les CPE mais
en même temps il y avait un côté sage
donc voilà c'est pas complètement fichu
pour Macron en revanche pour le l'élan
réformateur là il est arrêté en tout cas
alors de cet entretien que vous que dont
vous parlez que vous évoquez cet
entretien donné à nos confrères et
concerts de TF1 et France 2 Emmanuel
Macron a donné une feuille de route
claire Elisabeth borne il lui a dit bah
voilà il faut élargir la majorité
c'est pas un cadeau là avec ce qui se
passe en ce moment non bien sûr et
personne n'a envie de monter à bord du
Titanic donc je pense que cette demande
à Elizabeth borne relevait un peu du
voeux pieux un petit peu comme cette
volonté de tendre la main au syndicats
vous avez vu ce qu'il est advenu
syndicats sont allés voir aimablement la
première ministre puis il lui en dit
votre projet elle a répondu non ils ont
dit bon on s'en va et bon ben on n'est
pas beaucoup plus avancé donc je pense
qu'il peut y avoir des des majorités de
rencontres sur tel ou tel sujet encore
une fois ça n'est pas la fin du
quinquennat mais ça ne peut se faire que
sur des sujets consensuels ou sur des
sujets qui sont
positifs pour une partie de la
population je pense que quand vous
faites une vraie réforme ça veut dire
que vous introduisez une rupture vous
acceptez de de mécontenté une grande
partie du pays et pour ça il faut avoir
une force politique un capital politique
Emmanuel Macron n'a plus et on le voit
avec ces mouvements et cette onzième
journée à partir de là quelle est la
stratégie pour le gouvernement pour
Elizabeth borne il va falloir aller
chercher des majorités au cas par cas
ils ont ils ont pas le choix ils vont
être obligés de passer par là oui je
pense parce que il y a pas de raison que
la situation change à l'Assemblée et ce
qu'il faut c'est espérer enfin ce qu'il
faut pour eux en tout cas c'est espérer
que qu'ils y arrivent parce que il est
pas exclu que
on aille de blocage en blocage et dans
ces cas-là on n'a pas de solution c'est
là qu'on voit que ce qui imaginait que
la Cinquième République est un régime
présidentiel se trompe quand vous n'avez
pas une majorité solide vous vous êtes
entravé dans votre volonté de réformer
le pays donc pour l'instant à part
gagner du temps et effectivement essayer
de de d'avoir sur des textes précis
l'accord de telle ou telle partie de
l'Assemblée pour élargir la majorité
il y a pas vraiment de choix et ça c'est
un vrai sujet pour Emmanuel Macron parce
que c'est un homme qui est qui est
arrivé au pouvoir en disant avec moi les
choses vont changer vous allez voir que
le pays va être plus ambitieux plus
volontariste et bien c'est exactement le
contraire qui lui est imposé par la
situation politique et oui parce que du
coup ça te promet pas de réforme très
ambitieuse tout ça non je ne vois pas
très bien ce qu'on doit galérer à chaque
fois aller chercher votre par vote des
députés à l'Assemblée bon oui c'est vrai
et je vais vous dire heureusement que
nous ne sommes pas dans une situation de
de crise aiguë nous traversons une
difficulté un moment social difficile
mais encore une fois malgré cette
multiplication des journées de
mobilisation le pays n'est pas à l'arrêt
imaginez qu'il y a eu un tel climat
politique au moment de la crise du covid
c'est à dire que les gens soient venus
discuter dans la rue les mesures de
confinement là ça aurait été un problème
dramatique aujourd'hui c'est
problématique pour Emmanuel Macron mais
la situation n'est pas dramatique pour
la France quelles vont être les
chantiers à l'Assemblée nationale
prochainement on nous parle de cette loi
pleine emploi dont on parlait à
l'instant avec Marie Viso c'est ça le
prochain gros chantier ça peut l'être
parce que c'est a priori un projet qui a
un double avantage d'abord c'est que il
permet Emmanuel Macron de montrer qu'il
n'a pas renoncé à investir le champ
social et puis l'autre avantage c'est
que il peut y avoir des mesures
positives il peut y avoir du sucré après
le salé ou l'acide de cette réforme des
retraites parce que quand vous êtes
quand vous travaillez à mieux définir ce
qu'est le la pénibilité au travail ce
que peuvent être le meilleur partage de
la richesse avec les salariés tout ça
c'est du positif
et donc a priori on a plus facile de
trouver une majorité mais je pense que
c'est pas sur ces sujets là que les
Français jugeront le président de la
République est-ce que vous pensez
Guillaume en tête que la multiplication
des foyers de colère peut créer une
convergence des luttes et créer un grand
embrasement est-ce que on peut connaître
à nouveau des épisodes comme ce que l'on
a connu au moment des gilets jaunes et
bien écoutez la réponse elle est sous
nos yeux et avec les images que que nous
envoie nos équipes à part le le
revêtement de la rotonde je vois pas
grand chose qui s'embrasse donc et il y
a plutôt moins de monde dans les rues
aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait la semaine
dernière donc cette idée de convergence
généralisée des luttes ou en tout cas
cet espoir qui avait l'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui il n'apparaît pas dans les
faits c'est-à-dire que vous n'avez pas
de mouvement de grève généralisé il y a
certes quelques quelques lycées qui sont
qui sont bloqués mais c'est plus
folklorique qu'autre chose il y a des
universités ou de toute façon tout le
reste de l'année on travaille pas
beaucoup donc elle soit bloquées ou non
c'est peut-être pas très grave
c'est ce que je pense et je moi j'admire
les parents qui qui mettent encore leurs
enfants je pense que ça peut leur servir
au moment de parcoursup pour savoir
comment faire leur choix mais le encore
une fois le pays fonctionne et donc
cette conversion des lutte elle n'a pas
lieu alors pourquoi je pense parce que
il y a un certain nombre de gens qui ont
une vraie détestation d'Emmanuel Macron
mais c'est une population minoritaire et
le l'opposition généralisée au report de
l'âge de la retraite c'est une
opposition résolue
pérenne mais paisible et donc qui qui
vit mal c'est dérapages et ses violences
que l'on voit depuis maintenant plus de
deux semaines et donc évidemment profite
le gouvernement pourrait essayer de
discréditer le mouvement il y en a un
qui en tout cas travaillent qui est très
actif c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin cette séquence retraite
avec toutes les questions évidemment de
maintien de l'ordre qui en découle c'est
un moment important pour lui oui c'est
un moment positif parce que il n'est pas
porteur de la réforme et donc il peut
jouer sa petite musique qui est de la
musique de l'autorité et du refus de
l'achat en ligne et ça c'est quelque
chose que son modèle absolu Nicolas
Sarkozy avait déjà fait en son temps
vous vous souvenez pendant les émeutes
qui avait eu lieu de mémoire c'était en
2005 les émeutes dans les banlieues
voilà Nicolas Sarkozy faisait savoir
quand je dirais pas le problème comme il
fallait il y a une filiation entre
Nicolas Sarkozy et Gérald Darmanin il y
a une filiation évident d'abord dans le
dans le parcours dans les postes exercés
ministre du Budget ministre de
l'Intérieur et puis il y a ce
pragmatisme qui n'est pas
qui fait que le Latitude du ministre
elle est plus dictée par ce que
ressentent les Français que par une
vraie ligne idéologique et donc les
Français aujourd'hui ne n'acceptent pas
tous ces troubles fommentés par l'ultra
gauche et
Pierre Alva Manin s'en sert entre
guillemets il fait son travail il faut
le reconnaître il tient là-bas et donc
il en ça et oui il est l'un des l'un des
gagnants entre guillemets de cette de ce
de ce projet il en sort beaucoup moins
abîmé par exemple que la première
ministre à tel point qu'on parle même de
lui pour la remplacer quand il donne une
interview JDD dimanche dernier qu'il
pointe du doigt se terrorisme d'extrême
gauche selon ses mots à quoi est-ce
qu'il joue quelle est sa stratégie
écoutez on lui avait reproché ce terme
je crois qu'il avait parlé à l'époque
d'écotérisme en novembre dernier au
moment des premières manifestations
autour des méga vaccinés à l'époque
toute la gauche bien-pensante et tous
les bienfaits en général avait dit mais
c'est excessif c'est tout entier bah non
si vous voulez quand on quand vous avez
des témoignages de de de d'officier de
gendarmerie qui disent je voyais dans
les yeux de mes interlocuteurs dans les
Deux-Sèvres autour des méga bassines
qu'il voulait nous tuer je voulais on
n'est pas loin quand même d'actes de
terrorisme alors il y a pas des bombes
qui explosent et donc c'est vrai que ce
terminologie elle est elle est
dramatisante mais sur le fond il y a une
utilisation de la violence à des fins
politiques et donc on n'est pas très
loin du terrorisme même si bien sûr le
le terme peut choquer un certain nombre
de manifestants qui eux sont pacifiques
peut-être également que Gérald Darmanin
regarde les sondages parce que on l'a vu
vous le savez mieux que moi ce sondage
publié dans vos pages dans le Figaro
magazine réalisé par époque Fiducial qui
confirme la forte poussée de Marine Le
Pen à droite toute pour jardin alors
oui à droite toute parce que
effectivement il y a un désir d'ordre
mais il y a aussi je pense les électeurs
de Marine Le Pen le rejet de de ce
projet et je pense que Marine Le Pen a
bien fait de ne pas se mettre en avant
parce que le Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ses
amis se sont jetés dans la bataille or
qu'est-ce que constate les Français
c'est que il y a beau avoir des journées
qui se succèdent des manifestations des
mouvements de grève le projet n'est pas
retiré et que donc s'il y a un
changement il devrait être politique il
n'est pas le mouvement social n'est pas
suffisamment fort pour pour changer les
choses donc Marine Le Pen en profite
alors Gérald Darmanin je disais il est
moins moins abîmé que d'autres ministres
par ce projet c'est vrai qu'on l'a testé
puisque on a proposé à l'ifope de faire
un sondage en disant Et si la
présidentielle se rejoint aujourd'hui
pour voteriez-vous alors on a fait à
l'identique comme l'année dernière et
puis on a aussi testé ce qui pourrait
succéder à Emmanuel Macron puisque comme
vous le savez il ne pourra pas se
représenter la Constitution lui interdit
de faire trois mandats alors essayer de
voir Philippe qui s'en sort le mieux
alors Gérald Darmanin et loin derrière
il est à 11 % en premier tour de si mais
ma mémoire ne me trompe pas ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est moins que
Bruno Le Maire mais néanmoins dans
l'entourage de Gérald Darmanin on nous
dit ah c'est quand même pas si mal parce
que il n'est pas du tout en campagne il
est candidat à rien et pourtant il
existe donc oui il est en train de
cranter quelque chose malgré tout on est
encore loin de cette de cette échéance
est-ce que c'est dans quelle mesure en
tout cas cela est significatif de
quelque chose est-ce que ça veut dire ça
peut le pousser en tout cas à se lancer
à y penser de plus en plus en se rasant
le matin à se dire pourquoi pas 2027 ça
peut être mon tour je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
Gérald Darmanin pense surtout à Matignon
ce qui est vrai c'est que c'est un homme
extrêmement méthodique
organisé et qui n'a jamais caché avoir
de grandes ambitions et pour l'instant
il ne fait pas d'erreur vous savez bien
que c'est dans les moments de crise
qu'on juge de la de la du
professionnalisme de de d'un gouvernant
et il fait le job et donc effectivement
il peut se dire si je réussis cette
cette étape là je peux je peux avoir les
plus grandes ambitions c'est vrai que
Gérald Darmanin je trouve gère assez
bien la pression policière parce que les
policiers les forces de l'ordre
réagissent réagissent de façon ferme
mais il n'y a pas de dérapage et pour
dire les choses un peu cruments il y a
pas de mort
tant mieux il faut s'en réjouir mais
c'est aussi par ce que il y a une
maîtrise de la de la de du travail des
forces de l'ordre qui à mon avis il faut
saluer il y en a en tout cas qui s'en
sort moins bien dans ce dans ce sondage
c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon le leader de la
nupes même si il ne siège plus à
l'Assemblée nationale
17%, 17% pardon si le second tour se
aujourd'hui il est donc plus dans la
compétition il ne serait plus dans la
compétition pour se qualifier au second
tour qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire alors d'abord c'est pas
complètement nouveau puisque la dernière
fois non plus il n'était pas il n'était
pas au foot à finir très haut exactement
je pense que je regarde les chiffres en
même temps que en même temps que je vous
parle oui Jean-Luc Mélenchon baisse
puisque il avait fait on le rappelle
21,5% au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022 et là notre
sondage il faut Fiducial le crédit de
17%. donc c'est un recul de 4,5 points
mais ça n'est pas un effondrement moi
pour tout vous dire je pensais qu'il
allait baisser davantage je pensais que
compte tenu de de de de la la
complaisance dont il fait preuve par
rapport au dérapage et aux excès de de
violence de ce mouvement les Français ne
le le
[Musique]
disqualifie pas totalement et puis
l'autre chose c'est que il est le seul
qui qui existe à gauche puisque on a
testé alors c'est vrai qu'ils sont pas
encore très connus mais on a testé la le
score que pourrait faire la leader des
des Européens Écologie Les Verts marine
ton de lier
qu'on a aussi testé Olivier fort le
patron du Parti socialiste si vous
voulez faut prendre un microscope pour
voir leur score quoi c'est c'est c'est
toujours en dessous de 10%. donc pour
l'instant
il est le seul à à incarner la gauche et
ça pour lui c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle merci beaucoup Guillaume
roquette directeur de la rédaction du
Figaro Magazine on retourne sur le
terrain où nous attend Vincent roserons
Vincent il semble que le cortège aille
de bons trains à présent
oui effectivement le cortège qui semble
avoir accéléré on était assez bloqué
depuis un moment mais là depuis une
demi-heure ça avance plutôt bien ça
avance plutôt bien mais quand même on
est toujours on a toujours pas dépassé
mon bardage et comme vous pouvez le voir
sur ces images il y a encore tous les
ballons de Force Ouvrière toute la
société derrière donc en fait la fin du
cortège est encore très loin
actuellement de là où nous sommes donc
ça va être compliqué que tout le monde
arrive à Place d'Italie avant 19h mais
ça on a un peu l'habitude dans dans ces
manifestations pour que tout le monde
arrive assez vite parce que on avance ça
s'arrête peut-être qu'il y a des que ça
bloque devant puisqu'il a eu comme
Damien Canivez vous la montrer avec les
images de Julien Leclerc il y a eu des
problèmes à l'avant donc forcément ça
retarde le cortège là aussi mais là le
cortège semble avoir repris sa marche en
avant un cortège plus clairsemé en tout
cas clairement que la semaine dernière
ça on peut ça on peut l'assurer moins
dense
mais qui continue ça marche même si là
vous voyez derrière moi il est arrêté en
ce moment
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron quelques
difficultés de liaison parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde mais on s'en sort
merci infiniment j'accueille Grégory
Joron secrétaire national de SGP Police
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
quels sont les plus grandes villes les
villes les plus difficiles en termes de
gestion de maintien de l'ordre on a vu
tout à l'heure quelques éléments très
localisés de violences au niveau de la
rotonde dans l'ensemble la manifestation
se passe pour le moment plutôt dans dans
le calme est-ce que Paris quelle est la
différence par rapport à d'autres villes
sur cette sur cette question de maintien
de l'ordre Paris cristallise quand même
la capitale donc une attention
particulière à avoir un dispositif
forcément des fois un peu plus on va
dire un peu plus lourd sur la plaque
parisienne qu'on peut la voir dans
certaines villes parce que parce que
forcément les institutions se trouvent
ici forcément encore une fois toutes les
caméras sont à son braquées sur la
capitale il y a souvent aussi une
symbolique autour de tout ça ça se passe
pas très bien non plus à Nantes
aujourd'hui encore une fois
malheureusement on a déjà fonctionnaires
blessés des gendarmes également et il y
a eu quelques affrontements on sait de
toute façon voilà depuis le début d'une
forme de radicalité surtout en dehors du
cortège il faut préciser que les
cortèges syndicaux se passent très bien
que ce soit à Paris ailleurs mais on
précise aussi en dehors du cortège
malheureusement on voit souvent les
mêmes villes où il y a des heures et
notamment Nantes encore aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le théâtre d'affrontement
assez lourd on va aller voir Damien
Canivez ce qui se trouve sur le terrain
avec Julien Leclerc il semble Damien que
la situation soit en train de se tendre
un petit peu
ouais ouais c'est effectivement très
compliqué parce que nous nous trouvons
une fois de plus entre les casseurs et
les casseurs et les manifestants il y a
des grenades de désencerclement
forcément qui qui sont en train de
pleuvoir pour justement que les
manifestants puissent sortir de là où il
se trouve en fait nous nous trouvons au
niveau du boulevard Raspail vous savez
pourquoi la place dentaire Rochereau et
c'est à cet endroit que se trouve une
banque le Crédit Agricole pardon une
banque bien connue et et à cet endroit
là en fait une devanture a été
caillassée malgré les palissades qui ont
été érigés par les euh
[Musique]
des grenades lacrymogènes là qui sont en
train de pleuvoir il y a eu des pannes
des palissades qui ont été fixés et qui
ont été démontés par les manifestants et
derrière c'est vous voyez le local
qui a été complètement saccagé il y a un
feu qui a été qui a été mis et les
policiers qui sont venus pour disperser
les forces de l'ordre Timothée
[Musique]
on reste avec ces images tournées par
par Julien Leclerc avec donc cette ce
feu et cette devanture d'une banque qui
a donc été caillassée un mot peut-être
sur ces images Grégory
mobilier de la banque pour le sortir
dehors et le brûler donc là on est
typiquement justement sur cette mouvance
ultra Gauche anticapitaliste qui
s'attaque à je mange ce genre de
symboles de l'argent et de la
mondialisation pour s'exprimer donc on
sait d'où ça vient on sait qui c'est et
malheureusement on les retrouve
de manière récurrente sur les
manifestations que ce soit la
manifestation des retraites ou autre
chose clairement de toute façon c'est
pas la revendication des manifestants
qui les intéressent ce qui les intéresse
c'est de générer du chaos et de passer
leur message à eux avec avec violence
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête des
forces de l'ordre dans ce genre de
moments on a peur on cherche à bien
localiser
on n'a pas peur non on est on est
concentrer surtout parce que on a deux
objectifs pour le coup c'est-à-dire déjà
rétablir l'ordre c'est le premier mais
aussi ne pas perdre de vue que derrière
il y a une manifestation qui doit se
dérouler et des manifestants qu'on doit
protéger parce que on le sait aussi on
le savait ces éléments ultra violents
quand ils veulent pénétrer dans les
cortèges sur ces sur ces grandes
manifestations organisées par des
Confédérations avec des services d'ordre
propre se frotte aussi au service
d'ordre c'est-à-dire qu'il y a même ils
s'attaquent ils s'attaquent même aux
manifestants pour pouvoir rentrer dans
les cortèges donc nous on a un double
enjeu rétablir sur la mission sur
laquelle ont été envoyés mes collègues
c'est-à-dire essayer de faire en sorte
que les exactions cessent mais aussi
essayer de faire en sorte que le cortège
se déroule normalement donc ça reste
assez compliqué c'est de la gestion de
full c'est du direct et c'est tout
l'intérêt du maintien on va voir c'est
tout c'est toute la noblesse du métier
pour vos collègues qui sont parfois la
cible d'invective de la part de certains
manifestants radicaux avec parfois et
bien des insultes ce genre de ce genre
de choses est-ce que vous n'en avez pas
assez d'être entre le marteau et
l'enclume parce que tout à l'heure
Christophe cornlevin d'ailleurs
responsable des questions de sécurité au
Figaro le rappeler le les services de
police font partie des des des plus
syndiqués des ordres les plus syndiqués
de France oui oui on est on a on a je
crois un taux de syndicalisation qui
approche des 80% des personnels
donc forcément on est comme d'ailleurs
partie du monde actif donc comme la
plupart des actifs on est contre la
réforme des retraites c'est une réalité
sauf qu'après il y a aussi ses
fonctionnaires qui ont une conscience
professionnelle qui ont une mission qui
sont là qui font qui font le boulot
est-ce qu'ils ont assez est-ce qu'ils
ont assez de se faire insulter à se
sentir que c'est pas agréable j'ai été
CRS pendant plus de 10 ans donc je sais
ce que c'est mais ça fait partie aussi
du métier de comprendre que de temps en
temps on est aussi une forme d'exutoire
tant que ça reste dans une dans quelque
chose d'acceptable dès lors qu'on a
déblesses qu'on est l'objet de cible la
cible pardon de pavés qu'on en a pu le
voir de cocktails et autres autres
objets c'est déjà plus acceptable et
c'est là que qu'on doit rentrer dans
notre mission de rétablissement de
l'ordre ce qui se fait de manière trop
professionnelle on voit que là ça
progresse bien parce que il y a ces deux
objectifs le cortège comme on continue à
avancer et on essaye pardon du terme
mais de nettoyer devant pour que ça se
déroule du mieux possible
4200 policiers mobilisés aujourd'hui
dans les rues de la capitale c'est 1300
de moins que le 28 mars dernier est-ce
que ce n'était pas un petit peu trop
optimiste
c'est à dire un petit peu trop à moins
de pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
moins de concrètement pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a moins de force de l'ordre dans
les rues aujourd'hui que le 28 mars
dernier oui bah peut-être que
l'évaluation de la mobilisation a été
revue à la baisse il y avait une météo
qui était déjà un peu tendancieuse le
vrai ennemi de la mobilisation c'est la
pluie ça c'est une réalité donc il y a
peut-être ça
on reste sur quand même malgré tout un
dispositif qui est extrêmement lourd en
4200 agents engagés c'est quand même pas
rien ça fait très longtemps qu'on a
dépassé ce que j'ai pu connaître moi
avant les événements de Charlie Hebdo ou
un gros dispositif c'était 16 forces
mobiles engagées là on est plutôt sur
une trentaine plus les forces de la
préfecture de police donc ça reste de
toute façon des dispositifs entre
guillemets aux normes qui sont mis en
place donc non non ça reste quand même
un gros dispo un gros dispositif un
dispositif lourd mais qui n'est pas
toujours extrêmement visible comme nous
le rappeler tout à l'heure Christophe
Cornavin avec ses forces de l'ordre qui
s'efforcent de rester dans les rues
adjacentes c'est c'est nouveau pour
quelle raison non de nouveau ça a
toujours été la philosophie du maintien
d'or dans la française c'est basé quand
même sur la stratégie d'évitement sur le
sur le la distance à garder avec le
manifestant quand on est quand on est
dans une manifestation classique comme
on l'est aujourd'hui c'est à dire
organiser déclarer encadré par des
grandes confédérations on sait très bien
qu'il y a pas besoin de mettre de force
de police à proximité mais c'est vrai
que le 28 mars dernier pardon je vous
coupe mais on avait le sentiment qu'il y
avait moins de force de l'ordre
mobiliser alors évidemment c'est en fait
pas la réalité mais on avait
l'impression en tout cas qu'ils étaient
moins visibles de des manifestations
est-ce que c'est une volonté manifeste
et si oui pourquoi enfin c'est pas une
volonté soit encore une fois ça a
toujours existé sur un mode d'expression
classique et quel est l'intérêt de toute
façon quand on sait qu'il y a un service
d'ordre que c'est encadré que le but du
jeu c'est que ça se passe bien pour les
manifestants que le cortège va être
respecté il y a pas lieu d'avoir un
encadrement au plus proche pour pouvoir
faire en sorte de serrer on va dire la
manifestation les fonctionnaires de
police seront prêts à manœuvrer s'il y a
besoin et c'est surtout à surveiller sur
la tête de reportage comme on voit la
comme on voit là encore une fois
aujourd'hui ou les éléments les plus
radicaux se réunissent parce que
justement ils peuvent pas pénétrer dans
le cortège donc c'est moi je pense
plutôt une bonne stratégie le maintien
de l'ordre c'est c'est évidemment une
préparation et pour le coup je pense que
depuis quelques semaines on peut pas
critiquer la préparation de ses services
qui à mon sens plutôt bien équilibré on
va retourner voir Daniel sur le terrain
parce que le cortège est de nouveau
coupé en deux arrêtez Damien situation
de nouveau assez confuse là où vous vous
trouvez
ouais nous sommes au niveau de la place
d'enfer Rochereau vous voyez ce cordon
de de policier qui se trouve voilà au
niveau de la rue Victor conséquent en
tout cas oui c'est ça
considérant voilà j'ai une très mauvaise
vue on est assez loin il faut dire voilà
et c'est policier sont en train de
tenter voilà deux de disperser une fois
de plus c'est ces éléments radicaux qui
depuis tout à l'heure en fait s'en
prennent à une banque qui fait l'angle
de cette de cette rue vous le voyez elle
a été taillée et palissale ont été
érigés en amont de cette manifestation
par par la direction on imagine et
malgré effectivement la solidité
apparente de ce dispositif et bien les
manifestants très motivés et très
radicalisés surtout et surtout en nombre
sont parvenus à les faire sauter à tel
point que sur l'entrée qui se trouve au
niveau du boulevard Raspail et bien
voilà il y a des manifestants qui ont
réussi à s'infiltrer à l'intérieur de
cette banque et à tout saccager
littéralement tout saccager la vitrine
et pulvérisée en mille morceaux et c'est
à ce moment là que les policiers qui
n'étaient pas très visibles jusque là
sont sortis comme d'un seul homme d'une
rue d'une rue parallèle et ils ont été
extrêmement extrêmement réactive donc
vous les voyez ce sont des forces
mobiles qui ont lancé de nombreuses de
nombreuses grenades lacrymogènes sur sur
le boulevard avec également des des
grenades de désencerclement et qui ont
reçu en retour une fois encore des
projectiles et je peux vous assurer que
dans les prochaines minutes qui vont
rythmer cette manifestation les pavés
vont pleuvoir puisque tout à l'heure au
moment où il y avait un quel apparent en
réalité les manifestants parfois essayer
certains manifestants ont essayé de
cacher leur camarades de de jeux si
j'ose dire l'expression est mal choisie
pour déterrer des pavés qui forment les
trottoirs ici au niveau du boulevard
Raspail pour et bien se charger des
munitions pour la suite de la
manifestation donc c'est extrêmement
violent ici ce qui se passe dans les
rues de Paris les forces de l'ordre
essaye tant bien que mal de de résister
de protéger les bâtiments qui sont pris
d'assaut par par les manifestants mais
c'est assez compliqué de les reculer
tant de les faire reculer pardon tant il
sont ils sont nombreux donc local mais
pour l'instant et presque
redevenu normal même si voilà des
projectiles continuent d'atterrir sur
les forces de l'ordre mais en tout cas
on peut s'attendre à une charge de la
police dans les prochaines minutes pour
encore une fois de plus morcelé
davantage ce prêt cortège qui s'est
formé donc devant l'Inter syndicale qui
elle poursuit son chemin dans le calme
merci beaucoup Damien Canivez Grégory
Joron donc on a vu ces scènes de tension
même si évidemment ça reste en tout cas
pour le moment maîtriser Damien vs
disait à l'instant il va peut-être y
avoir une charge de la part des CRS
décrivez-nous un petit peu ce qui se
passe dans ces dans ces moments-là
quelle est la stratégie pour et bien
faire revenir le calme ce qui semble
être en train de d'arriver là la
situation qui commence un petit peu à se
calmer on dirait c'est une situation qui
est qui est pour le coup figée parce
qu'il veut pas dire qu'il y aura pas de
manœuvre parce que l'intérêt si en effet
de encore une fois d'ailleurs votre
envoyer sur le terrain là la très bien
dit il y a le cortège derrière qui
continue à avancer dans le calme je vais
juste réfuter enfin un tour entre
guillemets peut-être corriger une chose
c'est pas des manifestants qu'on a
devant les forces de l'ordre c'est des
huiles d'éléments ultra-violes des
casseurs c'est tout ce qu'on veut mais
c'est pas des manifestants les
manifestations les manifestants ils sont
derrière je pense qu'il faut vraiment
nommer les choses comme elles le sont là
ce sont des éléments ultraviants ils
viennent pas pour manifester ils
viennent pour casser il faut quand même
je pense le préciser parce qu'il y a une
énorme différence et pour le coup je
pense que ce qui va se passer en effet
c'est peut-être potentiellement une
manœuvre où on va essayer de regagner du
terrain avec un but premier c'est de
s'il y a un pré-corpège avec quelques
une centaine on me dit moi d'éléments à
risque et le but du jeu c'est clairement
de les disques ok entre guillemets
le groupe et de faire en sorte que il ne
puisse pas se reformer pour justement
générer tout ce qu'on voit de la casse
exetera quoi donc le but du jeu c'est de
gagner du terrain et de faire en sorte
que il se regroupe le moins possible sur
cette présence d'éléments radicaux
d'éléments violents on les voit à
l'instant à l'écran
vous me disiez la différence qu'il y a
dans ce cortège avec certains par
exemple au moment des des gilets jaunes
c'est que là les les éléments radicaux
se trouvent à l'avant du cortège et donc
ils n'ont pas intégré le corsage et ça
c'est un élément important pour les
forces de l'ordre c'est très très
important parce que déjà ça facilitait
énormément le les manœuvres et la prise
en compte justement des éléments ultra
violents vous imaginez bien que dans le
mouvement des gilets jaunes on a eu
quelque chose quand même d'assez un
briquet avec sur la fin une espèce quand
même de voilà de bienveillance presque
de de
des cortèges à l'endroit des éléments
ultraviaux ultra radicaux et du coup une
difficulté pour la police d'interagir et
d'intervenir parce que vous imaginez
bien que si vous deviez charger la
manifestation aujourd'hui ça serait
quand même un peu compliqué parce que le
discernement est difficile quand on a
une foule compacte là pour le coup on
sait que la manifestation derrière elle
est vraie manifestants sont derrière et
que devant nous on a simplement ceux qui
veulent s'en prendre au symbole aux
policier et à tout ce qui leur va pas
donc donc ça facilite quand même
l'action de la police et c'est une très
bonne chose et on voit d'ailleurs ce
contraste avec ces deux images nous
étions sur les images de Damien Canivez
et Julien Leclerc qui sont donc à
l'avant de ce cortège avec ses scènes de
voilà de tension en tout cas où on
s'observe même si ça reste maîtrisé et
puis nous avons vu ensuite les images de
là où se trouve Vincent roseron et
Mathis fleuret où là on voit que
effectivement
et bien lorsqu'on se rapproche du
cortège du cortège syndical et bien la
situation est beaucoup beaucoup plus
calme pourquoi est-ce que c'est si
difficile de d'interpeller de démanteler
les fameux black bloc
parce qu'ils sont très bien organisés
parce qu'ils sont très mobiles parce
qu'en général on a fait ils profitent de
la foule donc mise à part c'est encore
une fois sur le répète mais c'est très
important mis à part c'est cortèges très
bien organisé avec un vrai service
d'ordre assez aguerri les dernières
manifestations qu'on avait pu connaître
les Black Blocs et les éléments radicaux
faisaient partie du cortège donc ça
complexifié qu'on l'a dit juste avant
l'action de mes collègues ensuite ce
sont vraiment des personnes qui sont
aguerris qui connaissent les méthodes
d'intervention de la police et qui
arrivent à s'en soustraire assez
facilement et ensuite deuxième élément
même quand les interpelle
malheureusement on le sait très bien la
judiciarisation du maintien de l'ordre
est quand même une vraie difficulté tant
les éléments constitutifs souvent des
infractions sont un peu légères et elles
ne sont pas retenues par les magistrats
qui traitent un peu les personnes qu'on
met à disposition ensuite c'est la
première réalité c'est qu'il faut qu'on
travaille vraiment ce troisième temps du
maintien d'ordre c'est à dire comment on
judiciarise avec quelle méthode on peut
finalement prouver réellement que les
personnes qu'on a interpellé sont
vraiment les fauteurs des infractions
reprochées parce que la difficulté vous
imaginez bien quand vous êtes dans des
périodes dégradé comme ça quand vous
avez 100 personnes vous avez interpellé
10 personnes avec des capuches et vous
allez cibler quelqu'un qui vous avez
chien qui vous achetez un caillou ben
très facilement son avocat va dire que
c'est celui d'à côté qui a exactement la
même capuche le même pull noir et que le
doute forcément
va aller aider le mise en cause et
souvent ben malheureusement les affaires
sont classées donc ça c'est la réalité
on doit travailler sur la
judiciarisation de ces actes là est-ce
que vous à titre personnel ou bien
lorsque vous discutez avec certains de
vos de vos collègues de vos confrères
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
maintien de l'ordre est de plus en plus
difficile est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'il y a une montée des
violences dans le pays ou bien
finalement vous dites bon c'est
difficile mais ça a toujours été comme
ça non il y a des pics la réalité c'est
que l'enchaînement de ces périodes là
vous savez moi je je vais pas parler de
sentiment où je vais pas parler de de
d'effets de faits sociétaux la réalité
je pense qu'on doit l'avoir simplement
sur quelque chose de factuel c'est le
nombre de blessés quand vous décomptez
plusieurs centaines de blessés et je
crois plus publier depuis le début de la
séquence ça veut bien dire que les
choses sont violantes les fonctionnaires
se blessent pas tous en se foutant une
cheville sur un pavé mal un peu des
chaussées non il se blesse parce qu'ils
sont l'objet de et la cible d'éléments
violents de projectiles etc donc oui le
métier est de plus en plus difficile et
on le sait bien il y a quand même malgré
tout une radicalisation dans les formes
d'expression de la colère sociale et on
le découvre encore aujourd'hui avec des
images qui sont quand même tristes à
voir dans notre démocratie c'est une
réalité merci beaucoup Grégory national
du syndicat SGP Police on retourne tout
de suite sur le terrain on va aller voir
Vincent roseron qui se trouve et bien en
tête de cortège syndical en tout cas ce
cortège et bien plus calme je crois que
vous êtes au niveau de la Tour
Montparnasse si je ne me trompe pas et
j'ai le sentiment que c'est un petit peu
clairsemé derrière vous Vincent
[Musique]
oui effectivement comme vous le disais
tout à l'heure le cortège est plus
clairsemé clairement que l'autre fois
moi dans après là on est aussi sur une
grande place donc forcément une fois
qu'on arrive sur cette grande place qui
est juste devant monpardage le il y a
beaucoup de gens et enfin il y a
beaucoup de place et les gens arrivent
petit à petit donc il ne remplissent pas
forcément la place vu qu'il continue
petit à petit en tout cas le le cortège
ici continue toujours calmement
seulement perturbé par des explosions
mais c'est des explosion complètement
maîtrisée fait par les manifestants que
vous pouvez entendre de temps en temps
[Musique]
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron sur le
terrain vous continuez bien sûr de
suivre ce cortège qui se dirige toujours
vers cette place d'Italie mais d'un pas
assez assez lent j'accueille Emmanuel du
Barry de backbone Consulting bonjour
Emmanuel bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous avez suivi vous continuez
de suivre pour nous évidemment cette
cette manifestation avec nous cette 11e
journée de manifestation dans les rues
de Paris mais également de nombreuses
villes de France vous avez également
sondé les les opinions suite à cette à
cette rencontre entre Elisabeth borne et
les partenaires sociaux hier à Matignon
quels sont les principaux enseignements
de votre sondage le premier enseignement
c'est que 50% des français imputent
l'échec de cette médiation à la première
ministre elle-même alors quand on
regarde un peu dans les parties bien
évidemment ça change beaucoup mais ce
qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
même parmi les sympathisants LR par
exemple on a plus de 31% c'est
sympathisant qui vient plus de cet échec
à Madame borne alors après il faut aussi
nuancer le propos il y a quand même 35%
des Français qui pensent que cet échec
est dû autant aussi bien au syndicat que
la première ministre et ce pourcentage
monte à 45% chez bien sûr les
sympathisants Renaissance donc
intéressant de voir que les Français
sont partagés sur cette rencontre même
si c'est le diabète borne qui est ciblé
quand on parle de l'échec les syndicats
ont une part de responsabilité et c'est
bien noté par les Français alors
beaucoup de d'enseignements que vous
venez de nous dire on va y revenir bien
sûr en détail d'abord sur ce chiffre 62%
de soutien à la mobilisation ça c'était
il y a trois semaines 66% la semaine
dernière est-ce que l'on peut parler
d'un soutien stable ou bien est-ce que
c'est une c'est une marche d'erreur
comment évolue la courbe de ce soutien à
la manifestation à la mobilisation
depuis le début du mouvement au mois de
janvier jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est quand
même extrêmement stable parce que quand
on a commencé à sonder le 20 janvier on
avait 66% des Français qui étaient pour
qui soutenaient la mobilisation on est à
64 aujourd'hui il y a eu des pics bien
sûr à certains moments des petits creux
mais on reste quand même dans un
pourcentage très élevé néanmoins ce qui
est intéressant de noter c'est que sur
les réseaux sociaux par exemple cette
semaine on a une forte chute de la
mobilisation avec seulement un peu plus
d'un million un million 7 de messages
soit une chute de près de 20-25 % donc
c'est intéressant de voir que dans
l'opinion et sur les réseaux sociaux il
se passe deux choses assez différentes
quand même sur ce coup-là deux choses
assez différentes une nouveauté
également dans ce dans ce sondage un
enseignement en tout cas important c'est
sur cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel comme on attend pour
vendredi prochain les Français attendent
beaucoup du Conseil constitutionnel de
cette décision des sages comme
exactement et on a on a posé la question
aux Français et on leur posant la
question est-ce qu'il se soutenait une
censure totale du texte ou une censure
partielle et ce qui est intéressant de
noter c'est que c'est la position la
plus radicale qui l'emporte parce que
55% des Français soutiennent une censure
totale du texte contre seulement 43 pour
une censure partielle on aurait pu
penser qu'elles sont sur partielle était
un bon compromis les Français ne veulent
pas sur une en tout cas ils veulent une
censure totale du texte donc c'est assez
surprenant à cet égard et également un
quasi plébiscite pour cette question du
référendum d'initiative populaire les
Français ont envie d'aller aux urnes et
les Français ont envie de donner leur
avis parce que 70% d'entre eux sont pour
se référendum et même de manière très
surprenante près de 40 % des
sympathisants Renaissance sont pour
aussi se référer à Dom donc ça veut dire
deux choses la première c'est que il y a
peut-être beaucoup de sympathisants et
les ruaines qui cherchent un peu une
porte de sortie dans ce conflit qui dure
qui s'enlise depuis le mois de janvier
maintenant et par ailleurs on voit bien
que les Français veulent donner leur
avis veulent parler veulent donner leur
opinion ils veulent qu'on les entendent
et ça montre bien qu'ils ne se sentent
pas du tout engagés par leur vote qui
était on le rappelle il y a même moins
d'un an maintenant pour amener le Macron
dont la mesure figurait au programme
donc ça veut dire que le le vote de les
Français veulent refaire le match et
quand on regarde sur les réseaux sociaux
le référendum d'initiative partagée
c'est surtout les responsables
politiques qui en parlent et notamment à
la France insoumise qui eux claire n'ont
pas accepté leur défaite et veulent
clairement à nouveau refaire le match on
continue de suivre cette onzième journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites on est en direct depuis
quelques heures maintenant vous voyez
cette manifestation qui est en train de
se poursuivre cette manifestation qui
est qui est parti aux alentours de 14h
et qui donc se dirige en direction de la
place d'Italie avec quelques événements
toujours assez localisés mais des
moments quand même de tension comme vous
le voyez à l'instant d'ailleurs sur ces
sur ces images tournées par nos envoyés
spéciaux sur le terrain on va peut-être
essayer de les joindre d'ailleurs tu as
mis un Canivez qui est sur place avec
Julien Leclerc Damien encore un moment
de de confusion là on dirait
ouais ça fait de longues minutes que le
stationnons au même endroit ici
boulevard Raspail et je pense que la
tête syndicale ne doit pas être très
loin où on la voit dans les fumées
noires qui se dégagent de ce feu de vélo
que vous voyez sur les images de Julien
Leclerc alors sachez que la police est
en train d'adopter une toute autre
statégée là depuis quelques secondes ils
sont en train d'encadrer disons cette
cette fin de boulevard Raspail avant
qu'on se dirige vers la suite de la
manifestation vous avez des policiers de
part et d'autre de ce de ce boulevard il
y a une banque je vous rappelle qui a
été prise pour cible tout à l'heure par
des éléments radicaux et et pendant de
longues minutes les policiers ne sont
pas intervenus jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent et qu'il
parviennent à qui parvienne à disperser
avec des charges nombreuses d'ailleurs
les manifestants qui jetaient des pavés
alors une pluie de pavés s'est abattue
d'ailleurs sur ces forces de l'ordre et
c'est assez confus ici parce que je ne
peux pas vous parler de militants
d'ultra gauche de type black bloc comme
on parle comme on en comme on l'évoque
depuis le début de la manifestation vous
avez aussi des manifestants ou
effectivement peut-on parler de
manifestants c'est un autre débat mais
vous avez des personnes qui se sont
greffées à ce mouvement hyper radical et
qui vous êtes des pavés un visage
découvert et qui ont parfois 5 ans 60
ans et qui à première vue ne pas les
codes justement de ces militants
ultra radicaux Black Bloc alors c'est si
violent ici d'ailleurs que on a vu aussi
des policiers qui
ont reçu des projectiles et qui ont dû
être évacués aussi par par leurs
collègues tellement les pavés pleuré ici
sur ce boulevard Raspail vous le voyez
au sol d'ailleurs il y aura des des
abribus qui ont été brisés en mille
morceaux la banque c'est vraiment un
paysage chaotique ici que l'on a alors
effectivement c'est peut-être une goutte
d'eau dans ce cortège qui se déroule je
l'imagine très bien lorsqu'il s'agit de
filmer l'intersydicale et là vous avez
une charge de la police vous le voyez
ces policiers qui tentent de faire
remonter et de scinder ce cortège
d'éléments radicaux en deux de façon à
mieux les maîtriser c'est la stratégie
qui a adopté depuis le début depuis le
commencement de de ces violences et
voilà l'idée c'est de contenir un petit
peu les les manifestants dans un endroit
de façon à ce que voilà il ne puisse pas
aller à droite à gauche et allumer des
feux parce que c'est ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire au delà de du jet de
projectile il y a de nombreux casseurs
qui sont en train d'allumer des des feux
de poubelle et de mettre le mobilier
urbain à terre
merci beaucoup Damien Canivez avec on a
vu tout à l'heure les sapeurs-pompiers
de Paris qui sont en train de
d'intervenir pour et bien éteindre les
feux de poubelles Emmanuel Dubarry je
reviens sur cette question du référendum
d'initiative populaire 85 % des Français
y serait favorable j'ai envie de dire
dans ce cas-là pourquoi pas tenter le
coup et bien pourquoi pas tenter le coup
c'est quand même un risque politique
majeur pour le président de la
République parce que on l'a bien vu que
quel que soit la question qu'on est au
pouvoir le risque de réponse non par
principe quand même assez élevé donc ça
paraît risqué et surtout c'est jouer sa
réforme sur un coup de poker on l'aurait
un peu envie de dire après trois mois de
mobilisations trois mois le gouvernement
a quand même tenu même s'il a beaucoup
lâché il a quand même tenu tout ça pour
ça ce sera quand même un peu surprenant
sur les réseaux sociaux on en parle de
du référendum les gens disent on a envie
d'aller voter on a envie de assez peu
figurez-vous alors de manière générale
on entend plus ce genre qui sont
mécontents sur les réseaux sociaux que
les gens qui ont des choses positives
arabes positives à raconter mais on a
des volumes très faibles cette semaine
les gens en parlent assez peu et comme
je vous disais ce sont surtout les
hommes politiques qui en parlent et la
France insoumise en tête alors le
rassemblement national s'y est mis
récemment avec Jordan Bardella qui en a
parlé et qui a soutenu initiative mais
au-delà de ça franchement les Français
comme vous et moi on parle quand même
assez peu faut dire que c'est une mesure
assez technique il faut réunir je crois
que c'est 4,5 millions de signatures
est-ce que on peut penser que ça ça fait
des gens qu'on comprenne pas vraiment de
quoi il s'agit exactement c'est une
mesure qui a jamais tu jamais été
utilisé si je me trompe pas donc dans
les faits les Français connaissent pas
mais néanmoins les Français ont bien
compris le 49-3 quand on parlait de 49-3
ce qui est quand même assez technique
aussi c'était un type de la Constitution
qui n'est pas simple les Français
comprennent très bien donc je pense que
les Français sont tout à fait à même de
le comprendre pour le moment en fait
personne n'en a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup parlé c'est une demande qui est
faite par les les forces politiques
plutôt LFI et France insoumise mais pour
le moment les Français sera tout à fait
même comprendre et le manque
d'engagement vient plus du fait que pour
le moment personne n'en va en parler au
niveau du gouvernement parce que
effectivement c'est mettre le doigt dans
un engrenage qu'il ne maîtrise pas donc
les Français ils seront sûrement
intéressés s'il y a un référendum ils
sont tout à fait à même de comprendre de
quoi il s'agit si on peut comprendre
cette réforme on peut probablement
comprendre le référendum je continue
Emmanuel du Barry de lire les résultats
de ce sondage de xabagboon consulting
pour Le Figaro un sondage que vous
retrouvez en ligne sur Le Figaro.fr et
puis dans l'édition papier bien sûr de
de demain matin ce que je vois Emmanuel
Dubarry c'est qu'il y a les très
optimiste 23% des sondés qui pensent
partir à la retraite à 60 ans voire
avant 60 ans et puis il y a les très
pessimistes qui sont même 7% à penser
qu'ils partiront après 70 ans à la à la
retraite mais globalement Emmanuel a un
consensus se dégage de plus en plus de
Français considèrent qu'il partiront à
la retraite entre 61 et 64 ans comment
est-ce que vous vous l'expliquez bah les
gens ont à force de répéter retraite à
64 ans 24 heures sur 24 attention celle
dans tous les médias et dans toutes les
conversations de dîner ou de bureau les
gens finissent par comprendre qu'ils
vont partir à l'entrée plus tard et par
ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
que ça avait été aussi testé en juin
2022 sur l'âge auquel vous pensez vous
en tant que répondeur partir à la
retraite et il y avait seulement 34 %
des Français qui pensaient partir entre
61 et 64 là on est à 44 donc plus 10
points donc on voit que ça quand même
infuser que les gens ont fini par
comprendre alors ça dit pas si les gens
sont contents ou pas contents de le
faire mais en tout cas les gens semblent
assez résignés sur le l'âge de à
laquelle ils vont pouvoir enfin ou pas
enfin d'ailleurs partir à la retraite ce
que vous avez remarqué également
Emmanuel et sur ce qui se dit sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est cette unité
affichée par l'Inter syndical pour le
moment en tout cas et cette unité qui
qui est saluée à quel point les Français
sont plutôt contents de voir les
syndicats sont capables de s'entendre
parce que sur un projet comme ça on a
souvent vu dans l'histoire syndicale
française des syndicats qui se tient
dans les pattes qui ne sont pas d'accord
on avait bien vu lors du précédent
quinquennat le Emmanuel Macron tenté de
négocier sa retraite un peu de Laurent
Berger de manière discrète pour pas
voyez la tension des autres syndicats là
on voit qu'ils sont unis et les gens
sont assez contents et fiers de voir que
les syndicats peuvent s'unir là-dessus
alors ce que vous dites également c'est
que les streamers alors vous expliquer
déjà des qui des qui il s'agit eux ils
s'engagent c'est la première fois qu'on
voit ça sur un sujet vraiment politique
parce que même pendant la campagne on
n'avait pas trop vu à part pour dénoncer
l'extrême droite et le et Marine Le Pen
qui est le bon un peu un lieu commun sur
les réseaux sociaux on a des streamers
donc des gens qui animent des podcasts
ou qui ont comme vous un micro et une
caméra et qui parle dans leur chambre
plusieurs fois par jour qui ont des
audiences assez phénoménales parce que
certains ont plusieurs millions
d'abonnés et eux ont pris position en
fait dans cette réforme des retraites en
étant assez contre et c'est la première
fois qu'on le voit donc c'est assez
intéressant d'analyser les raisons de
pourquoi ils l'ont fait et effectivement
c'est vraiment le fait marquant et c'est
dangereux pour le gouvernement parce que
ces gens-là ont une audience jeune et on
sait très bien quand les jeunes sont
dans la rue c'est quand même plus
difficile de tenir pour le gouvernement
des influenceurs aussi se mettent à
contester cette réforme pour quelle
raison par par opportunisme alors pas
vraiment pas vraiment par opportunisme
ce qui est intéressant quand on a
regardé c'est que ces influenceurs sont
comme vous et moi il voit bien que le
projet de gouvernement va aller forcer à
travailler plus longtemps certains ne
veulent pas travailler plus longtemps et
du coup prennent position contre mais à
leur propre échelle et d'autres
mentionnent par exemple leurs parents
qui ont été ouvriers qui ont eu des
professions pénibles et se disent bah
forcément à travailler plus longtemps
c'est injuste donc je me lève je prends
la parole et je partage ça avec ma
communauté et ça a eu un impact assez
important mine de rien auprès des jeunes
parce que ces initiatives et on parlait
d'opportunisme ne sont pas opportunistes
parce que certains ont été fortement
critiqués par leur audience pour avoir
pris position là dessus en disant bah
normalement vous n'êtes pas fait pour
faire de la politique rester dans votre
couloir et n'en devient pas donc c'est
pas l'opportunisme je ne pense pas
beaucoup de messages dans le chat je
vous lis par exemple celui d'un
internaute Rico qui nous dit dans son
programme si Macron avait dit 65 ans
personne n'aurait rien trouvé à redire
est-ce qu'il y a pas une une erreur
originelle chez Emmanuel Macron en tout
cas est-ce que c'est quelque chose
quelque chose qui ressort sur les sur
les réseaux sociaux bah ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure c'est que les Français ne
se sentent pas du tout engagés par leur
vote à la présidentielle et ne considère
pas du tout qu'ils ont voté pour une
information 65 ans à l'époque c'était 65
ans son programme et considère qu'ils
ont voté contre Marine Le Pen et il y a
eu pas mal sondages qui sont sortis
récemment et on l'a vu notamment avec le
sondage du Figaro Magazine pour une pour
ne pas le nommer ce weekend qui montre
bien la forte progression de Marine Le
Pen et qui montre bien que certains
électeurs ne voteraient peut-être pas la
même manière s'il votait au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle ce dimanche
dernière question Emmanuel dubary a un
autre enseignement un autre un autre mot
assez novateur que vous utilisez et vous
allez nous expliquer de quoi il s'agit
avec ce slackivisme avec donc le coût
induit par la greffe prolongée sur les
salaires il faut s'attendre à de
nouvelles formes innovantes de
contestation et donc ce ce slackctivisme
qu'est-ce que c'est bah c'est un un
phénomène qui était théorisé aux
États-Unis qui est l'activisme en ligne
en fait et donc slack c'est les
feignants en gros et l'activisme donc
c'est les activistes feignants en gros
qui ne bougent pas de leur can mais qui
conteste sur les réseaux sociaux ou avec
tout ce qu'ils peuvent mais sans avoir
besoin de se déplacer et il faut
s'attendre à un regain de la
mobilisation sur ces réseaux parce que
comme vous le disiez elle manifester ça
coûte cher pour des jours de congés pour
les manifester ça coûte cher c'est pas
extensible donc les gens ont le droit de
trouver d'autres manières de le faire on
l'a vu ce weekend par exemple avec des
actions de coup de poing type brol en
haut là le triomphe donc effectivement
les gens vont continuer à se mobiliser
mais peut-être pas dans la rue et c'est
peut-être ça qui est dangereux parce que
le projet va peut-être passer mais la
colère elle va peut-être rester aussi
merci beaucoup Emmanuel chez backbone
Consulting on retourne sur le terrain on
va aller retrouver Vincent roseron
Vincent il semble que le cortège soit de
nouveau arrêté
oui Timothée effectivement le cortège
était de nouveau arrêté mais on avance
quand même sur un bon pas d'ailleurs une
information que je voudrais c'est qu'il
y a en fait on était quasiment à la fin
du cortège là-bas où il y avait on était
avec force ouvrière et on était
quasiment à la fin du cortège et il y
avait les cars de CRS qui vont très la
fin du cordage puisqu'il y a eu un
cortège de délestage qui s'est mis en
place pour faire passer par exemple le
cortège de la CGT n'empreinte pas le
parcours principal que nous avons tous
emprunter
Mathis ferait et moi ainsi que Damien
Cadillac et Julien Leclerc nous sommes
sur le cortège principal mais il y a à
cortège bis en fait de délestage pour
que tout le monde puisse faire la
manifestation il semblerait
qu'effectivement les le cortège de
délestage soit déjà arrivé d'ailleurs
sur la place de à la place d'Italie
pardon excusez-moi et nous nous venons
de dépasser en fait montparna
Montparnasse et on a normalement et là
nous arrivons justement à la Rotonde là
où il y a eu des débordements tout à
l'heure mais de l'autre côté c'est
toujours très calme
merci beaucoup Vincent roseron on
continue de suivre cette cette
manifestation avec vous j'accueille
Bruno codresse politologue et chercheur
CNRS au sevy-pov bonjour Merci beaucoup
cette onzième journée de manifestation
une journée qui est loin d'être terminée
mais si on devait déjà tirer un premier
bilan qu'est-ce que vous en retenez
il y a toujours de la mobilisation elle
a l'air plus faible peut-être que la
dernière
manifestation mobilisation mais ça reste
quand même un niveau qui est au niveau
significatif les enquêtes d'opinion
continuent de montrer qu'un très fort
rejet du projet de réforme de retraite
dans dans l'opinion donc pour le moment
on est toujours dans la situation
d'impasse les dernières heures ont
montré à la fois pas mal de tension
entre l'exécutif et les syndicats on
voit que ça s'arrange pas du tout pour
le moment les consultations menées par
la première ministre emmené elle
également à une impasse donc pour le
moment on fera les comptes ce soir
exactement mais pour le moment on va
être toujours demain matin dans la même
impasse précisément sur cette rencontre
entre Elizabeth borne et les syndicats
là aussi qu'est-ce que vous retenez
est-ce que vous retenez plutôt le
discours d'Elizabeth Borg qui dit ben
voilà il y a un dialogue on se voit on
discute et quelque part c'est plutôt
positif ou est-ce que vous retenez et
bien les les discours de ces syndicats
qui sortent de de cette réunion en
disant et bien c'est un échec nous
sommes dans une crise démocratique
qu'est-ce que vous retenez de cette
discussion je pense qu'on peut politique
en démocratie parler c'est toujours une
bonne chose voilà on fait toujours un
peu avancer ça permet de mieux
comprendre le point de vue de l'autre
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a des jeux
beaucoup beaucoup de discussions depuis
plusieurs plusieurs mois mais c'est vrai
que malheureusement les syndicats en ont
retiré pour le moment l'idée que on les
reçoit on parle mais au fond on ne
touche pas au point essentiel qui pour
eux la mesure phare les 64 ans alors
c'est une bonne chose quand même de
parler et surtout par rapport à l'image
que ça renvoie à l'ensemble de l'opinion
qui comme nous tous je pense à ce
sentiment de d'impasse et de blocage
c'est plutôt globalement une bonne chose
que l'exécutif essaye de maintenir le
dialogue avec les avec les syndicats par
contre ça pourra pas continuer avec un
dialogue qui tourne à vide on sait
qu'Elisabeth borne on dit on entendit en
tout cas qu'elle joue de son poste sur
cette séquence vous pensez qu'elle a
marqué des points avec cette réunion
hier je crois pas pas pour le moment en
tout cas pas dans l'opinion publique
c'est certain elle conforte peut-être un
peu l'image qu'elle a voulu donner
depuis qu'elle est en poste c'est-à-dire
l'image d'une personne qui veut essayer
de trouver des concertations qui veut
essayer de dialoguer mais c'est vrai
qu'un peu quand même un contraste dans
l'image d'Elizabeth borne entre cette
mission qui lui a été donnée par le chef
de l'État faire des majorités autour de
textes et générer ou trouver des des
passerelles et puis finalement
l'impression qu'elle a donné quand même
depuis le début qu'elle était assez
inflexible il faut se rappeler quand
même que très vite la première ministre
avait dit les 64 ans ça n'est plus
négociable et c'est vrai que elle avait
dit relativement tôt quand j'avais
entendu la première ministre dire ça je
me disais c'est quand même normalement
un peu l'antithèse de la politique en
politique on sait que c'est toujours
très risqué de dire que les choses ne
sont plus négociables malgré tout on a
le sentiment là aussi que
le gouvernement ne peut plus faire
marche arrière aujourd'hui il est
tellement engagé et l'exécutif a mis
tellement la barre haut du point de vue
de son engagement le chef de l'État n'a
pas pour le moment donné de signe qu'il
ménageait une petite trappe de sortie
quelque chose qui permet à tout le monde
de sortir la tête haute parce que c'est
quand même ça aussi le but d'une bonne
négociation c'est que tout le monde a le
sentiment qui peut sortir pas humilié la
tête haute et donc pour le moment c'est
vrai qu'on a une position de l'exécutif
qui est tellement stricte et tellement
au fond sans concession sur la mesure
phare que on est vraiment dans cette
impasse même si elle dit Elisabeth je
n'envisage pas d'avancer sans les
partenaires sociaux donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a bien un jour il va falloir se
remettre autour de la table l'espoir de
l'exécutif c'est que à force de se
remettre autour de la table à force de
faire des petits pas dans la direction
de chacun etc finalement on arrive à
réamorcer quelque chose autour des
thèmes dont les syndicats disent qu'il
aura il aurait fallu en parler depuis le
début le travail condition de travail
les rémunérations les carrières
la formation continue donc tout un tas
d'enjeux et c'est vrai que c'est ça
l'espoir du gouvernement c'est de faire
venir les syndicats sur des thèmes sur
lesquels à la fois ils sont extrêmement
sensibles je pense en particulier des
thèmes sur lesquels Laurent Berger est
très très sensible mais pour le moment
c'est vrai que les syndicats ont repéré
un petit peu on va dire la stratégie de
ce point de vue de l'exécutif et lui
maintiennent leur CAP qui est on ne
parle pas de ces sujets tant que la
mesure phare n'est pas retirée ou en
tout cas mise en pause on le voit à
l'instant sur ces images transmises par
nos agences de presse on voit et bien
les premiers manifestants qui sont en
train d'arriver sur cette place de cette
base d'Italie on va rejoindre Damien
Canivez qui se trouve dans le cortège
Damien où vous trouvez-vous à présent il
semble que le cortège n'avance à nouveau
plus du tout
cassez-vous cassez-vous non parce que
effectivement le pré cortège a rejoint
en tout cas le vrai cortège a été
rejoint par la tête de cortège syndical
et tout ça est arrivé dans une forme de
confusion avec les forces de l'ordre qui
sont intervenus sur les exactions que
nous avons filmé tout à l'heure et on a
le sentiment que les forces de l'ordre
sont en manque d'inspiration dans la
mesure où nous souhaitons simplement
poursuivre notre chemin comme c'est le
cas pour pour le cortège cervical et en
fait là nous sommes à l'arrêt parce que
[Applaudissements]
un peu partout sur cette place d'enfer
autre chose qui nous empêche de
d'accéder au boulevard Saint-Jacques
puis le boulevard Auguste Blanqui et
enfin la place d'Italie donc pour
l'instant tout ça vous avez un rêve et
les gendarmes sont en train de se
replier manifester manifestement mais
c'est assez compliqué de savoir ce qui
se passe ici parce que nous sommes à la
réelle et gendarmes vont à droite à
gauche sont assez dispersées même si là
il semble voilà retrouver une
trajectoire entre guillemets assumée et
et justement laisser le cortège se
porter mais c'est vrai que c'est c'est
assez compliqué parce que les les
tensions ont été si longue sur ce
boulevard Raspail que la distance entre
entre le pré-corpège de manifestants
radicaux et le cortège mené par
l'intersydicale et aussi rejoint chose
qui arrive assez rarement puisque les
casseurs sont quand même bien en amont
du cortège syndical voilà et là vous
voyez aussi les les les les
manifestants qui se campent des slogans
Antipolis et qui les incitent à quitter
cette place d'en faire Rochereau chose
qui sont en train de faire
Damien à l'instant quand on voit ces
mouvements assez confus alors on a bien
compris que il y a d'un côté les
manifestants et d'un autre certains
éléments radicaux qui sont venus et bien
pour
faire un peu sans prendre au milieu
urbain sans prendre à force de l'ordre
est-ce que quelque part les syndicats
même si c'est pas eux ils ne sont pas
directement responsables des actes de
certains des manifestants radicaux mais
enfin est-ce qu'il risque pas de finir
par se mettre l'opinion publique à dos à
force de voir ce type d'image si ce type
d'image était au fond devenait à la fois
si on passait un cap dans la violence
qu'il y ait vraiment des des dégâts
extrêmement importants qu'on ait des
scènes qui marquent beaucoup l'opinion
avec des magasins kifflent je ne sais
pas des choses qui vont marquer en
profondeur l'opinion c'est sûr qu'il
peut y avoir éventuellement un effet
dans le soutien de l'opiant public on en
est pas là pour le moment c'est vrai que
la production de toutes ces images joue
toujours sur des ressorts un peu
émotionnel quand on voit des poubelles
qui flambent quand on voit des
manifestants qui sont au fond qui sont
pris en charge par les forces de
sécurité quand on voit que les scènes de
cette prise en charge tout autour de mal
ça fait monter en gamme les émotions et
c'est vrai que de ce point là si jamais
très très bon parce que ça crée en
particulier sur les réseaux sociaux une
atmosphère qui est une atmosphère qui
est très négative pour le moment on en
est pas là on voit que les journées de
manifestation se suivent au début des
manifestations qui étaient purement
encadrées par les syndicats sans Black
Bloc aujourd'hui avec un peu plus de
Black Blocs qui sont qui sont là et
pourtant le soutien de l'opinion au
syndicat reste important nous avons
publié il y a quelques quelques semaines
notre enquête annuelle sur la confiance
des Français dans la politique et on
voit que la confusion dans les syndicats
elle reste quand même aujourd'hui
nettement nettement plus élevée que la
confiance dans les partis politiques et
que les syndicats sont quand même
globalement à des acteurs
gagnants de l'ensemble de la de la
séquence et on retrouvait en particulier
auprès de auprès de l'opinion on
retrouvait une forme de de crédit qu'ils
avaient perdu ces dernières années
tension en cours à Paris 20 personnes
interpeller ce sont les informations que
nous rapportent nos envoyés spéciaux sur
le le terrain vous continuez bien sûr de
suivre cette manifestation avec nous
nous sommes en direct vidéo et vous avez
également le direct écrit que vous
retrouvez juste en dessous de cette
vidéo sur le sur le site du Figaro Bruno
Bruno cotress bien loin de tous ces
cortèges que nous commentons le
président de la République lui Emmanuel
Macron il se trouve ces jours-ci en
Chine où il est reçu donc par partie
jinfing est-ce selon vous un hasard du
calendrier ou bien une heureuse
coïncidence une coïncidence je dirais
pour le chef de l'État on peut pas faire
l'hypothèse que le chef de l'État
fixerait son agenda notamment
international par rapport à l'actualité
politique
française
par contre c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
le chef de l'État a commenté un petit
peu notre situation politique syndicale
réagissant justement préparation des
syndicats disant leur insatisfaction de
la rencontre avec la la première
ministre et c'est vrai que ça n'a pas
complètement apaisé les relations entre
l'exécutif et les syndicats qui
aujourd'hui sont très très difficiles
pour ne pas dire exécrable est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer un une fin de quinquennat
ou en tout cas une deuxième partie de
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron un petit
peu à la Hollande avec un président et
bien qui va qui va chercher de l'oxygène
à l'étranger et qui se trouve un petit
peu moins présent sur la scène nationale
l'histoire n'est pas écrite mais c'est
certain que régulièrement au cours de
leur seconde mandat nos chefs de l'État
qu'il s'agisse de François Mitterrand de
Jacques Chirac et dans un contexte
différent d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
consacre beaucoup de leur second mandat
à la dimension européenne à la dimension
internationale considérant que dans le
premier mandat ils ont surtout fait de
la politique de la politique nationale
c'est vrai que Emmanuel Macron a un
agenda européen extrêmement important il
y a la guerre en Ukraine qui a ajouté
une dimension internationale très
importante et je ne doute pas qu'à la
sortie du conflit en Ukraine le chef de
l'État va vouloir reprendre revenir sur
un thème qui lui est extrêmement cher
que le thème de la politique de défense
et de sécurité européenne donc je serai
étonné qui Emmanuel Macron dans les mois
qui arrivent et dans les deux trois ans
qui arrivent ne s'occupent pas assez
fortement de l'Europe Emmanuel Macron ne
pourra pas être candidat un troisième
mandat j'imagine qu'il vaudra laisser
une trace importante de ces deux
présidents 10 ans de présidents
françaises au plan européen et il est
évidemment attentif aux enquêtes
d'opinion vous avez lu comme moi ce
baromètre du Figaro Magazine 26%
d'opinion favorable c'est 4 points de
moins qu'il y a un mois est-ce que c'est
il y a danger est-ce que cette chute
peut continuer ou bien est-ce que il
peut compter sur les prochaines réformes
pour se refaire un capital on est
clairement dans la zone de danger
c'est-à-dire que le chef d'État est
passé dans toutes les enquêtes d'opinion
en dessous de la barre des 30% de
popularité il commence à flirter avec
la zone des 20 à 25% qu'elle est
authentiquement extrêmement dangereuse
parce que pour conduire des réformes
pour conduire un pays avec tellement de
tension avec tellement de fractures
tellement d'incompréhension il faut
disposer d'une bonne popularité pour le
moment le chef de l'État est en
popularité faible et ce qui est
inquiétant pour lui c'est qu'on voit que
dans ces sympathisants les sympathisants
par exemple du parti présidentiel dans
ces dans son électorat de premier tour
il commence à avoir un véritable
effraytement et qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire est-ce qu'il a fait des erreurs des
trop grosses erreurs depuis sont depuis
l'élection présidentielle ici oui
lesquelles je pense que le chef de
l'État a peut-être fait une erreur en
ayant une campagne présidentielle qui
était on s'en rappelle une campagne très
courte vous rappelez il y avait
quasiment pas de campagne du chef de
l'État très peu de propositions les
lectorat n'a capté que la proposition
sur la réforme des retraites et le chef
d'État sans aucun doute négligé de faire
une passerelle un pont entre sa campagne
présidentielle et tout ce qui s'était
passé avant par exemple prenons un
exemple on n'a pas beaucoup entendu le
chef de l'État pendant la campagne
présidentielle dire passage vous propose
ça parce que je l'ai entendu dans le
grand débat national où je l'ai entendu
dans la convention citoyenne sur le
climat et c'est vrai que le chef de
l'État n'a pas donné le sentiment pour
le moment d'arriver à fixer un cap une
ligne alors lui comme tous les
politiques dit qu'il a un cap bien
évidemment mais c'est vrai que ce cap
pour le moment on ne le voit pas assez
clairement et tout le monde se pose la
même question qui est quelle est la
différence entre Macron deuxième mandat
et Macron premier mandat est-ce que
c'est le prolongement est-ce que ça
complète le chef de l'État nous avait
dit ça sera pas le même mandat ça c'est
plus le même Président c'est plus le
même façon d'exercer le pouvoir et c'est
vrai que pour le moment il a ouvert
notre appétit mais on n'a pas vu
beaucoup de choses venir lors de la
crise des gilets jaunes il s'en était
sorti effectivement avec ce grand débat
national est-ce que il peut dégainer ce
type de d'idées pour s'en sortir là où
est-ce que vous dites les Français ne se
feront pas avoir une deuxième fois je
crois que c'est un peu cette idée
effectivement
je pense que c'est pas possible on peut
pas refaire une deuxième fois le grand
débat le chef de l'État prendrait le
risque considérable de faire un mauvais
remake du grand débat national autant
dans le grand débat national le premier
tout le monde a salué la performance du
chef de l'État sa capacité à s'extraire
d'une situation qui était encore
beaucoup plus problématique que
qu'aujourd'hui mais par contre le
refaire poserait instantanément la
question qui est mais d'abord où sont
les conclusions du premier grand débat
qu'en a-t-il fait avant d'aborder un
second grand débat national on voit que
c'est beaucoup plus sans aucun doute du
côté de ses conventions citoyennes que
le chef de l'État est en train de
regarder une solution peut être un peu
plus politique
politicienne Elisabeth borde est-ce
qu'il doit s'en séparer selon vous
est-ce que ça peut être une occasion
pour lui de relancer ce second
quinquennat la première ministre sort
très affaiblie de toute la séquence
popularité faible également comme le le
chef de l'État et les habitants pour le
moment elle peut rebondir pourquoi pas
mettons en tout cas pour le moment n'est
pas arrivé à incarner dans le pion
publique un personnage le personnage
Elisabeth borne peine à émerger les
options positives à propos d'Elisabeth
borne c'est qu'elle est sérieuse qu'elle
est compétente qu'elle travaille ses
dossiers par contre les opinions
négatifs c'est que c'est une technocrate
qui manque d'empathie par rapport au
pays ou alors qu'elle n'est pas arrivée
à s'affirmer par rapport à Emmanuel
Macron et c'est vrai qu'en partant de là
on imagine mal qu'elle puisse tenir sur
cette image là pendant quatre ans merci
beaucoup Bruno cotreesse politologue et
chercheur CNRS au cevipov merci d'être
passé dans les studios de Figaro life
pour nous aider à analyser et à
comprendre ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui
dans notre pays on va retourner sur le
terrain vous le voyez ici ces places de
places d'Italie ou les premiers
manifestants sont en train d'arriver
vincent roseron lui se trouve dans le
cortège Vincent vous êtes je crois au
niveau de cette fameuse brasserie de
alors Vincent on a un petit souci de son
il semble qu'on ne vous entendent pas on
va essayer de rétablir ce problème je
vois que vous êtes en train de rallumer
peut-être le micro à moins que ce soit
un problème de de batterie voilà on vous
entend pas je vous confirme c'est pas
grave on va aller voir Damien canivevez
notre deuxième équipe sur le sur le
terrain Damien vous êtes un petit peu
plus en amont de ce cortège vous vous
approchez donc de cette de cette place
d'Italie où est-ce que vous vous trouvez
précisément et quel est l'ambiance sur
place
alors l'ambiance a strictement rien à
voir avec celle que l'on a pu connaître
par le passé puisque vous avez vu tout à
l'heure sur des images des feux de
poubelle des jets de projectiles face
aux forces de l'ordre alors que lequel
est quand même relatif puisqu'il y a une
entreprise un concessionnaire automobile
bien connu qui est en train de se faire
vandaliser les forces de l'ordre sont
assez loin d'ici vont-elles surgir d'un
instant tel autre c'est pas impossible
dès lors que des exactions sont commises
à partir de ce moment-là des des
policiers ont tendance à venir assez
vite pour encercler justement ces
vitrines en attendant voilà vous voyez
des manifestants radicaux qui sont en
train de cailler assez cette
concession alors on va essayer nous de
se mettre à l'écart avec Julien on va se
mettre à l'écart avec Julien Leclerc
parce que c'est très compliqué de filmer
ces choses-là vous savez très bien que
nous les journalistes ne sont pas
forcément les bienvenus dans ces
cortèges et que des confrères ont été
pris pour cibles pour les mêmes raisons
donc nous sommes obligés de baisser la
caméra à la suite de certaines menaces
qui sont proférées la con contre nous il
y a voilà des vitres qui sont en train
de voler en éclat mais pour notre
sécurité nous ne pouvons pas vous
montrer ces images le calme est très
relatif ici et je peux vous et je peux
vous dire que on n'est pas sur des
militants Black Bloc tel qu'on peut les
connaître habituellement tout à l'heure
alors que on en était en train de
déambuler sur ce boulevard Saint-Jacques
à un manifestant à visage découvert à
jeter un pavé en direction des forces de
l'ordre il se trouve que ce pavé est
arrivé dans la tête d'un manifestant qui
se trouvait non loin de ces policiers et
gendarmes et nous sommes allés le voir
il est sérieusement blessé à la tête
donc c'est dire le niveau de tension qui
règne ici même si sur les images vous
voyez un calme apparent on sait qu'à
tout moment la moindre étincelle la
situation peut devenir très très vite
exposée
[Musique]
merci beaucoup Damien Canivet sur le
terrain pour Le Figaro live cet
après-midi j'accueille en plateau
anne-charlen Bezina bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes
constitutionnaliste maître de conférence
en droit public on va revenir sur cette
question maintenant cruciale qui est
dans tous les têtes c'est cette question
du conseiller constitutionnel puisque
finalement c'est ça maintenant qu'il
faut savoir c'est est-ce que le Conseil
constitue va valider ou non la réforme
un mot sur ce qu'on vient d'entendre de
la part de Damien Canivez est-ce que ce
type de mots de
mouvement de violence même si ça reste
localisé ça reste globalement maîtrisé
mais quand même des moments de tension
est-ce que cela peut jouer est-ce que
cela peut avoir un impact dans l'esprit
des sages du Conseil constitutionnel et
donc dans la décision qu'ils vont rendre
infinie alors c'est paradoxal parce
qu'en fait on est dans un moment où on
se dit que la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel
cristallise toute cette tension donc on
aurait presque besoin que cette décision
Vienne fluidifier viennent donner une
solution et pour autant d'un point de
vue juridique et strictement
démocratique de séparation des pouvoirs
on peut souhaiter que non c'est à dire
que précisément un juge n'est pas censé
être sensible aux arguments de la rue
etc mais c'est vrai que le Conseil
conditionnel a quand même cette habitude
parce que c'est une spécificité
française de se prononcer très à chaud
du processus législatif dans le moment
où la population est encore très
sensibilisée à ces questions donc il a
il a aussi l'habitude de pacifier un
petit peu en essayant de ne pas prendre
frontalement non plus des problèmes et
en essayant toujours de se prononcer de
manière assez haute j'ai envie de dire
en termes de point de vue par rapport à
ces questions donc je ne crois pas
nécessairement que ça influencera le
processus décisionnel est-ce qu’après la
décision en tant que telle sera de
nature à apaiser le conflit ou pas là ça
sera une question aussi de et bien de
mesures entre deux décisions finalement
puisque il y a la décision sur le projet
de loi de réforme des retraites mais
aussi la décision sur le référendum
d'initiative partagé qui peut peut-être
aider un petit peu à fluidifier alors
concrètement on va rentrer dans le vif
du sujet avec vous unchard Beena on va
profiter de votre expertise les juges
constitutionnel ont donc une semaine
pour statuer pour décider donc du sort
de de ce texte une décision qui est
attendue pour vendredi 14 avril prochain
quels sont les options sur la table
aujourd'hui alors il y a deux décisions
à rendre on le rappelle la décision sur
le projet de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale qui porte réformes des
retraites et la décision sur le projet
de référendum d'initiative partagée
alors concernant le projet de loi de
réforme des retraites c'est un contrôle
qui est très plein de la part du Conseil
constitutionnel il peut se saisir de
l'intégralité de la loi il a pas besoin
de rester uniquement dans le cadre de la
critique de la requête donc là en plus
on a eu beaucoup de requêtes il y a une
requête des députés RN une requête des
députés socialistes une requête des
sénateurs et de la première ministre
donc il est déjà très nourri en
information évidemment dans ces méthodes
de travail le Conseil constitutionnel a
l'habitude d'appréhender en amont ces
questions donc ils travaillent sûrement
depuis le début du processus législatif
sur ces questions avec un membre pré
rapporteur de de cette loi
qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre de lui
alors il y a soit l'invalidation totale
en considérant que et bien il ne fallait
pas utiliser le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale à
leur rectificatif pour un projet de loi
de réforme des retraites pourquoi parce
que c'est une procédure très accélérée
parce que c'est un projet de loi avec un
objet bien particulier néanmoins le
Conseil consuel peut aussi se rattacher
au fait que pas mal de dispositions vont
concerner l'équilibre de 2023 donc c'est
toujours très difficile de savoir s'il
en arrivera jusqu'à la censure totale et
il peut y avoir la censure partielle
c'est-à-dire pas mal de dispositions de
loi qui soit censurées pour sortir un
petit peu trop de ce véhicule
particulier parce que c'est ça la grande
question c'est qu'en fait beaucoup de
Décines sont uniquement sur la procédure
et ça intéresse aussi les Français de
savoir que cette procédure qui a été
utilisée elle a été très chahutée on a
vu qu'elle a été très courte que le fait
d'avoir choisi un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale avait
beaucoup bousculé les choses donc on
attend une réponse du Conseil
constitutionnel sur ces questions est-ce
que une censure totale du texte c'est
possible en tout cas est-ce que c'est
déjà arrivé alors c'est déjà arrivé les
censures totales pour des motifs de fond
pour les motif de procédure c'est arrivé
deux fois en 78 en 2012 pour des cas
relativement lourds quand même notamment
une première fois en 78 où on avait voté
la deuxième partie du projet de loi de
finance avant la première donc on ne
peut pas solutionner le problème sans
reprendre toute la discussion et ici
c'est vrai que ça serait la première
fois que le Conseil constitutionnel sont
sur le gouvernement pour avoir choisi
une procédure qui ne serait pas la bonne
et encore une fois pour en arriver à une
censure comme celle-là il faudrait que
le Conseil constitutionnel estime que
aucune des dispositions du projet de loi
de réforme des retraites ne concerne
l'équilibre du financement de la Sécu
pour cette année or on le sait bien
cette retraite elle va être
d'application immédiate enfin quasiment
puisque ça s'appliquera dès le mois de
septembre donc il y aura forcément une
petite dispibilisation de l'équilibre
pour 2020 il faut qu'il y ait des
dispositions qui a un impact budgétaire
sur 2023 c'est ça qui est important de
de redire c'est qu'en réalité c'est un
texte très technique la projet le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative et la loi
organique nous précise que un projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale c'est quoi c'est quelque chose
qui va affecter l'équilibre de la
sécurité sociale et rectificatif parce
qu'il vient rectifier ce qu'on a décidé
en décembre donc il faut que ça affecte
l'équilibre de cette année évidemment
beaucoup des dispositions index seniors
CDI seniors même les dispositions sur la
pénibilité concernent en réalité une
projection en 2030 donc sorte très
largement du véhicule du projet de loi
de financement de la Sécu rectificatif
et donc on peut imaginer un conseil
constitutionnel qui nous dise c'est
mieux de ne pas utiliser ce type de
projet de loi à l'avenir parce que trop
de dispositions sortent en fait du
domaine et on peut pas avoir une vraie
réforme complète des retraites avec un
véhicule comme celui-là et c'est donc
sur ces points du texte que l'on peut
peut-être envisager une censure
partielle on verra bien est-ce que le
fait que le Conseil constitutionnel
valide l'ensemble de la réforme est-ce
que ça c'est possible à première vue
comme ça j'ai le sentiment j'ai
l'impression que c'est assez peu
probable ça me semble pour connaître
bien la jurisprudence constante du
Conseil constitutionnel ça me semble peu
probable parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel et c'est la mission
d'ailleurs que lui donne la loi
organique et très sensible au domaine
des lois c'est à dire que une loi de
finances ne doit servir qu'à voter des
finances une loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale ne doit servir qu'à
l'équilibre de la sécurité sociale et là
on voit bien qu'on est quand même très
borderline le Conseil d'État dans son
avis préalable au vote de cette loi
avait déjà dit que beaucoup de
dispositions sortaient un petit peu du
véhicule législatif donc je pense que le
Conseil constitutionnel sera amené à
censurer au moins certains dispositifs
et à émettre des réserves
d'interprétation c'est à dire à guider
le législateur pour qu'à l'avenir la
procédure soit peut-être un petit peu
mieux menée alors quelles sont ces
dispositifs les plus épineux sur le plan
constitutionnel donc vous avez dit
l'index senior c'est ça l'index senior
le CDI senior on peut penser aux
disponibilité au dispositions concernant
la pénibilité aussi en réalité tout ce
qu'on appelle les mesures
complémentaires d'un projet de loi de
réforme des retraites qui méritent à
plein de se retrouver dans un projet de
loi de réforme des retraites ont quand
même des des difficultés à se retrouver
dans ces projets de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale parce qu'il ne
concerne pas l'équilibre de la sécurité
sociale c'est plutôt des dispositions on
le voit qui concerne le travail et donc
toutes ces questions là pourraient tout
à fait être considérées comme trop hors
du texte on a retrouvé Vincent roseron
sur le sur le terrain au niveau de cette
brasserie de la rotonde boulevard du
Montparnasse Vincent roseron on se
disait tout à l'heure il semble que la
situation à cet endroit là en tout cas
soit redevenu assez calme
oui effectivement en fait dans notre
dans la fin du cortège mais au milieu du
cortège tout est assez calme depuis le
début de la manifestation et du coup on
est passé devant la Rotonde et il y a eu
vraiment un espèce de d'ailleurs on va
s'approcher un peu avec Mathis fleuret
pour vous montrer alors on voit les
dégâts qu'il y a eu que vous avez pu
voir pendant que ça se passait avec
Damien et je viens Leclerc mais en fait
les gens se sont à s'arrête prennent des
photos et de comprennent en fait ils ont
pas très bien compris ce qui s'était
passé puisque eux ils étaient dans une
association qui était très pacifique
depuis le début et maintenant il voit ça
ils comprennent ils ont pas très bien
compris ce qui s'était passé beaucoup de
gens nous ont dit d'ailleurs euh
pourquoi vous filmez ça alors que on
était sur une manifestation très très
tranquille beaucoup de gens disaient
mais c'est pas c'est ça nous dessert
finalement d'avoir ces débordements lors
des manifestations c'est c'est ce qu'on
a entendu en tout cas aux abords de
cette brasserie donc de la rotonde là en
tout cas on est sur la fin du cortège
qui va reprendre le boulevard Raspail et
remonter on va vous montrer avec les
images de Baptiste florait le cortège
qui est en train de remonter là
actuellement pour aller à Place d'Italie
mais on a regardé on a fait que la
moitié en fait de de ce parcours de
manifestation
[Musique]
qui a mis du temps non pas à démarrer
mais qui en tout cas s'est retrouvé
bloqué à plusieurs reprises arrêtez à
plusieurs reprises et qui a mis du temps
à se diriger vers cette place d'Italie
qui explique la raison pour laquelle et
bien vincer on reçoit Mathis fleuret se
retrouve seulement à mi-parcours alors
qu'il est quand même déjà 18h uncharlet
de Zina on parle tout à l'heure du du
poids du contexte social du contexte
politique sur les décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que alors on a
parlé des violences mais est-ce que par
exemple la menace d'un retour des
blocages peut là aussi instaurer un
rapport de force vis-à-vis de la
décision et vis-à-vis du de des sages
qui composent ce Conseil constitutionnel
alors encore une fois par rapport aux
conseils constitutionnel je suis pas sûr
qu'il y a forcément d'influence de ces
questions mais en fait le la l'autorité
qui est visée par ces manifestations
c'est bien plus le gouvernement et le
président parce que on se rend compte
qu'on a deux tempos finalement le
gouvernement et la majorité essaye de se
situer déjà en aval de cette de cette
réforme en se disant et bien c'est
terminé c'est derrière alors que les
syndicats ont encore espoir alors il y a
cet exemple dont on parle beaucoup
maintenant du CPE en 2006 mais il n'y a
pas que ça il y a des exemples sous la
5ème république de loi qui ont été
suspendues non appliquées et donc on
voit bien que finalement les syndicats
même s'ils devaient y avoir une
déclaration de conformité du Conseil
constitutionnel ne désespère pas et la
popularité est toujours du côté du
mouvement syndical donc la population
adhère à cette idée que on ne lâche rien
qu'on est dans un temps long et que
cette réforme des retraites est loin
d'être dernière nous c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est de voir qu'il y a une
temporalité qui est différente entre le
processus législatif de ce texte quand
bien même il devait être promulgué et le
processus d'acceptation sociale qui
semble beaucoup plus long et beaucoup
plus chaotique sur le CPE effectivement
vous faites référence donc à cette
réforme portée par le gouvernement de
2002 Villepin en 2006 une réforme
adoptée dans l'hémicycle une réforme
validée par le Conseil constitutionnel
mais qui n'a finalement jamais été mise
en œuvre est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un
destin pareil pour cette réforme des
retraites alors c'est vrai on avait ici
un petit paradoxe dans les deux têtes de
l'exécutif c'est que c'était une réforme
qui était bien plus portée par le
Premier ministre que par le président
lui-même et le président n'a donc pas
mis beaucoup de bonnes volonté à ensuite
appliquer ce texte lorsqu'il a vu la
tension sociale qui existait il faut
savoir aussi que Jacques Chirac avait
une vraie hantise des mouvements sociaux
et donc attendaient beaucoup de de la
validation populaire et ici ça serait
quand même à mon avis plus difficile que
ça s'applique parce que on voit bien que
c'est le président de la République qui
est derrière cet engagement c'est un
engagement de sa campagne présidentielle
donc finalement ça ne serait pas le
gouvernement qui serait en défaut mais
ça serait le président lui-même donc ce
sera plus difficile à mon avis d'en
arriver à cela même la pause proposée
par les organisations syndicales n'a pas
été honoré de succès par le gouvernement
et le président donc j'ai bien plus
l'impression que que cette majorité avec
son président tient le cap de et bien de
de la stabilité de cette réforme dans le
temps
417 000 manifestants dans les rues de
France à 17 heures contre
521000 le 28 mars ce sont les chiffres
que qui nous reviennent pour le moment
du terrain et qui ont été collectés par
nos équipes du Figaro data à 18h pardon
je vous disais 17h à 18h417 000
manifestants contre 521000 le 28 mars
avec donc une mobilisation qui semble
être revue à la baisse un autre élément
un jardin bézina que nous évoquions tout
à l'heure c'est ce référendum
d'initiative populaire d'abord c'est une
mesure qui pour le moment n'a jamais été
appliqués qui n'a jamais été mise en
place alors si en 2019 pour la
privatisation d'Aéroport de Paris mais
vous avez raison sur un point ça a été
mise en oeuvre mais ça n'a pas été
jusqu'à son terme donc la grande
question qu'on va avoir ici c'est est-ce
que ce référendum d'initiative partagé
c'est vrai que c'est pas vraiment un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
puisqu'il faut que ce soit les
parlementaires qui le soutiennent et
bien est-ce que vous pourrez vraiment
déboucher sur un référendum est-ce qu'il
pourrait débloquer la situation déjà il
a beaucoup d'inconvénients ce qu'il est
très corseté ce référendum d'initiative
partagé déjà il faut une décision du
conseil qui qui considère que il est
bien recevable moi je pense que ça sera
le cas parce qu'il y a pas vraiment de
problème de recevabilité il rentre bien
dans l'objet de l'article 11 il n'a pas
pour objet d'abroger une loi promulguée
puisque la loi de réforme des retraites
est pas encore promulguée mais il faut
encore recueillir près de 4 millions 8
signatures de citoyens français et
encore après cela il faut espérer que le
processus parlementaire n'amène pas à
une discussion de cette proposition
avant que le président ne soit obligé de
le soumettre à référendum et ça fait
deux délais un délai de neuf mois pour
le recueil des signatures et un délai de
6 mois pour ne pas en discuter au
Parlement donc vous le voyez il y a
beaucoup de corsets 4,7 millions de
signatures c'est absolument énorme c'est
absolument énorme et c'est très inédit
dans l'Union européenne et même dans le
monde où ce type de droit de pétition
existe par exemple en Italie c'est
au-delà d'à peu près 500 000 donc on est
vraiment dans quelque chose de de masque
irréalisable dès l'origine du texte
est-ce que cette ne serait-ce que la
mise en campagne de ce référendum
pourrait au moins stabiliser les choses
c'est une question qu'il faudra se poser
et le Conseil constitutionnel pourrait
tout à fait rendre de décisions un peu
originales avec une décision qui
laisserait passer ce projet de loi de
réforme des retraites mais une décision
qui laisserait aussi continuer le
processus de référendum il faut savoir
que les deux textes peuvent tout à fait
suivre leur vie de manière indépendante
l'un de l'autre en tous les cas ce RIP
ça ne ferait pas les affaires du
gouvernement parce que ça va être
compliqué de discuter avec les syndicats
pendant la collecte des signatures
exactement d'autant que les syndicats
ont dit qu'ils allaient y aller chercher
ces signatures avec beaucoup de ferveur
qu'ils entendaient faire de ce de ce
référendum un argument de poids en
termes politiques on peut penser aussi
aux parties d'opposition qui verront une
une continuation finalement de
l'opposition au mouvement donc cette
temporalité inversée qui fait que le
gouvernement veut déjà se projeter dans
la préréforme des retraites elle aura
sûrement beaucoup de mal à s'imposer
dans le calendrier parlementaire et dans
le calendrier citoyen avec la venue de
ce processus et son succès peut-être
est-ce que cette réforme des retraites
n'est pas en train de devenir une sorte
de sparadrap pour le pour le
gouvernement elle est en tout cas le
symbole d'une crise qui existe de
confiance finalement dans la vie
politique de confiance aussi dans
l'avenir de ce gouvernement alors est-ce
que des réponses politiques ou
constitutionnelles pourraient être
apportées c'est la question qu'il faut
se poser à l'heure actuelle est-ce qu'un
remaniement par exemple suffirait est-ce
qu'un changement de Premier ministre
est-ce que une dissolution pourrait être
envisagée on sait qu'on a un président
de la République Emmanuel Macron qui est
très peu enclin à utiliser les
mécanismes constitutionnels qui sont à
sa disposition alors la solution
est-ce que sa solution n'est pas au
moins politique c'est-à-dire dans un
discours peut-être que la solution à
toutes ces angoisses c'est peut-être un
petit peu plus d'espoir et à ce qu'on
peut espérer un nouveau cap cette
fameuse nouvelle méthode est-ce que
c'est pas le moment peut-être de la
Lancer on verra ce que le gouvernement
et le président sont en mesure de
proposer si la procédure du Rip aboutit
quel serait le texte
alors le texte actuellement proposé
c'est cette idée que on ne peut pas
revenir à un âge supérieur de départ à
la retraite à 62 ans donc c'est une
manière d'installer un seuil maximum
d'âge de départ il faut le savoir c'est
ce texte l'a pris isolément ne suffira
pas à réformer le droit des retraites
parce que déjà il faut savoir quel
profession ça concerne
quels années de départ de de
commencement de travail donc il y a une
réforme des retraites c'est évidemment
bien plus complexe que une simple phrase
notée dans cette proposition de loi donc
quand bien même ce cette proposition de
référendum était adoptée ou en tout cas
avec du succès il faudra de toute façon
en passer par un régime juridique bien
plus précis que ce que cette loi ne
précise et notamment parce qu'elle aura
pour objet d'abroger la réforme des 64
ans donc il y aura forcément une
incohérence législative à solutionner et
ça ne pourra pas se faire qu'avec cette
simple phrase on va retrouver Damien
Canivet sur le sur le terrain Damien la
place d'Italie est en train de se
remplir petit à petit est-ce que vous
nous confirmez cette information et et
est-ce que la situation comment la
situation évolue sur place vous étiez
témoin tout à l'heure d'un certain
nombre de scènes de tension j'ai
l'impression que c'est plutôt redescendu
et quel bilan plus généralement
tirez-vous de ce que vous avez vu sur le
terrain aujourd'hui de cette onzième
journée de manifestation
vous m'auriez posé cette question
Timothée dolom à savoir est-ce que la
manifestation se déroule dans le calme
il y a très exactement 15 secondes je
vous aurais dit oui mais au moment où
vous m'avez posé cette question des
fumées blanches ce sont voilà dispersés
ici où nous nous trouvons vers la fin de
cette manifestation et on a l'impression
effectivement que les policiers sont
revenus
sur l'itinéraire de la manifestation
avec une fois de plus des pavés qui sont
en train de pleuvoir donc la situation
ce temps à nouveau alors qu'elle était
calme il y a quelques instants on est
même passé vous l'avez vu devant une
concession automobile et ça c'était
plutôt bien passé avec quelques jeux de
projectiles mais aucune aucun
affrontement réel avec les forces de
l'ordre il y avait en plus des éléments
de chantier et d'autres enseignes qui
auraient pu être qui auraient pu être
prise pour cible par par les
manifestants il se trouve que il y a
rien eu il y a eu aucune aucun grand
débordement alors que là vous voyez il y
a une fois de plus un cordon de
policiers qui se met en place en tout
cas une la formation de police qui
s'organise avec de l'autre côté une fois
encore des casseurs qui sont en train de
balancer des pavés et je peux vous dire
comme vous venez de le voir à l'instant
sur les images de Julien Leclerc que ce
sont pas des cailloux qui sont lancés ce
sont de véritables pavés du mobilier
urbain extrêmement lourd à tel point que
certains policiers même ont été évacués
tout à l'heure par leur camarades parce
que ils se sont ils ont perdu
connaissance on a été témoins un moment
donné
d'un engin explosif qui a explosé dans
les pieds des forces de l'ordre il y a
au moins deux policiers qui ont dû être
évacués par leurs camarades et là vous
voyez que les policiers battent en
retraite en tout cas sont en train de
peut-être retrouver leur camarades pour
revenir un peu plus tard un peu plus
fort parce que en fait là nous trouvons
sur sur un boulevard qui est séparé par
une ligne de métro et de l'autre côté il
y a le cortège syndical qui défile dans
le plus grand des calmes c'est assez
étonnant d'ailleurs comme ambiance parce
que vous avez la partie gauche de la rue
qui est en proie à des violences assez
assez incroyables et de l'autre côté sur
la partie droite il y a le cortège
syndical qui manifeste dans le plus
grand des des pacifismes alors là des
des grenades lacrymogènes viennent
d'être tirés à l'instant par les forces
de l'ordre et le bilan que je peux tirer
Timothée aussi pour répondre à la
deuxième partie de votre question c'est
que tout toute cette manifestation s'est
déroulé en fait dans une tension
beaucoup plus importante que la dernière
que nous avons suivi le mardi de la
semaine dernière alors que les policiers
redoutaient des exactions aussi fortes
que le jeudi précédent la semaine
dernière a été relativement calme alors
qu'aujourd'hui on a vraiment assisté à
des scènes ultra-violente vraiment on
avait vu on avait l'impression de
revivre ces images vous savez qu'on a vu
à Sainte Soline avec des manifestants
ultra organisés qui s'en prenaient à des
forces de l'ordre avec des parapluies
avec un attirail très très
organisé bien là c'est c'est plus ou
moins les la même ambiance que l'on est
en train de retrouver vous voyez sur les
images de Julien Leclerc là les
policiers qui sont en train de de
reculer et les manifestants casseurs qui
se trouvent juste derrière nous qui sont
en train d'essayer de ben voilà de de
gagner ou de gagner un peu de marge sur
eux sachant que vous entendez beaucoup
de bruit autour de moi parce que des
grenades de désencerclement sont sont
lancés et nous nous trouvons juste en
dessous de la ligne de métro qui est en
extérieur à cet endroit où nous nous
trouvons et forcément l'écho est assez
impressionnant des feux également sont
allumés ici des barricades ont été ont
été allumés cette fin de manifestation
va se tendre encore davantage un abri de
bus aussi la viande céder sous le coup
d'un d'un pavé et les pompiers qui
cherchent une fois encore à intervenir
en toute sécurité sur sur ce boulevard
de façon à éteindre l'incendie là vous
voyez des des des une fois encore des
des grenades qui sont qui sont qui sont
lancés et des pavés d'ailleurs qui
atterrissent vraiment sur les casques
des policiers franchement on voit mal
comment cette manifestation pourrait se
terminer dans le calme vu l'ambiance qui
règne ici à Paris
sur le sur le terrain vous continuez de
faire attention de prendre soin de vous
merci en tout cas d'avoir suivi cette
cette manifestation pour nous d'être
venue nous rapporter ce que vous voyez
sur le terrain on continue avec vos
images avec celle de Julien Leclerc qui
est avec vous et on voit donc ces scènes
de tension ces mouvements de foule un
mot peut être bézina sur ce que vient de
nous décrire d'Amiens canivevez et bien
finalement une extrême violence qu'on
retrouve il a fait quand même le
parallèle avec Sainte Soline donc on se
dit que on n'arrive plus à avoir les
manifestations apaisées qu'on avait en
début de manifestation sociale et ça
prouve finalement que le climat ce temps
qu'on a du mal à retrouver le chemin du
dialogue et alors évidemment c'est c'est
violence là elles sont sûrement
périphériques à la contestation sociale
mais il y a un moment de vie les uns
contre les autres qui est quand même
très désagréable à vivre en démocratie
on a eu aussi beaucoup fou dans le
discours politique cette conseille cette
contestation des forces de l'ordre et
dans ces moments là on se dit quand même
qu'il y a il y a besoin de renouer le
dialogue d'arriver à apaiser un petit
peu ces situations parce qu'on peut pas
continuer quand même dans un dans un
climat ou ces images deviennent
quotidiennes et c'est malheureusement ce
qui est en train de s'installer donc ça
ça donne un peu un sentiment en avant de
de dialogue rompu et c'est ça je pense
qui est le plus le plus coûteux
aujourd'hui à regarder et à constater 20
interpellation nous dit-on au minimum
cet après-midi dans les rues de la
capitale c'est c'est un chiffre assez
c'est assez important quand même oui ça
me semble assez important et puis bon on
voit que on est à peine au début
finalement de cette journée puisqu'elle
n'est pas terminée et qu'elle ne se
terminera pas forcément dans le calme
alors voilà évidemment
on ne peut que souhaiter que la
manifestation sociale redevienne la loi
et que la violence redevienne
l'exception puisque ici on a presque le
sentiment que les choses s'inversent
puisque ça n'est même plus le temps de
revendications que de la violence à
l'état pur et ça c'est un peu dangereux
quand on voit que ça peut se propager et
devenir aussi c'est ça qui est un peu
dangereux dans ce message c'est cette
idée de se dire que la violence est elle
l'ultime manière de faire bouger le
gouvernement et que il ne reste plus que
ça on entend souvent d'ailleurs dans
dans le dialogue dans cette idée de se
dire que les gilets jaunes ont réussi
parce qu'ils ont été plus violents et
que donc il ne resteraient que ça il
faut savoir que les gilets jaunes ont
très peu été entendus quand même et que
la violence n'a pas particulièrement
servi leurs causes donc voilà on quand
le président de la République nous
disait il y a 15 jours il faut se
remettre autour de la table on peut le
souhaiter que ça soit la voix
d'apaisement du conflit qui qui gagne va
interpellation c'est vrai que on a déjà
connu davantage mais vu le climat qui
commence à s'installer sur cette
manifestation on se dit que il n'est que
18h et que malheureusement peut-être que
les choses peuvent continuer à dégénérer
et évidemment c'est n'est pas ce que
nous souhaitons on parle à une Charlène
Bezina du 13 avril comme prochaine
journée de manifestations c'est en tout
cas ce que nous ce que nous rapporte
certains journalistes du Figaro d'après
des sources syndicales ça serait donc la
veille de cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est finalement assez
logique oui c'est encore une manière
d'être dans les grands événements de ce
de ce texte et de le suivre dans sa vie
politique et parlementaire néanmoins il
faut pas oublier aussi que les
manifestations dites sauvages ont existé
juste après le 49-3 et on peut tout à
fait imaginer qu'après cette décision du
Conseil constitutionnel suivant qu'elle
soit favorable ou non à une certaine
issue et bien il n'y a encore des
contestations populaires c'est vrai
qu'on se rend compte finalement encore
une fois d'un d'un vrai fossé entre le
cheminement représentatif du texte et le
cheminement populaire et c'est là en
effet que se trouve l'essentiel de notre
problème c'est c'est de reconnecter
c'est de se faire qui qui finalement
aujourd'hui vivent une vie complètement
indépendante l'une de l'autre ça peut
faire pression en tout cas je vous ai
déjà posé la question mais ça peut faire
pression à mon avis pas tellement sur
les juges en tant que tel mais sur la
réception de la décision des juges au
niveau politique et puis aussi sur la
réception que cette que cette violence
et que cette révolte finalement peut
avoir sur le gouvernement et sur la
suite du processus législatif bien sûr
que quoi qu'il en soit quand est-ce que
la loi a le plus de chance d'être
promulgué on l'a dit à l'état adoptée à
l'Assemblée nationale la question c'est
de savoir si le Conseil constitutionnel
la valide ou non quelles sont les
options en fonction de la de la décision
des sages quand est-ce que cette loi
peut entrer en oeuvre alors si il y a
une censure totale et bien il faut tout
recommencer à zéro s'il y a une censure
partielle le gouvernement et le
président peuvent donc considérer que la
loi tronquée des dispositions qui auront
été censurées par le Conseil
constitutionnel peut suivre son cours et
ce qui se passe dans ces cas-là ce sera
pareil d'ailleurs en cas de conformité
totale c'est que il y a un compte à
rebours en réalité qui est lancé pour le
président de la République c'est
l'article 10 de notre const qui nous dit
qu'il y a 15 jours pour promulguer donc
de toute façon à l'issue d'une décision
du Conseil constitutionnel il y a
toujours ce délai de 15 jours alors
tronquer des quelques jours avant la
saisine mais là ils ont été très rapide
donc il reste à peu près 14 jours et
bien dans lequel le président est si
l'on en croit au moins la rédaction du
texte de la Constitution tenue de
promulguer encore une fois on a dit une
loi promulguée n'est pas forcément une
loi appliquée il y a encore une place
pour le dialogue mais ça c'est une
démarche politique c'est pas une
démarche juridique merci beaucoup
anne-charlen beezina
constitutionnaliste et maître de
conférence en droit public on continue
bien sûr de suivre cette actualité
autour des des retraites attentivement
avec en ligne de mire 7 décisions donc
du Conseil constitutionnel vendredi 14
mai prochain il y aura également
peut-être une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation et de manifestations le 13
mai et nous serons bien sûr sur le pont
pour vous faire vivre cette journée pour
ce qui est de la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui bien sûr on reste attentif
à ce qu'il se passe et puis si jamais il
y a des éléments significatifs nous
serons là bien sûr pour vous faire vivre
cette actualité merci en tout cas de
nous avoir suivi tout au long de
l'après-midi la suite du programme sur
le figarolive c'est avec Alexandre
devecchio esprit libre à 20h ses invités
ce soir le sociologue Mathieu bocoté qui
débattra avec l'historien et essayer
Nicolas Baverez vous n'oubliez pas juste
avant cela bien évidemment notre nouveau
programme bienvenue en Île-de-France à
19h et puis à 21h vous retrouvez Le
Figaro la nuit animée par Thibault
Gauthier excellente soirée sur le Figaro
life
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi
elle est là elle est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mathématique
[Musique]